[Musique]
bonjour à tous travie de vous retrouver
pour vivre le temps fort de la séance au
sénat les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
dans une heure les sénateurs vont
interpeller l'exécutif par amy et les
thèmes phares aborder cet après midi
l'offensive turque en syrie ou encore
toute la polémique sur le port du voile
décryptage et réactions avec alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle et alexandre
poussard depuis la salle des conférences
du sénat
à tout à l'heure le défi écologique un
défi démocratique dans le contexte des
mobilisations pour le climat au niveau
international comme nationale comment
associer les citoyens aux décisions en
matière d'environnement
le sénat s'est penché sur ces sujets on
en débat dans un instant enfin le trou
de la sécu fait son retour l'année
dernière le gouvernement nous annoncer
un budget à l'équilibré
ça ne sera finalement pas le cas les
mesures d'urgence pour répondre à la
crise des gilets jaunes sont passés par
là et n'hésitez pas à réagir et à
commenter toute cette émission avec le
hashtag piaget
[Musique]
et on va tout de suite rejoindre alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat
dans une heure maintenant vont commencer
les questions d'actu et à liste il y a
deux sujets qui se détache et witam deux
sujets vont dominer ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement l'offensive
turque en syrie et la polémique autour
du port du voile lors des sorties
scolaires alors polémique déclenchée
vendredi dernier par un élu
rassemblement national au conseil au
sein du conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté
les sénateurs de droite et de gauche
s'opposer vont interpeller le
gouvernement à ce sujet à noter tout de
même tam l'absence de certains membres
du gouvernement
cet après midi notamment celle du
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian et de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur en raison du conseil franco
allemand
merci merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes
ces explications et dont va maintenant
aborder bien le premier thème de cette
émission
dans un contexte marqué par les récentes
mobilisations pour le climat au niveau
international comme nationale comment
associer les citoyens aux décisions qui
touchent à l'environnement
on en débat dans un instant avec nos
invités mais d'abord zoom sur deux
visages de cette mobilisation citoyenne
en matière environnementale activisme
d'un côté convention citoyenne pour le
climat de l'autre
marion vigreux le 5 octobre dernier
alors que certains prennent place dans
l'hémicycle du palais d'iéna pour le
deuxième jour de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat d'autres envahissent le
centre commercial italie 2
ce jour là deux modes d'action bien
différents se font face pour une cause
pourtant commune l'urgence climatique
avec l'occupation d'italie 2 puis de la
place du châtelet le grand public
découvre extinction rebellyon un
mouvement social écologiste non violents
portés par des militants et des citoyens
ils prônent la désobéissance civile pour
inciter les gouvernements à l'action
pour eux l'heure n'est plus à la
transition douce
[Musique]
on n'est plus en train dire non mais ça
va aller la science va nous sauver et
c'est non on voit les chiffres on voit
les faits par une greta le dis aussi en
fait c'est il faut déclarer l'urgence
ce mouvement est spontané al'inverse la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
institutionnalisée mise en place par le
gouvernement à l'issue du grand débat
national elle doit incarner la
démocratie participative en matière
d'écologie
nous avons besoin de vous pour définir
des mesures qui nous permettent de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'au moins 40% 150 citoyens tirés
au sort vont donc participer à six
week-ends de travail entouré d'experts
et de juristes le fait que ce soit
médiatisée par les personnes qui sont
choisis
également ça mettra un petit coup de
pression pour vraiment trouver des
solutions qui vont permettre de donner
peut-être naissance à des lois les
conclusions seront présentées au
parlement en janvier 2020 en attendant
un constat s'impose si les uns
bénéficient de l'oreille attentive du
gouvernement les autres et malgré
l'essor de la mobilisation peine encore
à se faire entendre et on va débattre de
cette question de l'engagement citoyen
en matière environnementale avec nos
invités j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur
ce plateau guillaume chevrollier bonjour
jour vous êtes sénateur les républicains
de la mayenne membre de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable vous êtes co
organisateur d'un colloque qui s'est
tenu lundi au sénat sur la biodiversité
et l'engagement des collectivités merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous également sur
ce plateau jean luc fichet bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste du
finistère et membre de la commission des
lois également avec nous en tonnes
bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre
d'extinction rébellion on va en parler
et on va dire expliquer ce que c'est et
enfin sur ce plateau mathilde immer
bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre du
comité de gouvernance de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat cette convention
qui émanent d'ailleurs des suites du
grand débat alors tout d'abord on l'a vu
lors de ce sujet il ya d'un côté
l'activisme de l'autre il ya la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
ce que ce sont deux visages de la
mobilisation citoyenne opposés ou au
contraire complémentaires pour vous maty
deamer qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
ans militante écologiste en même temps
que membre du comité de gouvernance pour
moi c'est évidemment une articulation à
trouver une complémentarité
cette convention citoyenne 150 citoyens
tirés au sort ça ne mènera à rien si ça
reste entre les murs du ce1 débat fermé
au sens économique social et
environnemental exactement par contre si
ça sort et qu'il ya des mouvements quel
qu'il soit écologiste
il ya aussi dans le monde de
l'entreprise qu'il ya aussi des débats
dans les associations qu'il ya aussi des
débats parlementaires et d'élus
là on a une vraie vie démocratique qui
permet d'avoir un véritable impact et un
élan citoyen dans la société et que
cette convention aboutissent à des
choses qui sont concrètes et qui ont un
retentissement réel et qui passent dans
des lois donc une fonction qu une
convention qui est utile que si on passe
à l'action à ce que vous êtes d'accord
là dessus en automne vous
quel regard vous portez justement sur
cette convention qui émane du grand
débat qui constitue un an disait 250
citoyens tirés au sort mais finalement
ceux qui ont décidé de participer pour
la plupart sont intéressés par
l'environnement peut-être plus que quand
même la moyenne des citoyens et qui
doivent plancher sur des mesures à
prendre pour que la france satisfaite
finalement ses objectifs en matière de
réduction d'émissions de co2 je crois
qu'il ya pas d opposition franche entre
les entre les deux manières de faire par
contre nous on se positionne la queue
regard assez critique quand même sur le
sur le sujet notamment sur les objectifs
qui sont presque prêts fixé et qui sont
pas travailler par l'assemblée enfin par
la convention en revanche on va suivre
et on a des équipes qui suivent nos kids
l'horizon 2030 c'est ça tu as fait il ya
une petite citation du sommet de la
terre de rio en 92 sur le principe de
précaution dont je vais vous la lire en
cas de risque de dommages graves ou
irréversibles l'absence de certitude
scientifique absolue de dowa ce ne doit
pas servir de prétexte pour remettre à
plus tard l'adoption de mesures
effectives visant à prévenir la
dégradation de l'environnement
aujourd'hui avec un objectif de 40 % en
2030 fin de -40 % en 2030 je crois qu'on
est très très loin de ce principe de
précaution si on en suit simplement les
rapports du giec qui vont aller loin du
compte quoi pour nous on est on est
clairement loin du compte donc fixé un
objectif qui est qui est loin de
finalement de faire face aux menaces
existentielles
dans lesquels on est aujourd'hui c'est
déjà presque signé malheureusement un
échec par contre le le travail
démocratique qu'est ce qui est mis en
place
on le suit avec attention et on en
espère les contribuer c'est ce que vous
dénoncez à travers toutes les actions
que vous faites notamment actuellement
par exemple à paris avec sa nombre de
blocages alors on n'est pas là pour
dénoncer la convention citoyenne en tant
que tel je pense qu'il ya plein d'autres
choses à faire avant voilà non pas la
convention citoyenne mais peut-être le
manque d'ambition du gouvernement c'est
ce que évidemment fait pour le moment
les ambitions parle encore de croissance
je pense que c'est juste un contresens
historique voire un non sens
scientifique par rapport à là où on en
est c'est absolument impossible on n'est
pas là pour juger des discours on est là
pour juger des actes aujourd'hui
l'inaction de l'état et des
gouvernements elle est simplement
criminel regard des millions de morts
que ça près par guillaume chevrollier
alors vous déjà si on reste sur ce type
de mobilisation citoyenne vous êtes
plutôt extinction rébellion ou
convention citoyenne ont peut-être ni
l'un ni l'autre
peut-être les deux je pense que dans le
contexte du moment qui est du
développement de la démocratie
participative que les citoyens
s'investissent davantage dans le débat
public pour porter leurs idées et moi
même en tant qu'élu m'arrive de faire
des consultations et puis on est les
sénateurs sur le terrain au contact de
nos grands électeurs et même au delà des
citoyens donc en contact démocratie
participative oui mais il ya la
démocratie représentative et en tant qu
il eut moi je défends les institutions
est face au défi écologique il faut
faire jouer pleinement les institutions
associées citoyens mais les élus ensuite
ils débattent dans la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et
développement durable
ce matin d'ailleurs nous recevions la
président du design nationale du débat
public et la commission chantal jouanno
voilà il nous revient et d'ailleurs on
recevra dans les prochains jours dans
les prochaines semaines ce qui monte le
le comité citoyen du moment parce que il
faut pas qu'ils aient d'à côté cette
structure et de l'autre côté les
institutions de la république qui ont
leur légitimité démocratique
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble
construire ensemble pour faire partager
un diagnostic et esquisser des solutions
et dialogué mais dans le respect des
institutions et de la démocratie
représentative ça me semble essentiel a
rappelé dans ce débat et vous n'avez pas
parlé d'extinction rébellion qu'est ce
que vous pensez de plus ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'activisme des actions qui
sont un peu plus coup de poing
moi je suis un partisan du respect de la
loi
donc vous pouvez pas être d'accord c'est
ça qu'on nous dit je veux bien des
expressions diverses dans la société
mais dans le respect de la loi et qu'on
n'entrave pas des activités qui sont
autorisés par la loi donc je pense que
on est dans un pays où il ya une
multitude de possibilités d'expression
et on peut s'exprimer d'ailleurs dans le
débat démocratique en se présentant à
des élections en respectant les règles
on se présenter aux élections donc que
ceux qui ont des choses à dire se
présente aux élections
ça tombe bien il y en a régulièrement
france mais effectivement sur le
principe de la désobéissance civile ou
de le faire des blocages ça je n'y suis
pas favorable
jean luc fichet vous votre avis qu'est
ce que vous en pensez déjà sur bien des
formes de mouvements citoyens plus
proche de l'activisme comme l'extinction
rébellion ou de la convention citoyenne
qu'est ce que vous faisiez concerne la
convention citoyenne
écoutez je crois que on est tous un
petit peu observateur de ce qui va se
dire dans cette convention première
c'est une première cette initiative qui
est intéressant je crois que les gens
qui la composent sont divers variés
doigts qu'ils ont commencé leur travail
maintenant la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va faire du produit deux de ses
réflexions là et comment ça va se
traduire dans les faits par des
initiatives qui sont effectivement
importante pour nous tous pour ce qui
concerne après l'extension rébellion
écoutez moi je suis
l'actualité de près je suis comme mon
collègue respectueux de la loi et de
souhaite et demande qu'on la respecte
pour autant on sait très bien que ce
sont des initiatives comme celle là qui
sont non violente qui justement faut
qu'on bouge qu'on évolue sur sur la loi
pour ma part je ne pense pas que cela
remette en cause
l'expression démocratique notre
représentation démocratique mais par
contre ça nous interroge certainement
sur l'urgence écologique qui lie à
aujourd'hui qui est très forte et que
bâle et les jeunes et les moins jeunes
expriment ou d'une manière très très
très pressante ces derniers renvoient un
mouvement plutôt utile vous êtes un peu
sur la ligne 1 de nicolas hulot qui a
démissionné du gouvernement se le
rappelle a notamment parce que sa voix
en matière d'environnement ne portait
pas suffisamment ils ne considèrent pas
lui non plus d'un mauvais oeil ce
mouvement comme extinction rébellion
c'est ce qu'il a dit hier dans le
parisien regardait il dit c'est une
réponse au sentiment de ne pas être
entendus ou plus précisément que le
traitement de la crise est insuffisant
face à l'accélération de l'emballement
des phénomènes
il ajoute je ne prône pas la
désobéissance civile mais je ne juge pas
non plus ceux qui l'utilisent à
condition qu'elles restent strictement
non violente
à chacun sa méthode anton et bien vous
avez donc voilà un allié parmi l'une des
voix qui porte sur la question
environnementale en france oui je crois
que s'il a démissionné du gouvernement
c'est bien parce que malheureusement la
voie institutionnelle aujourd'hui la
voie de la démocratie représentative
comme elle est pensée elle a prouvé son
échec à traiter ces questions là on a 40
ans de retard réellement pour éviter les
millions de morts autour le fait face je
rappelle simplement une étude
j'en cite une mais il y en a énormément
des défunts de la production du savoir
scientifique il ya 76 % des insectes
volants qui ont décliné en moyenne dans
les dernières 27 années il faut savoir
que 70 % notre agriculture dépend de la
pollinisation par les insectes
je sais pas si vous êtes fort en
mathématiques mais moi je vais être papa
dans deux mois ça fait dans moins de dix
ans en gros on a un déclin des insectes
et on perd 70 % de notre alimentation
j'ai sincèrement envie que d'avoir
quelque chose à manger d'avoir quelque
chose à donner à mes enfants et je pense
que ça c'est le c'est juste le k2
tout le monde donc je veux bien et on
est on est absolument pour la démocratie
si on regarde nos revendications notre
troisième c'est de réparer la démocratie
c'est juste demande de trouver une
légitimité par là par contre il faut
fixer des objectifs rapport à ce qui est
nécessaire et malheureusement
aujourd'hui les institutions comme l ont
été fondés les gouvernements comme lui
comme il travaille aujourd'hui on
pouvait leur échec à résoudre ces
questions là jeu justement je vous faire
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit chantal jouanno
qui a donc été auditionné ce matin par
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire ça résonne avec ce que vous
venez de dire elle dit grosso modo s'il
ya une participation citoyenne il faut
absolument que ce soit 6 suivie d'une
action sinon et bien ça discrédite
l'ensemble il faut qu'il y ait une
coordination entre les deux écoutez la
mon rôle c'est de dire terminer
maintenant les procédures de
participation autour de ce sujet le
temps est à la décision
le temps n'est plus à la participation
et c'est vrai que la participation n'a
de sens d'existence et de légitimité que
si elle est suivie par la décision
c'est à dire qu on est dépendants les
uns des autres complètement dépendant
jamais la participation ne peut
remplacer la décision ce n'est pas une
décision en soi la participation c'est
un éclairage de la décision mais s'il
n'y a pas décision après prêts sur la
base de cette participation
on est nous mêmes discréditer hilmar oui
pour le coup c'est une parole qui fait
consensus mathilde et marie laborde en
sus
et c'est même une des lignes rouges
parce que séné dans le cadre du grand
débat mais ça a été poussé par des
collectifs citoyens les jeux les
citoyens inspiré notamment de travaux
d'extinction de révéler à newquay qui
porte cette proposition d'assemblées
citoyennes depuis un bouton qui est en
train de le mettre en place également en
grande bretagne la ligne rouge qu'on
avait c'était de dire dans le cas du
grand débat n'y avait pas d'engagement
sur la suite des propositions
si on va sur cette convention citoyenne
il ya une condition c'est un engagement
qui a été pris par le président de la
république et le gouvernement 2 sans
filtre soumettre les propositions qui
sont issus de cette convention citoyenne
au parlement à la voie réglementaire
direct ou à la voie référendaire et vous
y croyez vous pensez que sincèrement ça
va aboutir jusque là pour vous pour
l'instant que j'y crois mais sont à
éviter c'est à dire que j'ai aussi
une certaine méfiance et on l'a vu les
150 citoyens tirés au sort ont même une
certaine méchanceté des questions qu'ils
ont posées le même auprès du ministre il
est vraiment alizés dans une opération
de communication exactement néanmoins
garnements néanmoins quand on regarde
les exemples à l'international on voit
que ça marche en irlande une question
sociétale comme la question de
l'avortement a été adopté par un tel
processus suivi d'un référendum
c'est vrai aussi là avec la voie
parlementaire on voit que ça peut
fonctionner ensemble ou des mesures sur
les questions écologiques en irlande sur
cette même assemblée citoyenne sont
maintenant transmises par le trans
pardon traduite par le parlement en loi
donc on voit là que vraiment il ya une
articulation à trouver entre les
différentes formes de démocratie qui
existe qui est possible on a des
exemples à l'international on a une
demande forte et moi sur l'objectif
parce que je pense que scania en donne
est primordial l'objectif de 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
celui qui aujourd'hui dans la loi dans
la lettre de mission de cette convention
citoyenne
on a au moins 40% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et dès le premier
week-end de la convention on a vu les
150 citoyens tirés au sort mettre en
cause est-ce que 40% ça suffit et ce
qu'il faut que sur ceux au moins enjoué
qu'on aille plus loin
quel est le lien entre l'empreinte
carbone les émissions importés et donc
ils sont en train de questionner ce
mandat et donc la porte la parole dans
tonnes dans la rue qui dit ça ne suffit
pas comme objectif est bien les écouter
et il ya une résonance dans cette
convention donc j'espère on verra ce
qu'il en sorte que les citoyens qui sont
souverains irons plus loin et auront les
objectifs qui sont cohérents avec ce que
disent les scientifiques
j'aimerais juste rajouter si je puis me
permettre que c'est pas juste une parole
qui est porté dans la rue c'est une
parole qui est porté dans la plupart des
rapports scientifiques qui s'accumulent
depuis des décennies nous on fait juste
valoir ça et on se base uniquement sur
des études scientifiques
oui effectivement faut pour avancer sur
ces sujets je crois qu'on va partager
des objectifs sans doute que c'est la
manière dont on approuve quelques mois
comment elle résoudre
moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas le faire
sans démocratie bien assise et par
paliers parce que attention à ce que à
un moment donné à prendre d'initiatives
trop brutale on est des effets inverses
parce que il ya des choses qui existent
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont bien d'autres
qui vont moins bien d'autres qui vont
très mal
il faut les faire les faire évoluer
parce que on partage les mêmes objectifs
mais pour autant on a aussi le temps qui
est un maître reiki
qu'il faut tenir parce que on risque de
mettre en difficulté une grande partie
de nos de nos citoyens et qui sont sans
doute ceux qui auraient plus intérêt à
profiter dans le temps justement de nos
initiatives mais je vais pas les mettre
en difficulté cela guillaume chevrollier
pour prendre un exemple un peu vraiment
concret par exemple la question de
projet d'aménagement du territoire il en
a été question lundi lors de votre
colloque sur la biodiversité
comment est-ce qu'on a joué on
aujourd'hui on associe pour vous les
citoyens les riverains on les consulte
et puis comment en se tient compte de
leur avis parce que il ya eu comme
beaucoup de polémiques sur des projets
d'aménagement qui ne plaisait pas du
tout aux gens qui étaient autour et pas
seulement parce que le défi c'est
l'acculturation aux problèmes
environnementaux c'est d'ailleurs
l'objectif de ce colloque s'est montré
qu'on partage l'objectif de préservation
et de reconquête de la biodiversité et
comme tous ici autour de la table je
suis naturellement favorable à ce qu'on
améliore notre environnement pour nous
mêmes et puis pour nos enfants
ça c'est évident et donc l'objectif
c'est de démontrer aussi qu' on peut
respecter et différents modes
d'expression mais je pense que il faut
pas faire preuve de catastrophisme par
rapport la situation faut partager un
diagnostic est démontrée et c'était le
sens de ce colloque que les
collectivités locales qui sont des
acteurs de terrain en grande partie sont
déjà mobilisés pour préserver et
reconquérir la biodiversité par des
actions concrètes notamment dans le une
compétence forte des collectivités qui
est l'urbanisation la gestion de l'eau
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols saas et les collectivités et quand
vous avez des élus qui sont sensibles à
ces questions là qui ont une autre
approche dans la conduite de projets et
bien ça fait résonance avec les
préoccupations des citoyens qui sont à
la fois soucieux de leur environnement
mais qui veulent aussi avoir un logement
donc voilà c'est fait il revient après
aux politiques d'arbitré d
l'injonction qui peuvent être
contradictoires mais moi je pense que
sur ce sujet de l'environnement
cette loi est un sujet qui doit
rassembler les français dans une société
aujourd'hui qui est profondément nui
divisé pense que les questions autour de
l'environnement sa loi de nature nous
fédérer et nous rassembler le problème
c'est que c'est un sujet qui a aussi
divisé il ya bien sûr le précédent de
notre dame des landes
il ya de très nombreux projets
d'aménagement ou bien aujourd'hui il ya
des à dist qui a protestent contre ce
type d'opération justement alexandre
vous êtes avec gérard longuet dans la
salle des conférences du sénat gérard
longuet il connaît bien ce sujet et ce
problème pour lui d à dist et oui gérard
longuet vous connaissez bien ce problème
des à 17 avec notamment ce projet-ci
geodon d'enfouissement de déchets
nucléaires sur le site de bure dans
votre département dans la meuse vous
avez un peu éviter un nouveau notre dame
des landes
comment ça s'est passé d'abord il ya une
évidente nécessité 58 réacteurs donne à
la france le mix énergétique le plus
décarbonés de l'union européenne mais il
y a des déchats forte activité
villelongue qui sont aujourd'hui stockés
dans des piscines qui devront un moment
ou un autre
sortir de ces piscines car
malheureusement ces déchets sont
dangereux sur des milliers d'années la
solution du stockage en couche
géologique profonde a été retenue ou
plutôt a été étudié pendant une
vingtaine d'années depuis 98
aujourd'hui nous savons que le stockage
en couche géologique profonde est la
solution alors il y à des opposants dans
la population locale
il y à des opposants extérieur ce sont
en général les plus spectaculaires mais
en meuse force est de reconnaître que ce
sont des intermittents de la zad
quelques-uns ont fait le choix de l'est
sur place quelques dizaines sans doute
pas plus de 20 et les autres viennent
l'été lorsqu'il fait beau sur le plateau
barrois alors sur ce projet
d'enfouissement de déchets nucléaires
est ce que la population a été consultée
ce que la démocratie fonctionne et la
démo passer a parfaitement fonctionné
parce que tous les candidats élus dans
les mairies au conseil général et au
conseil départemental aujourd'hui au
conseil régional
moi même comme
sénateurs les députés successifs ont
toujours défendu ce projet et ont été
élus donc il y a une majorité politique
qui accepte le projet ce n'est pas
l'unanimité mais c'est une majorité
politique stable qui est passé de gauche
avec le parti socialiste
à droite avec les républicains
aujourd'hui avec un député centriste
proche du président macron mais il y a
une continuité dans l'engagement en
faveur de ceux qui un stockage en couche
géologique profonde d'accord donc une
des communes démocratie environnementale
qui passe par les élus qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces nouvelles formes
d'écologie citoyenne même institutionnel
avec cette conférence citoyenne pour le
climat qui a été lancée dans le guardian
il y a toujours eu je n'ai conférence de
citoyens des réunions ceux qui ont lancé
cela d'ailleurs ce sont en général les
grandes entreprises qui produisent des
biens de consommation grand public qui
teste des parfums qui teste des produits
agroalimentaires qui teste des vêtements
ou qui teste des solutions techniques
pour l'automobile il se trouve que le
gouvernement a voulu tester
l'environnement j'ai plutôt tendance à
faire confiance aux professionnels
j'ai plutôt tendance comme président de
l'office parlementaire a considéré que
les parlementaires ont des données
scientifiques sous la main s'il ya des
bonnes idées pourquoi ne pas les écouter
les écouter mais la décision nous
appartient très bien la décision vous
appartient merci gérard longuet pour
votre témoignage
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
intervention mathilde il meurt alors
vous entendez chara longue et lui dit la
démocratie a fonctionné par de la
démocratie représentative et il est
assez dubitatif par rapport est bien au
comité citoyen et on imagine aussi
vis-à-vis d'extraction rébellion vu les
mots qu'il a pu avoir à l'égard par
exemple donné à dire tous des
manifestants dans leur ensemble
moi je pense qu'il faut pas opposer à
nouveau on voit que la démocratie
représentative
elle l'a elle connaît aujourd'hui une
crise quand on voit le nombre
d'abstentions d'élection en élection
quand on voit la montée du populisme y
compris les élus sont inquiets sur la
situation
la démocratie participative et a
fortiori la démocratie délibérative tout
comme on voit là on la voit aujourd'hui
dans la convention citoyenne vient
compléter donne une note légitimité
au processus de démocratie
représentative on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation où la population à un
niveau d'éducation beaucoup plus élevés
qu'auparavant sur à l'habitude
d'internet et de pouvoir interagir
donner son avis donc pourquoi se priver
de nouveaux outils qui peuvent être
pertinents ce qui me semble important
quand même dans ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est que sur les projets
d'aménagement local c'est pas forcément
là où je suis moins la plus pertinente
néanmoins il me semble que consulter les
citoyens qui vivent sur le territoire et
pas seulement les industriels ou les
élus est extrêmement important dans le
cadre de projets industriels et on voit
un certain nombre de lieux de région
parle pas que de bureau je connais assez
mal le cas de ben hur ou finalement il
n'ya pas se forme de consultation est
donc derrière comme il n'y a pas
d'autres moyens de se faire entendre
il ya des formes de deux ânes
il ya une répression policière parfois
illégitime qui a aussi lieu dans un
certain nombre de ces contrées là donc
il ya un an je pense à avoir une bonne
part spéciaux citoyenne pour que chacun
ait sa place et que le problème du coût
est une forme qui correspondent à l'envi
des citoyens et des élus sur le
territoire jean luc richer oui je pense
que ce qui est dit da est tout à fait
intéressant et important c'est que la
démocratie participative est essentiel
aujourd'hui dans la manière de mieux
gouverner de mieux conduire des projets
au sein des collectivités quelles
qu'elles soient pour autant il ya quand
même un moment donné où il faut arriver
la décision il faut décider et puis il
faut organiser faut structurer et puis
il faut agir pour arriver à un résultat
est donc la démocratie participative
assad enrichissant c'est que elle fait
qu'aujourd'hui les décisions on les
prend plus de la même manière nous
enrichit plus de la même manière mais
pour autant il faut décider donc ça veut
dire qu'il va à un moment donné faire
des comptes en et des pas contents
justement guillaume chevrollier vous en
tant qu'élu en tant que parlementaire
est ce que vous diriez que ces
mobilisations
tout cela ça a joué sur votre façon de
de considérer ce genre de sujet par
exemple on entend edouard philippe ou
emmanuel macron qui disent vas nous on
est des convertis quand même de la
dernière arme et ça nous empêche pas
d'être aussi motivés que les premiers
convertis à la cause environnementale
qu'est ce que vous en dites
je n'ai entre qui lui forcément l écoute
des citoyens et ses mouvements et comme
la jeune adolescente quand attenberg
voilà est là elle identifie une
génération de jeunes la marche pour le
climat s'identifient à cette jeune
personne pour porter une cause qui les
préoccupent
donc moi je les ai rencontrés dans mon
département c'est on est à l'écouté
redit qu' on n'est pas sans agir
et après ils sont très inquiets et ne
veut pas ni des éléments scientifiques
des données sur de la perte de
biodiversité qui peuvent être inquiétant
mais pour autant ça ne doit pas
paralyser l'action et dire qu'il n'ya
pas de solution non il y en a beaucoup
il faut donc évidemment ça le fait
qu'ils aient ces mobilisations et avec
cette large médiatisation crée forcément
une influence politique mais pour autant
je suis au développement durable depuis
un certain temps je l'étais auparavant
dans une autre assemblée
c'est un sujet sur lequel je suis
investi depuis longtemps et c'est pas
l'actualité qui me positionne sur ce
ciel vous êtes assez positif sur une
figure comme greta tonnes d'algues on a
bien entendu aussi les critiques de
toute une partie de la classe politique
à l'égard de cette image qui l'ont
regardé aussi de hauts etc
je pense que c'était pas la bonne
méthode mais après il faut c'est bien
qu'ils aient encore une fois partie de
la population s'identifient à cette
personne mais après il nous revient de
décider et c'est pas elle non plus de
dicter des autorisations mais il faut
pas nier qu'elles aient une influence
faut la respecter comme je respecte les
citoyens qui s'exprime avec différents
modes d'expression mais j'attends aussi
que chacun respecte les institutions et
moi je pense que pour régler les
problèmes de notre pays
faut faire jouer pleinement les
institutions mêmes on le voit on crée à
l'issue du grand débat des nouvelles
structures
je pense que si on fait jouer pleinement
toutes les institutions et toutes les
strates politique que dans notre pays
ça peut créer l'apaisement que ceux qui
veulent agir et comme nous ici
l'assemblée des territoires
l'action je le répète se fait au niveau
local il ya des élections locales que
les citoyens s'engagent
parce qu'en plus on est dans une crise
du civisme et il ya des gens qui
s'engagent moins dans les conseils bien
allez-y
engagez-vous et portez vos sujets et
puis passer devant le suffrage universel
comme ça ça donnera une de la vivacité
dans les débats et sa revitalisera la
démocratie locale et la démocratie
représentative
sans la l'opposé à la démocratie
participative
anton qu'est ce que vous pensez de ses
discours ses discours qu'ils sont quand
même tous positifs envers
l'environnement etc
tout le monde est d'accord sur l'idée
générale d'ailleurs par les mots mais
d'ailleurs on le voit quand on passe au
niveau du citoyen au niveau individuel
tout le monde n'est pas prêt à faire les
efforts ou les sacrifices n'ont plus que
ça requiert on a vu aussi par exemple et
bien le mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
depuis tout c'est moi qui disent bon
nous on n'était pas opposé à
l'environnement mais on n'est pas prêt
on mais on fait passer notre fin du mois
avant la fin du monde qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous il ya aussi ce regard là
du côté des citoyens
ouais je reviendrai juste trente
secondes sur ce que sur ce qui est dit
sénateurs à ma droite dont jean
guillaume chevrollier gelé mois cela dit
faut pas céder au catastrophisme je
crois qu'on cède pas au catastrophisme
on a un regard éclairé sur les données
scientifiques et encore une fois je vous
invite à lire les rapports scientifiques
si seulement vous les lisez je ne sais
pas comment comment on peut dire ça si
on lit vraiment ces rapports là
aujourd'hui ils sont catastrophiste ils
sont catastrophiste les données
auxquelles on fait face met en péril la
survie d'une grande partie de l'humanité
ce les scientifiques qui nous le disent
c'est pas moi en tant que citoyen même
si je suis passionné de science c'est
pas la question
après s'il faut poser fin du mois et fin
du monde si dans dix ans personne mange
je rappelle que de paris ces trois jours
d'autonomie alimentaire je pense que la
question n est pas tellement là bien
évidemment qu'on veut qu'on veut une
lutte sociale et écologique en même
temps et c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
reparler démocratie avec des assemblées
qui sont garantes d'une transition juste
équitable
si on peut le rappeler pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale en angleterre le
rationnement a permis une bien plus
grande équité et égalité dans la
répartition des biens et des services
dans la société
alors voilà on peut on peut débattre de
plein de choses là je m'exprime à titre
individuel mais je pense que c'est très
très très important aujourd'hui et c'est
même fondamental pour notre survie et on
en est là aujourd'hui malheureusement
parce que les institutions n'ont
toujours pas résolu
on fait des beaux discours et bien
évidemment que personne va dire devant
caméra ou même devant tout le monde
qu'on est opposés à l'environnement
c'est une certitude mais aujourd'hui les
discours n'ont pas suffi et je suis
désolé les institutions en place et les
voies traditionnelles partisane avec des
parties ont montré que ça n'a pas marché
ça n'a simplement pas marché nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui d'une mobilisation et
des citoyens et citoyennes se lève dans
plus de 70 pays entre en résistance
parce que nos gouvernements font une
action qui est criminel façon continue
malgré les engagements donnés à la
combientième de coop malgré les
engagements internationaux lé sommet
macro et champion de la terre quand même
oui ça n'a toujours rien changé les
émissions de carbone continue année
après année d'augmenter les pbs en mai
je terminerais là-dessus 10 pbs forme et
nous a quand même confirmé qu'on était
rentré dans la sixième extinction de
masse depuis les débuts de la vie sur
terre
voilà ta mère siens votre discours en
tout cas apporté à porter sur ce plateau
en présence d'élus de parlementaires
vous le voyez et justice sociale et
écologique ne sont pas forcément
incompatibles
en tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir tous
participé à ce débat merci guillaume
chevrollier merci jean luc fichet merci
anton et merci beaucoup match il y meurt
d'avoir participé à cette discussion
on va passer au deuxième thème de cette
émission le trou de la sécu qui est de
retour hier soir agnès buzyn la ministre
des solidarités de la santé et le
secrétaire d'état olivier du soft ont
présenté le budget de la sécurité
sociale 2020 au coeur des discussions
le financement de la sécurité sociale et
le financement des mesures d'urgence
pour les gilet jaune retour de suite sur
cette audition avec michael spitzberg
il était annoncé le voile a reporté au
prochain quinquennat il faudra attendre
2023 pour voir le fameux trou de la sécu
se résorber en attendant les comptes de
la couverture sociale françaises
repartent dans le rouge pour atteindre
5,1 milliards d'euros en 2020 soit son
niveau de 2010 est en cause des
hypothèses économiques trop favorable
qui n'ont pas été confirmées et donc des
recettes en baisse mais également les
mesures dites de pouvoir d'achat
décidée par le président de la
république pour répondre à la crise et
gilet jaune
une enveloppe de quelque 17 milliards
d'euros pour 2019 et 2020 dont le
gouvernement a décidé d'en faire
supporter une partie à la sécurité
sociale
nous avons souhaité nous avons inscrit
dans ce plfss la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale d'un certain nombre de
mesures d'urgence économique et social
sur la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires ou encore un certain
nombre de modifications autour du taux
de csg
lorsqu'on regarde le coût des mesures
annoncées à l'issue du grand débat ou
pour répondre à l'urgence économique et
social nous atteignons 17 milliards
d'euros dont 14 sont prises en charge
directement par l'état
un principe de non compensations qui
passe mal vous remettez en cause ce qui
est pour nous un principe majeur qui ce
qui a permis donc un autre ce qui est
social d'être pérennisé et qui devrait
permettre de le devenir de le demeurer
l'état se doit de compenser tous les
allègements de cotisations sociales
qu'ils se décident alors ce n'est pas
une mesure technique
c'est un choix politique dont vous
l'avez dit mama ministre paie l'effet
cesse c'est un choix politique qui rompt
avec ce principe d'autonomie et de
financement exclusif pour la sécurité
sociale
une crainte aussi partagé à l'assemblée
nationale hier les députés de la
commission des affaires sociales ont
adopté des amendements pour supprimer le
transfert de charges de l'état vers la
sécurité sociale au sénat le plfss sera
examiné à partir du 6 novembre et j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
pour débattre de la sécurité sociale
michel amiel bonjour je les adore la
république en marche
ainsi que victor là ce n'est un bon jour
jaunâtre is socialiste alors d'abord
michel amiel il y a un an vous pavoiser
enfin le gouvernement pavoiser on nous
disait même que le budget de la sécu
serait en excédent que s'est il passé
ah oui c'est passé deux choses puisque
effectivement on va avoir un déficit un
trou importé l'expression habituelle de
5 milliards sans les les indices
macroéconomiques comme l'on dit qu'ils
ont moins bon que ce que l'on espérait
donc l'apparition entre optimistes
doublé ses 55 moitié moitié
parce que je vais appeler les faits je
les fais gilet jaune qui a consenti une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat et qui
je le rappelle au niveau du parlement
était quand même voté à l'unanimité
voilà pour répondre très concrètement ce
qui s'est passé alors victoire jasmin
la gauche a dénoncé le fait que l'on
creuse déficit dès qu'on revient à
l'équilibré qu'est ce que ça signifie
pour vous eh bien ça signifie que le
gouvernement était en lévitation ne
connaissait pas la vraie vie et que ce
gouvernement qui a fait un certain
nombre d'annoncés s'est très vite rendu
compte que la politique qui était mené
jusque là et bien n'était pas compatible
avec les besoins des français et avec
l'intégralité des français
particulièrement les personnes qui
vivent au quotidien dans des situations
difficiles
donc d'où la prise d gilet jaune et
aujourd'hui on a bien vu que le chef de
l'état à la fin de l'année 2018 il a
pris un certain nombre de mesures et
qu'il n'a pas anticipé parce qu'il
croyait qu'il avait tout bon il a fait
un certain nombre d'annoncés et il ya eu
un rétro pédalage et on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui donc entre les annonces
qu'il a faites et la réalité de la vraie
vie on se rend compte aujourd'hui que ce
gouvernement avait vraiment le conte
problème on va rappeler un d'ailleurs
ces mesures d'urgence un des gilets
jaunes il y a eu et bien à l'annulation
de la hausse de la csg pour les petites
retraites il y a eu la prime
exceptionnelle versée par les
entreprises qui est exonérée de
cotisations sociales et qui est
d'ailleurs prolongée en 2020 et puis à
part milad les mesures il ya aussi la
suppression des cotisations salariales
sur les heures supplémentaires
michel amiel vous entendez victor jasmin
elle dit vous étiez en lévitation
vous n'aviez pas compris mais à toutes
ces mesures de justice sociale qui était
réclamée par les français oui je veux
pas taquiner ma collègue mais je
rappelle qu'elle est au ps et d'hommes
qu'elle soutenait le gouvernement
précédent avec madame touraine que les
résultats n'étaient pas extraordinaire
non plus non il faut admettre un moment
donné que le trou de la sécu ne va pas
pouvoir être comblés par des mesurettes
et que si on aboutit pas un moment donné
et à des réformes de structure et je
suis pas sûr que les français les voeux
il faut appeler un chat un chat et à des
changements de comportement ou je dis
bien des changements de comportement
on pérennise aura le trou de la sécurité
sociale je voudrais quand même rappeler
connaît le seul pays je parle de pays
modernes à avoir une dette sociale
c'est le seul pays monsieur migaud de la
cour des comptes le rappelait la semaine
dernière c'est pas négligeable donc vous
appelez un véritable changement de
modèle michel amiel oui vous voyez
regardez justement ce que dit l'ancien
secrétaire d'état au budget christian
eckert il a donné une interview il ya
quelques jours un magazine il a dit ils
veulent tuer la sécu c'est là les propos
de christian eckert qui rajoute le
gouvernement veut faire la preuve que le
système n'est pas viable
si le gouvernement supprime des recettes
de la sécurité sociale dès qu'elle
revient à l'équilibré et la met ainsi
dans le rouge ce n'est pas la peine
d'avoir fait polytechnique pour
comprendre qu'ils veulent changer de
système u par la fin ça vous fait
sourire évidemment bien évidemment parce
que le gouvernement et je viens
d'entendre ce que dit mon problème je
peux comprendre mais j'ai soutenu parce
qu'on est dans un principe de solidarité
et nous avons de vrais écarts entre les
personnes qui cotisent et des personnes
qui malheureusement ne peuvent pas
cotisé donc il ya eu la cmu la cmu c
on peut on peut quand même comprendre
qu'il veuille à un moment donné réformer
mais pas de n'importe quelle manière est
pas un mais connaissant la voir la vraie
vie des citoyens la vraie vie des
entreprises et la vraie vie des
personnes âgées particulièrement des
personnes à la retraite dont place au
gouvernement a fait des erreurs à faire
un rétropédalage
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à des
difficultés et les annonces qui ont été
faites par le gouvernement est
pratiquement le président de la
république le nom et dont bien compte
que c'est hors de question aujourd'hui
d'avoir cet équilibre voulu et admis par
oew par sept majeur donc vous le voulez
pas l' équilibre où l'on l'équilibré pas
ne pas au détriment des français j'avais
raison mais à quel prix
l'orgue est d'accord mais à quel prix -
des français mais comment on fait donc
il falloir il va falloir un moment donné
en tout cas vous avez été en lévitation
vous avez ignoré à manger les petits
chanteurs mais c'est une autre histoire
mais alors aujourd'hui il va falloir
probablement prendre un certain nombre
de mesures mais pas de n'importe quelle
manière et lesquels parce que les
lesquels on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
nous avons qu'un quart d'heure et et en
débattre mais je crois qu'il est
important que le gouvernent
on se rende compte de la réalité de
notre pays et se rendre compte de la
réalité du quotidien des français et
particulièrement des personnes qui
vivent dans des situations de précarité
justement c'est un texte qui intervient
dans un contexte tendu pour l'hôpital
hier agnès buzyn a défendu les mesures
qu'elle prend pour l'hôpital public lors
de son audition devant les sénateurs on
l'écouté on en parle juste après ce
gouvernement et vous l'avez votée
l'année dernière a augmenté pour la
première fois le budget de l'hôpital
public tarifs hospitaliers
depuis dix ans donc nous avons inversé
la tendance par rapport au budget
hospitalier des dix dernières années et
j'ai pris un engagement cette année de
faire aussi bien au moins aussi bien en
termes de tarifs hospitaliers donc de
budget pour l'hôpital public
j'ai également annoncé des mesures
spécifiques pour les urgences à hauteur
de 750 millions d'euros en trois ans
dont 80% seront affectés à des
ressources de personnel donc c'est un
budget qui est essentiellement dédié aux
ressources humaines victoire l'as mars
que c'est un texte à la hauteur pour la
situation de l'hôpital et face notamment
à la situation d urgence qui réclament
plus de moyens
oui alors je dis que c'est peu ambitieux
ou ya de véritables et cohérence parce
que au moment où les urgences sont en
crise partout sur le territoire français
on se rend compte qu'il y à des mesures
pour les gens qui paient pour les soins
qui sont annoncés mais les laboratoires
et là dans la mesure où on ne parle pas
et même les médias ils n'en parlent pas
suffisamment pourtant les laboratoires
qui permet d'avoir un diagnostic
biologique pour contenter le diagnostic
clinique des praticiens hospitaliers et
bien les laboratoires doivent faire des
économies de 105 millions d'euros
alors au moment même où il faut
l'accréditation des laboratoires il faut
la certification des pratiques
il faut aujourd'hui que dans tous les
laboratoires et particulièrement les
laboratoires hospitaliers où ils
travaillent 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 il faut des personnels mais il faut la
qualification du produit ou du matériel
il faut également une amélioration
continue de la qualité et dont le rendu
le rendu en urgence de pratiquement tous
les
jamais donc comment voulez vous que si
le laboratoire alors qu'on demande aux
labos à croix bleue faire des économies
et on diminue parce que madame musée ne
le dit pas mais on diminue la cotation
des examens on diminue la nomenclature
est aujourd'hui les laboratoires seront
en très grande difficulté et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'essentiel
parce que mensah qui veut prendre en
charge ces patients de façon globale et
holistique a besoin de la biologie et de
l'imagerie vous entendez à les critiques
de victoires jacent michel amiel un
critique avec fougue de ce projet de loi
de finances du budget de la sécurité
sociale vous eh bien justement qu'est ce
que vous lui répond il n'est pas la
seule à le critiquer a été totale
ce n'est pas parfait on hérite d'une
situation qui était compliqué faudrait
demander à combien étaient l'ondam
hospitalier vague de madame touraine
s'était pas brial vous le savez très
bien la situation hospitalière conflit
que le fait que l'on prévoit que les
dépenses de santé vont alors augmenté
sur le modem le parti sur la biologie je
sais pas pourquoi vous mais vous avez
posé une question difficile d'y répondre
les urgences 750 millions d'euros si
c'est important ça fait partie de ce que
madame 50 millions d'euros
les urgences ça a été quand même salué
par un certain nombre d'urgentistes bon
monsieur peloux dit non il faut lâcher
les dames c'est ce que disent nos amis
communistes
l'objectif national des dépenses alors
objectif national des femmes d'assurance
maladie c'est forcément très technique
mais c'est le véritable sujet de façon
naturelle
on serait je fais des chiffres europe on
serait à 4 % versus 2,2
3 au niveau des urgences qu'est-ce qui
se passe il ya un problème en amont
c'est à dire avant de rentrer aux
urgences il ya un problème en aval quand
on sort d urgence est le problème si ce
que j'ai suggéré hier soir à l'audition
à madame busin le problème en aval c'est
ce qu'on appelle justement les lits
d'aval
il faut sanctuary sanctuariser des lits
il ne faut pas que les urgences soit
engorgé par des gens qui d'une part
n'ont rien à y faire parce que ce n'est
pas une urgence mais aussi par des gens
dont on ne sait pas quoi faire parce
qu'on n'a pas des lits qui s'appauvrit
et maudite osella tout à fait poser la
question aux urgentistes c'est ce qui
vous diront immédiatement dans les pays
anglo saxons on appelle ça le band
management donc peu importe le mot mais
c'est le vrai sujet vous avez des gens
disent menacés plus d'argent pour
l'hôpital
oui bon ça c'est facile à dire oui c'est
facile à dire qu'on a une dette abyssale
on peut dire il faut continuer à creuser
moi j'ai essayé d'apporter des solutions
véritables pas des solutions d'économies
mais des solutions de structure quand
vous savez que des gens qui passent des
heures entières voire des nuits sur un
brancard parce qu'il n'ya pas de lits
d'aval
non seulement c'est pas bon en terme de
gestion hospitalière bien évidemment
mais ça augmente aussi la morbidité et
la mortalité
c'est des choses qui sont capitales et
ça il faut le faire il ya 40 ans ça se
passait pas comme ça on a on a créé des
ddd des dispositifs qui sont délétères
je crois qu'à un moment donné il faut
les remettre en question mais tu en as
marre oui alors je voudrais d'abord
revenir sur le lab ouattara parce que
mon collègue ce qui est du choix que
j'ai fait de parler de laboratoire
c'est important et c'est capital parce
que les personnes restent très souvent
aux urgences justement parce qu'il faut
des examens complémentaires pour le
diagnostic
la deuxième la deuxième chose les
biologistes seront bientôt y sont vent
debout
ils sont bien ils sont vent debout
contre les mesures qui ont été prises et
la semaine prochaine et lever une 2e v3
24 et bien il y aura une mobilisation
des biologistes
donc il faut quand même prendre en
compte cette demande il faut prendre en
compte aussi toutes ces problématiques
là on ne peut pas faire deux bords de la
lorgnette on peut pas faire comme si
tout était parfait rien n'est parfait et
que ça avait très bien
pardon juste un mot les urgences que la
jauge wam l'argentin il faut les
autonomiser il faut que dans un système
d'urgence comme ça se passe dans les
grands pays anglo saxons ou scandinaves
vouziers les urgences avec tout ce qu'il
faut sur place il n'est pas normal qu'un
test biologique soient traités sur un
même plan d'égalité aux urgences et dans
un service où sa part tendu au lendemain
pareil pour l'imagerie il faut repenser
totalement notre système d'urgence c'est
ce que disent des urgentistes
je rentrais pas plus tard qu'hier je
vous avez bien compris pourquoi je suis
venu c'est ce champ là un beau jeune
homme fait alors eh ben voilà un accord
à la fin de ce dégel merci beaucoup
michel amiel merci c'est beaucoup dr
jasmin je viens d'avoir participé à ce
débat
nous sommes maintenant à un quart
d'heure des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
il commence à avoir du monde qui arrive
dans la salle des conférences du sénat
qui jouxte les mystiques et justement
alexandre vous êtes avec jérôme durain
sénateur socialiste de la saône et loire
il va tout à l'heure interroger le
gouvernement et oui jean bien vous allez
même interrogé le premier ministre sur
les questions de laïcité notamment la
polémique de cette semaine autour du
port du voile des accompagnants
scolaires qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement sur cette question
la question que je vais poser concernant
la laïcité que le racisme en france
moi j'étais à dijon où conseil agen le
jour je suis conseil régional j'ai
assisté aux événements qui finalement
nourrissent cette polémique il pas
question de laïcité il est question
d'une agression à caractère raciste de
menaces à caractère raciste et il y à
des vents mauvais qui souffle dans ce
pays sur cette question donc moi ce que
j'attends du premier ministre est qu'il
nous dise comment le gouvernement compte
agir pour qu'on rétablisse dans ce pays
une forme de concorde républicaine donc
envoya pas de problème de neutralité
religieuse dans tous les lieux publics
dans ces assemblées d'élus
comme c'était le cas dimanche la côte
est pour une fois je suis plutôt
d'accord avec le président de la
république et avec le premier ministre
qui disent que on a une loi qui règle
ces questions et le sujet d'ailleurs si
on s'en tient à ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dernier
ça n'est pas un sujet de défaut
d'application de la loi c'est une
provocation parce qu'on peut faire on
peut régler cette question de plein de
façons différentes on peut dire on fait
une suspension de séance on demande à la
dame de sortir là on a humilié une maman
devant son enfant c'est ça le sujet donc
il ya une libération de la parole
raciste dans ce pays qui est inquiétante
et on peut espérer que l'on puisse dans
ce pays vivre
quelles que soient nos options
religieuses politiques ensemble sur
cette question des accompagnants
scolaires c1 c'est un peu à la liberté
de chaque assemblée plus dessus de
chaque assemblée publique de chaque
directeur d'école et ce qu'il faut pas
légiférer pour clarifier la stir et la
situation même pour l'autoriser non non
faut pas légiférer président de la
république ne disait pas autre chose en
2016 le premier ministre a donné son
avis hier alors je sais que les
républicains ici vont proposer un texte
dans quinze jours moi je n'y suis pas
favorable parce que je pense que c'est
un piège politique
chaque fois qu'on stigmatise chaque fois
qu'on oppose une partie de la communauté
nationale à une autre partie de la
communauté nationale ont créé un conflit
on crée de la difficulté donc si on peut
pour une fois faire le dos rond et s'ils
travaillent ensemble sur ce qui nous
rassemble se respecte et apprendre à se
connaître
c'est peut-être mieux qu'une mauvaise
loi alors pas de stigmatisation mais de
l'autre côté ce qu'il faut également
lutter contre le communautarisme
oui il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme il faut lutter contre le
racisme
il faut redonner des moyens à
l'éducation populaire
il faut que la république regagne ses
lettres de noblesse dans tous les
territoires de ce pays dans les
quartiers et que les gens est envie de
se départir de ces signes d'appartenance
parce que ce sont souvent des signes
d'appartenance davantage communautaire
que religieux donc voilà c'est un sujet
de fond saint sujets culturels
c'est un sujet d'éducation son sujet
républicain c'est sans doute pas un
sujet de voix très bien merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui pour votre témoignage type
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
interview cette intervention et j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir pour commenter
cette séance qui commence dans une
dizaine de minutes jean philippe
derosier bonjour vous êtes
constitutionnaliste professeur de droit
public à l'université de lille ont bien
d'entendre jérôme durain sénateurs
socialistes à propos de tout ce climat
actuel cette polémique
sur le port du voile jean-philippe de
rauzet cette polémique elle pose quand
même une question fondamentale c'est que
met-on derrière le mot de laïcité et
comment est-ce qu'on applique le
principe de laïcité
la réponse est assez simple c'est la
république qui est laïque et c'est à
elle que s'applique donc ce premier
principe en ce sens que elle ne
privilégie aucune religion
elle n'était associée à aucune religion
mais la laïcité va de pair en
particulier dans une république et une
démocratie avec le principe de liberté
de religion compléter si besoin est par
la tolérance et donc l'état est laïque
les agents de l'état ne peuvent pas être
associée une religion donc il est hors
de question que quelques agents de
l'état que ce soit puisse effectivement
porter un signe religieux ou qu'on
puisse l'associer à une religion
pratiquée après dans sa sphère privée il
est libre évidemment d'avoir la foi
qu'ils souhaitent
mais pour ce qui est des usagers du bus
du peuple des citoyens eux peuvent avoir
effectivement la religion qu'ils
entendaient la manifester librement
pourvu que évidemment ça ne trouble pas
l'ordre public la sécurité publique et
le le vivre ensemble dans notre dans
notre république et ce qui est pointé du
doigt actuellement parce que c'est la
source de la polémique c'est les
accompagnateurs scolaire et cette
dame-là de leur statut enfin parce que
d'ailleurs il ya une proposition de loi
du groupe
heller qui se prépare au sénat celle qui
se prépare du côté de l'assemblée et du
côté du sénat le texte stipule que ces
personnes concours au service public de
l'éducation
donc ils cherchent à faire un lien entre
vraiment l'accompagnateur scolaire et
l'école oui oui je vois bien le sens de
tout cela après ce n'est qu'une qu'une
aide il ne concourt pas au service
public parce qu'ils accompagnent les
enfants de façon bénévole ou alors il ya
quelque chose que je n'ai pas compris
lors d'une sortie ils n'ont pas un
statut il y à un endroit et en
particulier en droit administratif
une catégorie qui s'appelle les
collaborateurs occasionnels du service
public mais c'est une catégorie qui ne
s'applique que pour les régimes de
responsabilité effectivement lorsque
quelqu'un près de concours au
fonctionnement d'un service public
et subi un dommage à ce moment là il
peut engager la responsabilité de l'état
en tant que collaborateurs occasionnels
du service public mais là on n'est pas
du tout dans ce cas là on est dans le
cas où il ya une activité encore une
fois bénévole spontanée des deux hauts
fonctionnaires effectivement de l'école
mais qui n'est pas associé à l'école
elle-même pour une sortie est ce que
demain les parents d'élèves
lorsqu'ils sont élus devront plus
manifester non plus leur religion de
quelque façon que ce soit lorsqu'ils
feront des réunions entre eux parce que
en tant que parents d'élèves élus ils
concourraient eux aussi au
fonctionnement d'une république
tout cela me semble aller un petit peu
trop loin dans la garantie du principe
de laïcité est un sujet en tout cas
qu'elle va être largement débattu cet
après-midi lors de cette séance on voit
d'ailleurs arrivé bien le président du
sénat gérard larcher dans la salle des
conférences qui jouxte l'hémicycle alors
que et bien cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement doit
commencer maintenant dans huit minutes
votre regard justement sur est bien ce
que ce sujet pose comme fracture au
niveau de la majorité présidentielle on
voit bien et d'ajustement reconstituer
la fracture droite gauche entre ceux qui
estiment que je ne faut pas avoir
d'accompagnantes de sortie scolaire
voilée et puis les autres qui sont
plutôt du côté de la liberté oui oui ça
c'est cette majorité avec son caractère
hétéroclite et hétérogène le véhicule
depuis le départ et ce n'est pas la
première fois que l'on voit une une
telle fracture émerger on l'a déjà vu au
moment de la loi sur l'immigration
on l'a vu à nouveau avec la discussion
de la loi anti casseurs et alors même
qu'il y avait même des parlementaires de
droite classique qui prenait fait et
cause contre cette loi et donc
effectivement la question de la laïcité
a toujours été un sujet politique
relativement clivant entre la droite et
la gauche
et cette majorité qui cherche à faire le
grand écart entre les deux ne parvient
pas à dépasser cet écart
qui montre bien qu'il est profondément
ancré dans la société politique
française d'ailleurs c'est edouard
philippe
homme de droite qui a tenté de dépasser
ce sujet qui a fermé la porte à une loi
sur les accompagnants scolaires donc
finalement lui aussi a tenté finalement
il a plutôt rejoint les positions et la
proposition de loi de la sénatrice dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure
brignon tout à fait est là a déjà déposé
un amendement qui avait été adopté au
sénat
allant dans ce même sens lors du débat
sur la loi confiance dans l'école école
de la confiance voilà qui avait été
adopté au sénat majorité plutôt
conservatrice et de droite pour
interdire justement aux accompagnants de
manifesté ostensiblement leur leur
religion et c'est la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale au moment du débat
en cmp est donc imposée par la majorité
qui a retoqué comme monty cet amendement
c'est à dire qu'il a supprimée du texte
final effectivement il ne figure pas
dans la loi écoles de la confiance
jean philippe derosier un autre sujet
qui va très largement marqué à cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement il ya plusieurs questions
qui sont prévues sur ce sujet ce sujet
c'est l'offensive turque en syrie est le
sort réservé aux kurdes nos alliés
d'hier contre pêche est ce aussi pour
vous une mise en avant de l'impuissance
européenne sur ce dossier
en quelque sorte oui
c'est d'abord je le pense et je le dis
très fermement la mise en avant de
l'inconscience du président des états
unis parce que je ne sais pas si facile
je ne sais pas s'il mesure est ou non
s'il ne les mesures est pas c'est qu'il
est extrêmement incompétents
s'il mesure est le poids de sa décision
et les conséquences de sa décision
c'est qu'il est totalement inconscient
on savait que le président de turquie
recep tayyip erdogan avait cette volonté
là qu'il ne la mettait pas exécution du
fait de la présence des troupes
américaines
et l'on est donc là il lui a
complètement ouvert la voie l'europe
c'est l'impuissance europe et ça montre
le rien faire tafer est très pro cette
position en effet aimé il y à la
puissance de l'europe il y à
l'impuissance quelque part de l'otan
parce que la turquie demande de l'otan
les états unis sont membres de l'otan
dont elle est paralysée
il y à quelque part aussi le manque de
puissance des nations unies qui elles
aussi sont en partie pas seulement mais
contrôlée par les états unis au sein du
conseil de sécurité et qui donc ne
peuvent pas intervenir et donc en effet
là on est dans une situation dramatique
et sur le plan sur le plan du droit et
sur le plan politique assez préoccupante
parce que la turquie met en avant une
défense d'elle-même mais l'on voit très
clairement qu'en réalité c'est une
guerre d'ingérence et donc que l attaque
là là là les kurdes de syrie tandis que
l'on voit est bien toujours du monde
dans la salle des conférences du sénat
on voit notamment jean-marie bockel en
discussions avec le ministre sébastien
lecornu ainsi que hervé marseille alors
que et bien l'examen du texte sur le
statut de l'élu et le texte engagement à
proximité se poursuit au sénat un tout
ce monde discute en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle le reste du temps toujours
sur ce sujet jean philippe de rosé est
ce que et bien il faut aussi craindre la
résurgence de dèche avec et bien cette
situation internationale ce sont les
mots hier du premier ministre je ne
crois pas qu'on peut craindre qu on
puisse craindre une résurgence de dèche
cardage n'a pas n'a pas disparu des shs
n'existe pas physiquement ce n'est pas
un état
même s'il véhicule le nom de état
islamique mais à la fois ils sont ils
sont partout et sont nulle part dont
qu'ils occupaient effectivement un
territoire pendant un certain temps ce
territoire occupé a été réduit c'était
effectivement une victoire pour les
alliés mais il ça ne veut pas dire que
les personnes qui animent la théorie de
pêche
l'idéologie de neige parce que c'est
d'abord une idéologie elle n'a pas
disparu ces personnes là n'ont pas
disparu il ya eu des morts il ya eu des
arrestations
mais ça n'a pas pour autant fait
complètement disparaître d'âge donc il
ya toujours une présence
effectivement dès lors que l'on
introduit une zone de tension une zone
de conflit eh bien ça alimente cette
idéologie là et il y à craindre des
répercussions et merci beaucoup à jean
philippe desrosiers pour votre éclairage
on va rejoindre tout de suite alexandre
poussard un toujours sur ce même sujet
puisque à votre micro se trouve pierre
laurent le sénateur communiste de paris
qu'il va à lui aussi interpeller le
gouvernement
et oui pierre laurent vous allez poser
une question au gouvernement sur cette
question brûlante de l'offensive turque
en syrie qu'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement français pour stopper cette
crise
ce que j'attends c'est des actes et pas
seulement la condamnation la
condamnation elle est générale en france
l'indignation est très forte il faut des
actes forts de la france pour être
crédible au plan international donc
j'interrogerai le mini sur la nature des
sanctions que nous envisageons contre la
turquie il y à l'embargo des armes mais
ça ne suffit pas il faut descendre sur
économique financière politique et une
action internationale pour ça et il faut
aussi un travail pour obtenir la zone
d'exclusion aérienne qui fasse stopper
les bombardements tueur les
représentants des kurdes demande que la
france finalement remplacent les états
unis comme allié sur le terrain des
kurdes est ce que vous êtes pour une
intervention française en série les les
kurdes nous demandent de l'assistance et
nous demandent de l'aide et nous devons
leur apporter
et nous devons leur apporter et en même
temps la situation la priorité de la
situation c'est d'obtenir l'arrêt de
l'offensive sur parce qu'il ne faut pas
rajouter de la guerre à la guerre dans
une zone où il ya déjà des centaines de
milliers des millions de déplacés et à
nouveau des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont obligées de fuir
on ne sait où donc il faut arrêter le
malheur dans cette région et en priorité
stopper l'offensive que turque et si on
n'arrive pas à stopper cette offensive
vous êtes pour fournir des armes et il
ne faut pas dire qu'on va y arriver
justement l'action la vallée doit être
conséquente et il faut de parler avec
tout le monde pour l'obtenir c'est ça la
priorité
très bien merci beaucoup pierre laurent
et on va écouter tout de suite votre
question au gouvernement on va se
diriger dans la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat avec alice bardot
qui va vous présenter le menu de ces
questions d'actualité oui alors
justement alexandre l'enfance yves turc
en série fera l'objet de près d'un tiers
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement cet après midi plusieurs
sénateurs de tous bords politiques se
sont emparés du sujet et c'est jean
claude requier pour le groupe
rds
qui ouvrira la séance il y aura
également des questions au sujet du port
du voile lors des sorties scolaires et
notamment une question posée par la
sénatrice lr jacqueline eustache brinio
dont la proposition de loi pour
interdire le port du voile le port par
nom des signes religieux aux
accompagnants d'élèves entre autres va
être examiné au sénat le 29 octobre
prochain
alors ce matin le président du sénat
gérard larcher a appelé à voter cette
proposition de loi une position que ne
partage pas le premier ministre cet
après midi edouard philippe devrait
répéter ce qu'il a dit à l'assemblée à
savoir qu'il ne souhaitait pas faire un
texte pour les accompagnants scolaires
la cloche a sonné je vous laisse écouter
les questions au gouvernement
la séance est ouverte le comprend du
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois point il est donc adoptée
sous les réserves d'usagé premier
ministe mesdames et messieurs les
ministres l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
some retransmis en direct sur la chaîne
parlementaire public sénat et sur notre
site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect de son
temps j'espère que ce n'est pas une
invocation rituel mais que ce sera le
cas et au respect des uns et des autres
la parole est au président jean claude
requier pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
il avait la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis une semaine les regards du monde
sont une nouvelle fois tourné et la
sphère la syrie depuis que l'armée
turque a lancé sa l'offensive contre les
forces kurdes et y pêcher officiellement
ankara souhaite établir le long de sa
frontière une zone sécurisée en
installant au moins un million de
réfugiés et en construit la renta record
villes et infrastructures
mais dans les faits ce sont à nouveau
les milliers de civils qui sont pris
dans l'étau d'une guerre civile qui
déchire depuis des drones ce pays martyr
avait des conséquences humanitaires
terrible on parle de près de 160 mille
déplacés d'exactions de règlements de
comptes nourrie par des haines
longuement mûri le fastueux turquie si
je suis le retrait des troupes
américaines
ce que l'ambassadeur de france en syrie
michel duclos appelle la géopolitique
des nouveaux autoritaires ou quand la
volonté de puissance intérieure et
extérieure des dirigeants turcs russes
ou iranien a fait d'assyrie le terrain
de jeu mortifère leurs ambitions ne nous
y trompons pas ce qui se passe mais
gravement en cause la stabilité
régionale et internationale avec en
toile de fond leurs toits ou fort de
bachar al assad
le spectre de la résurgence des shs que
les forces turques kurdes ont combattu
mais dans le livre n'a jamais totalement
paru la pantomime pathétique du
notamment déchiré le spectacle désolant
ville europe mi terme en impuissante et
une reconnaissance de l'engagement du
président de la république en faveur
d'une armée européenne
oui la france entretient des liens
d'amitié profonds et en servez le peuple
turc
mais le chantage et de ses dirigeants
étaient supportables il appelle de notre
part la plus grande fermeté monsieur le
premier ministre que va faire la france
pour faire cesser l'offensive turque et
le drame humanitaire qui cyanose comment
réagira-t-elle pour empêcher la fuite
des jihadistes français aujourd'hui
détenus
quelles sont nos marges de manoeuvre
pour tenter de stabiliser cette région
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gauthier
monsieur le président rock et pain vous
avez rappelé les faits je veux les
confirmés dans une certaine mesure la
syrie nous savons tous le 9 octobre
dernier a décidé de manière unilatérale
je le dis clairement de manière
unilatérale de lancer une offensive en
syrie contre les forces démocratiques
syriennes
cette offensive a une ampleur
considérable par les moyens qu'elle
mobilise y compris le soutien massif de
supplétifs syrien de l'armée nationale
syrienne par les périmètres par le
périmètre et par la profondeur de
l'offensive terrestre ainsi que des
frappes aériennes
vous savez que ces frappes aériennes se
sont étendues sur l'ensemble de la
frontière et compris à l'extrême
nord-est très au delà de la zone où
l'incursion terrestre a été réalisée le
13 octobre
les etats-unis ont décidé là encore de
manière unilatérale de retirer leur
dispositif militaire du nord-est syrien
ces deux décisions unilatérales emporte
des conséquences très lourdes des
conséquences très lourdes pour nos
partenaires kurdes qui se sont battus à
nos côtés contre des shs hommes et
femmes réunis
et à qui je veux rendre une nouvelle
fois hommage en notre nom à tous
conséquence
conséquences très lourdes pour notre
sécurité
parce qu'après cinq années de lutte
contre des shs le risque de voir ses
effectifs ses forces
opéré une forme de résurgence est
quasiment avérée l'idée que l'état
islamique puisse reprendre pied de façon
organisée
que ce soit au nord-est syriens ou le
cas échéant à travers la déstabilisation
de la région au nord ouest irakien fait
peser un risque sécuritaire
sur l'ensemble de la région et sur
l'ensemble de nos pays pour les raisons
que nous n'ignorons pas de conséquences
très lourdes sur le plan humanitaire il
ya aujourd'hui 700 mille civils dans
cette zone
des familles entières ont pris la route
pour fuir les combats
depuis le début de l'offensive dont on
dénombre 150 mille déplacés et
évidemment les premières victimes
civiles conséquences très lourdes enfin
sur la recherche d'une solution pérenne
dans la région parce que l'offensive
militaire et les menaces de la turquie
de réinstaller de force
les réfugiés syriens en turquie dans la
zone des 30 kilomètres qui longe la
frontière entre la syrie et la turquie
ne va pas faciliter la définition ou la
wii l'avènement d'une solution politique
dans la région
alors monsieur le président vous poser
la question de la réaction de la france
nous avons pris un très grand nombre
d'initiatives
d'abord la france a de la façon la plus
claire et la plus ferme condamner cette
opération militaire nous l'avons dit à
l'ambassadeur de turquie en france par
l'intermédiaire du quai d'orsay le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion de s'entretenir avec le
président erdogan
il lui a dit clairement combien quelle
était la position de la france est que
l'été notre condamnation de cette
opération militaire
ensuite cherché à mobiliser dans les
enceintes internationales et partout où
le multilatéralisme a du sens l'ensemble
de nos partenaires c'est vrai au sein du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui a été
réuni en urgence c'est vrai au sein de
l'europe qui s'est exprimée d'une seule
voix en la matière c'est vrai aussi au
sein de la coalition
car n'oublions pas que
les états unis d'une part et l'ensemble
des autres pays qui faisait partie de
cette coalition pour lutter contre des
ch ont été informés de la décision
unilatérale des états unis qui par son
importance dans la coalition
cette décision rente impossible pour les
autres pays de continuer à avoir un
impact sur le terrain face à l'impact de
l'opération turque sur la sécurité
européenne
nous avons pris la décision avec
d'autres pays européens de suspendre nos
exportations d'armes vers la turquie
c'est une décision commune de
l'allemagne des pays-bas de la norvège
de la finlande du royaume uni le canada
a par ailleurs pris la même décision
notre objectif c'est de poursuivre avec
nos partenaires de l'union européenne
toutes les initiatives possibles en vue
de conduire la turquie à mettre un terme
à cette opération
mais compte tenu des décisions turc et
du l'unilatéralisme dont la turquie a
fait preuve
ne nous voilons pas la face demandé
condamné un site et nous le ferons
obtenir sera beaucoup plus difficile et
je veux le dire simplement ce sera
beaucoup plus difficile
ce sera d'autant plus difficile que les
états unis ont pris cette décision
unilatérale
je veux dire monsieur le président vos
pieds sans jeter l'opprobre sur qui que
ce soit que les conséquences de cette
décision unilatérale seront très lourdes
très lourdes sur les etats-unis sans
doute sur la région c'est certain et
probablement même sur la façon dont nous
envisageons les relations avec nos
partenaires dans des théâtres
d'opération compliqué merci monsieur
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
pierre laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologie s'il a deux
minutes
monsieur le ministre l'offensive de la
turquie contre les forces kurdes et
démocratiques syriennes soulève
l'indignation
cette agression est un crime contre la
paix contre les combattants kurdes qui
ont combattu des ch et contrôle ex leur
expérience d'un roja va démocratique et
elle offre une opportunité inespérée à
neige de reconstruire ses forces
nous avions alerté de nombreuses fois
sur les risques de voir la rue la
turquie franchir le pas sur les
ambiguïtés de la coalition et sur le
rôle trouble joué par la turquie en son
sens aujourd'hui les masques tombent
la turquie fait la guerre aux kurdes et
à personne d'autre au mépris de la
sécurité du monde et cette guerre a été
autorisée par le président des états
unis
la france doit parler d'une voix claire
fortes indépendantes qui ne s'étouffe
pas aussi tôt dans les coulisses du
renoncement
la france doit agir monsieur le ministre
au delà de l'embargo des armes annoncé à
quelles mesures de sanction économique
financière politique fort que la france
est elle prête
la turquie est un important partenaire
commercial nous avons donc les moyens
d'agir
deuxièmement la france continue t-elle
d'agir pour aboutir à la mise en place
d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
et comment troisièmement que répond la
france à l'appel lancé par quinze
organisations humanitaires quelle est
notre stratégie pour obtenir un
cessez-le-feu qui protège le travail
humanitaire garantit son accès en tous
lieux protège les populations civiles
par l'interdiction de l'utilisation des
armes explosives en zones peuplées
permettent de rapatrier les enfants
français détenus dans les camps de
prisonniers
enfin monsieur le ministre puisque les
états unis et la turquie sont au coeur
de cette affaire et qu'ils sont membres
de l'otan
n'est-il pas temps de convoquer un débat
parlementaire d'urgence
interrogeant le rôle de l'eau
tant notre rôle dans cette alliance est
notre place au sein de son commandement
intégré le gouvernement est il prêt à
convoquer d'urgence ce débat
parlementaire pour vous répondre la
parole et au secrétaire d'état auprès
d'une vis de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pierre laurent la
semaine dernière cette haute assemblée
appelez déjà l'attention du gouvernement
sur la situation qui se préparait et
j'avais l'occasion de répondre
christine bruneau depuis lors la
pression militaire non seulement n'a pas
faibli mais s'est considérablement
accrue et l'émotion elle même je crois
n'a pas faibli et s'est aussi
considérablement accru avec une
mobilisation de toutes et tous et je le
sais d'un certain nombre d'entre vous à
travers des initiatives aussi une
proposition de résolution
depuis lors le pré ministre l'a dit à
l'instant la france s'est mobilisé
fortement dans toutes les enceintes
d'une part en demandant la réunion du
conseil de sécurité urgemment
la semaine dernière le conseil de
sécurité d'ailleurs doit demeurer saisi
de la question il se réunit très
régulièrement sur la situation de la
syrie et ce sujet doit systématiquement
être évoquée la france est intervenue
activement au sein du conseil des
ministres des affaires étrangères tenue
lundi et c'est parce qu'une voix forte
ci est exprimée celle de jean yves le
drian qu' il y a eu une condamnation je
crois unanime à ce moment là et que le
conseil européen des prochains jours
nous l'espérons viendra consacrer
vous évoquez naturellement les outils
économiques
sachez que il était prévu qu'une
commission mixte économique se tiennent
début décembre avec la turquie nous
avons fait savoir qu'il était impossible
que cette commission mixte économique se
tiennent
très naturellement dans le contexte que
nous connaissons et soyez sûrs que la
france elle a condamné dans les termes
les plus fermes et le président de la
république l'a d'ailleurs dit au
président erdogan et la france
continuera à être mobilisé pour obtenir
la cessation de l'offensive culture que
contre les kurdes
le plus rapidement possible et c'est un
sujet qui nous engage chaque heure
chaque jour chaque semaine tant que cela
dure je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
rémi féraud pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues ma question
porte à nouveau sur l'agression
militaire de la turquie dans le nord-est
syrien ce que nous demandons est je
crois dans l'ensemble des groupes de
cette assemblée à votre gouvernement
c'est de réagir plus fortement plus
fermement plus rapidement il en va de la
fidélité à nos alliés kurde bien sûr de
la fidélité à nos valeurs mais aussi de
notre propre sécurité
comme le premier ministre vient de le
dire lui-même chacun sait le rôle
exceptionnel des combattants kurdes aux
côtés de la coalition internationale
dans l'éradication du califat de dèche
chacun sait que les attaquer aujourd'hui
c'est permettre laser la résurgence du
terrorisme islamiste jusque sur notre
sol le président de la république a
appelé la société française à faire bloc
contre le terrorisme or cette lutte elle
est globale et faire bloc en france sera
illusoire si nous laissons les
djihadistes reprendre pied dans le
nord-est syrien alors vous nous dites
que la france agit et c'est vrai mais
nous vous disons qu'elle agit trop tard
et insuffisamment pour être efficaces
ces sondes intériorisé un sentiment
d'impuissance et d'isolement largement
exagéré l' invasion par la turquie du
canton d'afrique livrer ensuite aux
milices jihadistes et où les kurdes ont
été victimes d'un véritable nettoyage
ethnique était un avertissement auquel
nous n'avons pas su réagir
monsieur le ministre la france va-t-elle
enfin se mobiliser à la hauteur des
sacrifices réalisés pour nous par les
combattants kurdes
merci je le mois de monsieur le ministre
répondre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur rémi
féraud oui vous avez raison le rôle joué
par les combattants des forces
démocratiques syriennes les fds dont les
kurdes a été déterminant et ils y sont
ils sont parvenus à une défaite
territorial 2 dahesh avec l'appui de la
coalition internationale de la france et
le courage de ces femmes et de ces
hommes appellent notre reconnaissance
une reconnaissance qui doit continuer à
s'exprimer
naturellement dans les faits est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que il n'ya pas
de dosage dans la façon dont nous
justement cherchons à mobiliser tout le
monde
notre engagement il est total pour
mobiliser la communauté internationale
encore une fois dans toutes les
enceintes nous avons immédiatement
appelé à la réunion du conseil de
sécurité dès lors que l'armée turque
avait franchi cette frontière
nous avons nous n'avons pas ménagé notre
peine parce que très clairement la
décision les décisions unilatérales qui
évoquait le premier ministe qui ont été
prises sont graves très graves et leurs
auteurs portent une responsabilité
devant l'histoire naturellement alors
monsieur le sénateur je vous sais très
impliquée sur la question kurde
à l'image de la haute assemblée de la
commission des affaires étrangères qui
ce matin a auditionné l'ambassadeur de
turquie
je veux saluer d'ailleurs la proposition
de résolution qui appelle un engagement
résolu de la france en faveur de toute
initiative
sachez que nous rejoignons complètement
cet appel que c est en ce moment même
discutée lors du conseil des ministres
franco allemand qui se réunit
à toulouse que les prochaines heures les
prochains jours seront également très
important au conseil européen et que la
situation humanitaire étant ce qu'elle
est eh bien nous nous préparons d'ores
et déjà à une réponse avec notre centre
recrue de crise et de soutien parce que
l'afflux de réfugiés risquent de se
faire au kurdistan irakien
il ya d'ailleurs une demande d' aide
internationale pour pouvoir gérer cette
situation et nous devrons être également
présent au rendez-vous pour ses frères
d'armes de lutte contre le terrorisme
que sont les kurdes monsieur féraud
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre de votre
réponse nous appelons les autorités
françaises à s'engager davantage et à
sortir de la posture défensive dans
laquelle nous nous sommes nous mêmes
placés rappelons la phrase de charb
contre le cynisme et la mort aujourd'hui
il y a le peuple kurde
il est de notre devoir est de notre
intérêt d'être à ses côtés
nous serons à vos côtés pour prendre des
initiatives beaucoup plus forte dans les
jours qui viennent
merci la parole est à notre collègue
franck menonville pour le groupe les
indépendants merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
malgré l'annoncé de l'imminence d'un
possible accord la nuit dernière entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
concernant leur exil
la pression reste importante sur le
conseil européen de demain
monsieur le ministre dans ce conte ce de
son contexte particulièrement
mouvementée est incertain pouvez vous
nous dire où on sent les négociations
sur un accord de sortie du royaume-uni
mais également que peut-on attendre des
prochains jours
car pour l'heure il faut le rappeler
le royaume uni fait encore partie de
l'union européenne et les interrogations
quant aux relations futures ne cesse de
grandir
ce fut notamment le cas lorsque le 3
juin dernier le président américain
donald trump
ce tweet est je cite un grand accord
commercial est possible une fois que le
royaume uni se sera débarrassé de ses
chaînes celui ci a été très clair quant
à ses intentions de créer
une prochaine relation privilégiée avec
le royaume uni
il y a d'ailleurs eu un un accord
bilatéral dans le cadre du cloud act
américain qui a déjà été conclus donc le
3 octobre dernier et non sans remous
en effet la commission européenne a
saisi s'est saisi de cette question et
doit se pencher sur la conformité de
tels accords sur le avec le droit
communautaire
beaucoup d'incertitudes demeurent encore
elles sont plus forte encore pour nos
entreprises
nous entendons les craintes et les
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens et de nos
pme sur nos territoires
donc quelles mesures concrètes
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
préparer le brésil à la fois en termes
économiques mais aussi politiques et où
en sommes nous vraiment actuellement
pour vous répondre la parole et où
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe et les affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur frank mais non ville
la préparation de la france et l'union
européenne à ce bric site remonte à
plusieurs mois puisque vous le savez des
textes ont été adoptés par les
assemblées des ordonnances nous
permettant justement de nous préparer au
mieux à cette situation qu'il y ait ou
non un accord et les préparatifs ont
continué à se faire de façon très
intensive sous la houlette du premier
ministre qui réunit très régulièrement
tous les ministères concernés
s'agissant des entreprises vous évoquiez
leurs inquiétudes nous avons conduit une
action très proactive à leur égard y
compris en appelant personnellement
chacune entreprises exportatrices
françaises vers le royaume uni pour
pouvoir préparer toutes les procédures
en cas de non accord alors les heures et
les jours prochains vont ils voir un
accord éventuel aboutir michel barnier a
estimé la semaine dernière que des
garanties suffisantes existait pour une
reprise pleine et entière des
négociations mais l'heure tourne
aujourd'hui nos préoccupations sur les
positions britannique sur l'irlande et
l'irlande du nord ne sont pas tout à
fait le v
il faut le dire nous avons des
préoccupations sur l'intégrité du marché
unique de l'union douanière qui est
importante sur le consentement de
l'irlande du nord et sur le maintien de
conditions de concurrence loyale alors
l'union européenne se montre très
clairement ouverte à la négociation
constructive à la discussion
encore faut-il que le prémice
britannique donne cette impulsion
politique nécessaire son cabinet ce doit
se réunir dans les prochaines heures
nous dit on en tous les cas quelle que
soit l'évolution nous sommes prêts à
faire face à tous les scénarios y
compris celui d'un retrait sans accord
nous avons adopté des cadres juridiques
très complet la sensibilisation a été
conduite et naturellement nous avons une
coordination très active avec eux tous
les pays voisins et puis au delà du 31
octobre
tout restera à faire pour bâtir une
relation future parce que l'histoire et
la géographie est là le royaume uni
reste un pays européens au sens large du
terme et nous devront bâtir une relation
qui reste proche
compte tenu de ses liens je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant président
christian cambon pour le groupe l'est
républicain le président monsieur le
ministre
comme mes collègues précédent l'on
soulignait le vent est à nouveau en feu
l'offensive massive que la turquie vient
de conduire dans le nord-est de la syrie
anéantie d'un seul coup tous les efforts
que la coalition avait mené coalition
dont la france est le deuxième
contributeur et tout cela risque bien
évidemment d'être ainsi très positif
pour des ch qui n'en est qu'ils n'en
attendait pas tant
le bilan est accablant déjà près de
mille morts à l'heure où nous parlons
160 mille civils réfugiés lancer sur les
routes
le retour de pêche et le risque peut
être pire encore d'évasion de
djihadistes qui vont venir faire payer
très cher l'europe pour son engagement
enfin les kurdes les cures de nos alliés
les kurdes nos amis qui se sont battus
avec temps d'héroïsme pour notre propre
sécurité
ce peuple sans patrie ce peuple trahi
une fois de plus qui est contraint
d'appeler au secours ses ennemis d'hier
les américains ont cru défendre leurs
intérêts mais quelle confiance accorder
demain à leur parole alors
monsieur le ministre mes questions sont
simples
tout d'abord comment le temps peut-elle
rester sans réagir
nous étions un certain nombre dimanche à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan et à
nos questions forte nous avons fait
entendre la voix de la france
le secrétaire général stoltenberg n'a
jamais daigné répondre
et par ailleurs que comptez-vous faire
face aux millions de aux milliers de
jedi de djihadistes qui menacent notre
sécurité
le ministre annonce son départ pour
l'irak qui espère-t-il obtenir là bas et
surtout pour les français pour notre
nation
que comptez-vous faire ici en france
pour assurer la sécurité des français
pour vous répondre et la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président quand bon rien à redire à
retrancher vous ajoutez à au constat que
vous dressez monsieur le président ni
sur le caractère unilatéral de décisions
qui ont été prises par la turquie et les
états unis ni sur les conséquences très
lourdes je les ai évoqué mais je me
retrouve entièrement dans ce que vous
avez vous même formulée s'agissant du
risque sécuritaire du risque ou du
risque de la résurgence probable de
dèche liés à la déstabilisation de la
possibilité de trouver en tout cas de la
très grande difficulté de trouver une
solution politique
dès lors que cette intervention se
déroule rien à ajouter
vous évoquez au fond deux questions
distinctes même si elles sont un peu lié
la première c'est l'otan la turquie
membre de l'otan nous sommes membres de
l'otan les états unis sont monde
longtemps un grand non pas tous mais un
grand nombre de partenaires présents
dans la coalition internationale était
membre de l'otan vous avez évoqué les
questions posées par un certain nombre
de parlementaires français à l'assemblée
de représentant français à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan et l'absence de
réponses qu'il aurait été formulée
cette absence de réponse me semble
traduire un très grand trouble
pour dire les choses de façon posée est
ce trouble regardons le en face si le
principe d'une alliance est de permettre
à des partenaires de travailler ensemble
les décisions unilatérales et les
décisions qui viennent s'entrechoquer
les unes avec les autres ne me
paraissent pas relever d'un bon
fonctionnement nous avons donc là
quelque chose à regarder en face à
travailler sérieusement c'est vrai avec
nos partenaires
mais quiconque consiste quiconque aurait
pour discours de dire que l'otan
fonctionne
comme elle a toujours fonctionné
circulez ya rien à voir pardon de le
dire trivialement à mon avis se
tromperait deuxième question la sécurité
en france qui se traduit de deux façons
la première c'est la possibilité de
reconstitution d'un espace géographique
maîtrisé par des shows lequel serait
propice à l'organisation d'actions à
l'extérieur de ce territoire
nous n'en sommes pas là non pas du tout
que le risque serait nul mais nous n'en
sommes pas là un certain nombre de
détenus sont toujours détenus ceux qui
sont en prison les prisons sont assez
loin de la zone où ont lieu les combats
en tout cas un certain nombre de prisons
sont très loin de la zone où ont lieu
les combats d'autres camps qui
détiennent où sont parqués si j'ose dire
non pas les combattants et un certain
nombre de gens qui se sont échappés
après les derniers combats notamment à
banyuls dans le sud de la région
ces camps sont encore constitué
nous devons évidemment avoir en tête que
la résurgence de dèche est quelque chose
qui est possible et nous devons discuter
avec nos partenaires de la région qui
ont les mêmes intérêts que nous pour
savoir comment est-ce que nous allons
éviter la reconstitution de dèche cette
discussion va être compliqué car la
situation est profondément déstabilisé
et qui peut dire que nous pourrions
compter demain sur nos alliés kurdes
dans ces conditions compte tenu de la
décision amérique et puis il ya
évidemment la question des retours vers
le territoire national je veux dire
monsieur le président comment que de ce
point de vue là l'ensemble du dispositif
est prêt au sens où nous sommes prêts à
judiciariser évidemment tous ceux qui
s'étant rendus sur zone se sont rendus
complices des actions criminelles qui
ont été conduites sur place autrement
dit grande vigilance sur le territoire
métropolitain
dans l'hypothèse où certains voudraient
revenir nous savons qu'un certain nombre
de gens s'ils devaient échapper au
contrôle de nos et les kurdes irait se
battre cherche pas forcément revenir et
se battre et travaille avec les pays
voisins notamment avec l'irak vous avez
dit monsieur le président que le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères allait se rendre
de façon imminente incessantes et même
je crois dès ce soir en irak pour
discuter avec ses homologues avec le
gouvernement irakien des mesures à
mettre en place et éventuellement de
l'accompagnement qui est susceptible
d'être mis en place notamment en matière
de coopération judiciaire
puisqu'un certain nombre de ceux qui
sont détenus en syrie par les kurdes ont
commis des crimes en irak et peuvent
donc de ce fait le cas échéant être
judiciariser sur place c'est un des
éléments qui sera évoquée par le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères avec son homologue sont avec
son homologue d'irak merci monsieur le
premier ministre
la parole est à notre collègue laurent
lafon pour le groupe de l'union sont
plus monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre shah collègues
vendredi dernier le conseil
constitutionnel a jugé que les droits
d'inscription appliquées à l'université
serait contraire aux prescriptions du
préambule de la constitution de 1946
selon lesquelles je cite l'organisation
d'enseignement public gratuit à tous les
degrés est un devoir de l'état
seuls des tarifs modiques serait
autorisé le jugement répond à une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité posée sur la
possibilité donnée aux universités dans
le cadre du plan bienvenue en france
d'augmenter significativement les droits
d'inscription pour les étudiants
étrangers plan pour lequel la commission
culture et éducation du sénat avaient
demandé un moratoire dans son
application
cependant la portée de cette décision
dépasse la simple question des tarifs
appliqués aux étudiants étrangers et
s'applique aux droits d'inscription de
l'ensemble des étudiants français et
étrangers dans l'ensemble des
établissements publics universités ou
écoles
ce jugement que le conseil
constitutionnel qualifie lui-même
d'inédits crée des incertitudes
juridiques tant il est difficile d'en
mesurer aujourd'hui les portes l'impact
exact il pose un certain nombre de
questions qui pourraient avoir des
conséquences sérieuses sur le
financement de nos établissements
le principe d'autonomie financière
n'est-il pas atteint par cette décision
qui remet en cause la possibilité pour
les établissements de fixer eux mêmes
leurs droits d'inscription
la gratuité est elle réellement un moyen
efficace
pour garantir l'égal accès aux études
supérieures n'y at il pas là un leurre à
penser que parce que c'est gratuit
c'est accessible à tous à tous enfin est
il pertinent de financer entièrement par
l'argent public et donc par l'impôt la
formation des étudiants étrangers dont
un grand nombre de repartent dans leur
pays d'origine une fois leurs études
terminées
enfin monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
partager avec nous la lecture que fait
le gouvernement de ce jugement
quel sera l'impact sur le financement
des établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur quelles conséquences
entraîne-t-il sur la hausse des frais
universitaires pour les étudiants
étrangers
décidée dans le cadre du plan bienvenue
en france
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur blanc caire où la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur laurent lafon vous me permettez
de d'excuser l'absence de même la mise
de l'enseignement supérieur frédéric
vidal qui étend actuellement aux côtés
du président de la république au conseil
des ministres franco allemand
vous l'avez rappelé il ya en effet une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui a été déposé
auprès du conseil constitutionnel
à la suite d'ailleurs de l'examen d'une
requête par le conseil d'état le conseil
constitutionnel a rendu sa décision le
vendredi au 11 octobre
que dit cette décision vous l'avez
rappelé le conseil nous explique que le
principe de gratuité de l'enseignement
supérieur s'applique mais que les droits
d'inscription différencier peuvent être
appliqués dans la mesure où il reste je
cite modique
le conseil a également rappelé que
naturellement le financement de
l'enseignement supérieur devait
principalement mais pas exclusivement
être assurée par l'impôt et qu'il
convenait de prendre en compte la
situation financière de chaque étudiant
le ministère a pris acte de cette
décision et désormais il reviendra au
conseil d'état de statuer ultérieurement
sur le fond de ce litige
vous le savez le plan bienvenue en
france et les enjeux de financement de
l'enseignement supérieur
de façon plus générale font l'objet
d'une réflexion collective et vous en
avez rappelé certains tenants et
certains aboutissons s'agissant de
bienvenue en france la commission de la
culture a travaillé le sujet en détail
il ya quelques mois
il s'agit de nous donner les moyens
d'accueillir mieux et davantage
d'étudiants internationaux
nous devons améliorer leurs conditions
d'accueil de logements de suivi des
cours de français
nous devons avoir une politique
ambitieuse parce que c'est un enjeu de
rayonnement de la france grâce aux
exonérations et aux bourses ce plan
conjugue ainsi des droits différenciée
qui sont il faut le souligner est
plafonné au tiers du coût réel d'une
formation et il y avait aussi dans ce
plan un triplement des bourses sans
compter les exonérations qui peuvent
être décidée directement par les
universités dans le cas du principe
d'autonomie que vous avez rappelé et
d'ailleurs elles sont nombreuses à
l'avoir fait cette année chacun pourra
ainsi constater que les deux critères
dégagés par le conseil constitutionnel
c'est à dire la prise en compte des
situations individuelles et le
financement à titre principal par
l'impôt sont respectées ce qui peut nous
rendre optimiste pour la suite
3 124 mille étudiants étrangers
poursuivent actuellement leur cursus en
france nous voulons que en 2027 la
possibilité soit fait d'avoir cinq cent
mille étudiants les universités du monde
se mobilise
nous devons en fait rentrer autant c'est
un enjeu essentiel pour la france nous
compte de façon à ce que nous comptions
2 % d'étudiants internationaux conclus
et russe
le conseil d'état tranchera donc dans
les prochains mois sa décision répondra
définitivement aux interrogations qui
demeurent à ce stade merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à notre collègue julien
bargeton pour le groupe g république en
marche
essayons de respecter les deux minutes
s'il vous plaît on a seize questions
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
le président de la république a annoncé
en avril un pacte productif qui a été
présenté hier par plusieurs ministres il
doit fonder un new deal économique
écologique et technologique
l'industrie française dispose d'atouts à
commencer par ses talents mais rencontre
aussi un certain nombre d'obstacles qui
ont été identifiés depuis plusieurs
années les difficultés ancien du
commerce extérieur en témoigne
d'ailleurs si le chômage réduit à huit
ans et demi pour cent et si
l'investissement repart dans les
entreprises 30 milliards d'euros en deux
ans cependant la bataille de la
compétitivité est loin d'être gagné des
emplois industriels secret mais des
sites sont menacés
le mérite de ce pacte est de ne pas
minimiser les enjeux auxquels nous
devons faire face pour répondre à la
demande mondiale
certains secteurs clés doivent devenir
exportateur net quelles sont selon vous
les leviers principaux pour renforcer
notre industrie ont été évoquées
notamment ont été évoquées notamment les
impôts de production qui sont l'un des
sujets à traiter 70 milliards d'euros
c'est une spécificité française mais ce
n'est pas le seul sujet ce n'est pas le
seul sujet comment l'industrie peut-elle
participer au retour au plein emploi à
l'horizon 2025 qui n'est pas une utopie
parce que finalement ce sont les
salariés qui rendent possible une nation
productive
quelles sont les actions prioritaires la
méthode envisagée
et selon quel calendrier je vous
remercie pour vos répondre la parole et
au secrétaire d'état en charge du
numérique que monsieur cédric où vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur julien
bargeton je vous remercie pour votre
question je voudrais commencer par
excuses à monsieur
le ministre de l'économie des finances
bruno le maire qui est retenu à toulouse
pour le conseil des ministres franco
allemand
vous avez eu l'occasion de le dire
effectivement l'économie française se
porte mieux et se porte mieux depuis
quelques années c'est ce que les
chiffres disent nous avons aujourd'hui
cinq cent mille chômeurs de moins cinq
cent mille chômeurs de moi l'amour d'une
croissance qui est meilleur que nos
voisins notamment meilleur que
l'allemagne et c'est particulièrement
vrai dans l'industrie puisque je suis
content heureux que cette assemblée le
salut pour la première fois depuis dix
ans l'investissement est au plus haut et
pour la première fois depuis dix ans
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous recréons des emplois industriels
alors est-ce suffisant non et c'est tout
le but du pacte productif
porté par bruno le maire puisque le fond
du défi c'est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une révolution
technologique et industrielle et que
chaque révolution technologique et
industriel dans l'histoire a fait des
gagnants et des perdants et que tout
l'enjeu est de faire en sorte que
l'europe et la france soit au rang des
gagnants dans une compétition notamment
dans le numérique un domaine que je
connais bien qui aujourd'hui est en
partie menée par les américains et les
chinois même si nous avons des leaders
comme atos ou dassault systèmes qui
tirent leur épingle du jeu est donc
l'objectif du pacte productif qui
rassemblait les collectivités
territoriales ces assemblées les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales c'est de
travailler sur une stratégie pour faire
en sorte qu'on ce qu'on travaille au
levier qui nous permettront d'être au
niveau de la compétition internationale
c'est la question des impôts avec
l'entrée dans le débat d'une la question
de la baisse des impôts de production
c'est la question d'identification d'un
certain nombre de technologies clés
l'intelligence artificielle l'ordinateur
quantique dans lequel nous devons être
présents et c'est enfin avec muriel
pénicaud la question de la formation
mais je le répète l'objectif final du
pacte productif c'est de faire en sorte
que l'industrie française soit au
rendez-vous de la compétition mondiale
choix merci monsieur bargeton
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue madame jacqueline eustache
brinio pour le groupe des républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre je souhaite
vous interroger à partir de mon
expérience celle d'une élue qui a vu
progresser dans nos quartiers
le communautarisme qui a vu les jeunes
femmes se mettre le voile porté le voile
sous la pression alors que leur mère
sont été libérés le voile en 2019 n'est
pas anodin et nous aurions tort de le
considérer comme une expression d'une
pratique religieuse d'ailleurs beaucoup
de femmes musulmanes dans notre pays ne
le porte pas le voile est trop souvent
le symbole d'un islam politique qui
considèrent plus la femme comme un objet
soumis que comme un individu un individu
émancipé pour reprendre un qualificatif
cher au président de la république nous
aurions tort de baisser les yeux et ne
pas voir que le port de signes religieux
ostentatoires dans le cadre des sorties
scolaires est un instrument de
prosélytisme et parfois même de
provocation l'école de la république
doit montrer aux petites filles qu'elles
ne transige pas avec les principes de
laïcité et d'égalité
or sur cette question centrale du
respect de la laïcité et de la
neutralité régit le religieuse et
adultes intervenant dans le cas de
l'école hors les murs la majorité et le
gouvernement se divise vous avez tenté
monsieur premier mise désamorcer les
querelles au sein de votre majorité mais
une fois de plus vous avez en définitive
baisser les bras
vous ne cessez de dire qu'il faut lutter
contre le communautarisme et en même
temps vous ne cessez de renoncer à agir
ce n'est pas l'ambiguïté qui contribuera
au réarmement moral de notre pays et au
respect des principes qui vont la france
et qui unissent les français
monsieur le premier ministre pouvait me
dire exactement ce que le gouvernement
compte faire vraiment pour lutter contre
la communautarisation de notre société
et faire respecter les principes de
notre république laïque et indivisible
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
aux ministres de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse monsieur blanquet s'il
vous plaît la parole est aux ministres
et à lui seul
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
merci pour votre question qui porte sur
un sujet important sa porte déjà sur la
république je pense que nous sommes très
heureux d'avoir tous en commun
l'héritage républicain et ses skis sur
l'ensemble des bancs nous unit et
constitue notre contrat social
nous sommes au dessus tous très heureux
du principe de laïcité c'est un trésor
que qui nous vient de la république et
notamment de la troisième république
et cet héritage est un héritage
extrêmement précieux d'autant plus qu'il
est en effet un outil pour le 21e siècle
la laïcité est extrêmement moderne elle
nous est très utile dans la société
d'aujourd'hui parce que nous avons
besoin d'avoir une république une de
citoyens égaux c'est un point
extrêmement important et c'est ce qui
nous différencie d'autres pays y compris
de pays voisins
l'angleterre par exemple est une société
aujourd'hui communautariste avec les
dangers que cela représente
donc oui vous avez raison la république
et la laïcité sont nos outils
d'organisation sur le sujet particulier
que vous évoquez qui n'est pas le seul
sujet loin s'en faut
loin s'en faut en matière de laïcité et
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent un petit peu insistez beaucoup
sur celui là alors que d'autres sujets
sont plus importants on doit d'abord
éviter la confusion
on doit d'abord éviter la confusion
j'entends dans le débat public des
choses très différentes mélanger il ya
d'abord l'action du gouvernement dans la
lutte contre la radicalisation c'est un
sujet très important sur lequel le
président la république s'est exprimé en
des termes fermes
vous le savez il y à la lutte contre le
communautarisme et c'est ce dont je
viens de parler c'est à dire l'enjeu
républicain d'une société de citoyens
égaux et qui vaille en particulier à
l'égalité homme femme et puis il y as en
troisième lieu évidemment la laïcité qui
s'applique évidemment à toutes les
religions et qui est notre bien précieux
parce qu'elle nous permet à tous de
vivre ensemble et l'école est la matrice
de cette laïcité et nous devons à chaque
enfant
la neutralité politique et religieuse
dans sa vie quotidienne
la question des sorties scolaires est un
enjeu hybrides parce qu'il s'agit de
l'enfant en dehors de l'école mais dans
un cadre qui en est fait et scolaires et
donc je les dis nous ne souhaitons pas
une loi parce qu'une loi créerait plus
de problèmes que de solutions
autrement dit elle serait contre
réductive y compris vis-à-vis de notre
enjeu républicain de scolariser tous les
enfants et de faire en sorte que tous
les parents se sentent bien venu à
l'école de la république
en revanche et je les dis et c'est
l'expression le sens de l'expression que
j'ai utilisée
le voile n'est pas souhaitable parce que
en effet nous ne souhaitons pas que ce
soit un élément qui puisse être
interprété comme du prosélytisme dans
ses sorties scolaires et c'est ce que
nous sommes capables de mettre en oeuvre
concrètement tout ceci me rappelle un
adage latin qui nous vient aussi de la
république romaine a conclu une medio
stat virtus virtu vous pouvez le décrire
de deux façons c'est la vertu mais c'est
aussi le courage merci madame quelques
secondes
non j'ai rien entendu très concret mais
je peux pas croire qu'aujourd'hui vous
puissiez raté une occasion de marquer
une réelle volonté de lutter contre les
velléités de l'islamisme en france alors
que deux français sur trois sont prêts à
soutenir cette loi qui interdit le voile
pendant les sorties scolaires
franchement je trouve ça manque de
courage
la parole est à notre collègue jérôme
durain pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre il règne dans ce pays une
atmosphère irrespirable vendredi en
séance du conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté le président d'un groupe
qui n'a rien de républicain a fait
dégénérer les échanges en accusant
d'abord les agents de la région d'être
touché par la radicalisation et le
communautarisme islamistes en twittant
ensuite la perte d'appétit que provoque
chez lui une exposition consacrée à
martin luther king en agressant enfin
verbalement une femme voilée des enfants
venus découvrir les institutions
républicaines sont repartis dans le
tumulte et une maman accompagnatrice
sous la menace de l'arrivée des russes
certains ont vu dans ces événements une
interrogation sur la laïcité
j'y vois surtout la triste expression du
racisme que nous croyons au ciel ou que
nous n'y croyons pas nous avons la
responsabilité de dénoncer le climat
malsain qui règne dans ce pays les
musulmans pour ce qu'ils sont sont
pointés du doigt monsieur zemmour
récemment condamné a son rond de
serviette sur les plateaux de télévision
dans les universités des fichages
tendancieux commencent à apparaître
nous ne tomberons pas dans les pièges
tendus par les provocateurs de tous
bords notre boussole c'est la concorde
républicaine le président macron et vous
même monsieur le premier ministre avait
rappelé l'état du droit
en ce qui concerne la laïcité hier
encore 90 personnalités ont lancé un
appel au président pour condamner les
événements de vendredi
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
premier ministre pour endiguer la
libération de la parole raciste dans ce
pays
dont vous répondent la parole est là
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur une nouvelle fois notre pays
cette assemblée notre société se
passionne et se divisent pour une
question en l'occurrence la question du
voile
je ne méconnais en rien l'importance de
ce sujet mais face à ses passions je me
permets de vous répondre monsieur le
sénateur que ma boussole hamoir c'est le
droit et mon cap c'est la lutte contre
le communautarisme et la radicalisation
ma boussole monsieur le sénateur c'est
le droit et le droit
il est posé depuis longtemps c'est
l'article 10 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est la
loi de 1905 qui prévoit vous le savez
nous le savons tous un double principe
extrêmement exigeant celui de la
neutralité absolue des pouvoirs publics
et des agents publics et celui de la
liberté de nos concitoyens à croire ou
ne pas croire et à exercer leur culte
dans le respect de la loi
ces principes ne sont pas des petites
choses
ils sont au coeur de la façon dont nous
avons choisi de vivre et nous y sommes
je le sais a tâché alors bien entendu
sur ces principes nous pouvons parfois
avoir des différences d'appréciation
nous avons déjà fait bouger le cadre
juridique
je sais vous savez que en 2004 le
parlement a choisi d'aller plus loin
s'agissant de la laïcité en indiquant
que le port de signes religieux
distinctifs là en l'occurrence du voile
était interdit dans les enceintes
scolaires à l'école au collège et au
lycée
il l'a fait c'est la loi elle a été
jugée constitutionnelle c'est donc un
principe qui nous oblige mais cette loi
n'a pas dit que le voile était interdit
à l'université elle n'a pas dit que le
voile est être interdit dans le cadre
des sorties scolaires
lorsque des parents lorsque des parents
accompagner bénévolement volontairement
une sortie scolaire mesdames et
messieurs c'est la loi et c'est la
jurisprudence constante et rappeler est
rappelé et monsieur le président il me
semble que rappeler la loi de façon
précise dans l'hémicycle au sénat n'est
pas quelque chose d'inutile et n'est
certainement pas quelque chose de
critiquable
alors ce que la loi fait ce que la loi
fait la loi peut le modifier dans le
respect de la constitution dans le
respect des principes
après un débat j'ai bien compris qu'un
certain nombre sur ses bancs en
l'occurrence porter l'idée d'une
modification de la loi le parlement aura
vocation à en débattre jeudi pour ma
part que la boussole ayant été expliqué
c'est le droit tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
le cap me semble devoir être celui de la
lutte contre la radicalisation contre le
communautarisme et il me semble et c'est
un avis personnel
il me semble qu'en matière de lutte
contre la radicalisation et le
communautarisme il y a des choses
incroyablement plus efficace à faire
incroyablement plus productive à faire
que de légiférer sur les sorties
scolaires et l'interdiction du voile
dans les sorties scolaires
je me permets là aussi d'exprimer ma
ligne il me semble qu'à la suite
d'ailleurs de ce qu' il me semble qu'à
la suite d'ailleurs de ce que le sénat a
proposé par la voix d'une ppl porté par
madame la sénatrice gatel faire en sorte
d'exercer un contrôle beaucoup plus
strictes sur les écoles hors contrat au
moment de leur création faire en sorte
grâce à la loi portée par monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
pouvoir avoir un contrôle beaucoup plus
strictes sur les enfants déscolarisés
sur les réseaux leur déscolarisation et
sur le contenu de l'éducation qu'ils
reçoivent à domicile
voilà à mon avis des sujets qui sont
bien plus importants bien plus porteur
que la simple évocation de la loi qui a
été évoqué voilà ma position lutte
contre la radicalisation lutte politique
contre le communautarisme lutte à tous
les instants avec le soutien aux
enseignants avec la création des
instruments nécessaires
c'est la position du gouvernement c'est
la boussole que nous avons choisi le cap
que nous regardons le duras douze
secondes 12 2 secondes monsieur durand
il ya ce que vous avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre il ya aussi une forme
de racisme qu'il faut dissiper des vents
mauvais souffle sur notre société il
faut dissiper la confusion apaiser les
tensions et ramener tous nos concitoyens
vers la république a parlé maintenant
notre collègue isabelle raymond pas
verrou pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres cher collègue monsieur le
premier ministre c'est au tour des
pompiers professionnels hier de
manifester contre le manque de respect
du gouvernement
en grève depuis des mois parce qu'ils
assurent des missions qui ne sont plus
leur coeur de métier avec une forte
augmentation des incendies ils joignent
leurs revendications aux personnels des
hôpitaux eux mêmes débordés par
l'explosion de l'ensemble des services
hospitaliers notamment d urgence toutes
les professions au coeur des grandes
missions de l'état sont en crise
profonde
les policiers vous ont exprimé récemment
leur colère le suicide récent d'une
directrice d'école
la tentative de suicide une principale
montrent que l'éducation nationale n'est
pas épargné cette colère généralisée
exprime avant tout une crise de
l'autorité de l'état
vertus capitale pour une société ces
professions qui enseigne qui soigne qui
nous protège en ont assez des grands
discours qui ponctue une situation qui
ne cesse de se dégrader
assez de leurs conditions de travail
assez de la violence croissante dont ils
sont victimes
parce qu'il représente l'état lorsque
l'on touche à un pompier ou un
enseignant lorsque l'on insulte un
médecin c'est la république que l'an
défi cette année 1272 d'agressions de
pompiers ont déjà été recensé 312
pompiers ont été blessés nous avons le
sentiment que vous assister en
spectateur à une situation qui échappe à
pourtant c'est bien une des compositions
de l'état républicain qui se produit
sous nos yeux
les événements d'hier l'expriment
parfaitement l'état régalien n'assure
plus comme ils devraient sereinement
ces grandes missions de service public
comptez vous monsieur le premier
ministre réponde à la colère aux
angoisses des agents qui rendent un
service au public
qu'avez vous à dire aux pompiers aux
personnels soignants aux enseignants aux
policiers dont la dégradation de la
situation s'accélère pour vous répondre
la parole et au secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur monsieur lune
elle avait la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs adam la madame
la sénatrice
permettez moi de vous répondre sur les
sapeurs-pompiers qui effectivement
étaient dans la rue hier pour une
manifestation qui tenait d'exprimer les
difficultés de démission qui sont les
leurs et que ce gouvernement connaît
parfaitement et sur lesquels vous le
savez madame la sénatrice
nous travaillons en concertation avec
les organisations syndicales concernées
vous avez évoqué la question importante
et c'est vrai des agressions dont sont
victimes les sapeurs-pompiers souvent du
fait même des personnes qu'ils vont se
courir parce qu'ils ont des difficultés
psychologiques ou qui sont sous
l'emprise de l'alcool il ya une montée
des violences que nous prenons en compte
dans le cadre de conventions de
coordination avec les policiers avec les
gendarmes pour mieux encadrer
l'intervention des sapeurs pompiers
vous l'avez souhaité maintenant ils
interviennent avec des caméras piétons
et nous allons poursuivre cette action
pour faire baisser le niveau des
agressions mais ce que je voudrais aussi
dire c'est que cette action elle est
menée dans le cas d'une grande
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales
deux sapeurs pompiers ils ont été il
avait été reçu par le ministre de
l'intérieur en marge du congrès à vannes
ils ont été reçus hier au cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur et nous allons
poursuivre cette discussion dans les
jours qui viennent le 6 et le 14
novembre il y aura des réunions
importantes avec le ministre de
l'intérieur les organisations syndicales
et les collectivités employeuse pour
traiter des questions par exemple de la
prime de feu ou autre sujet de
recrutement cette discussion elle va se
poursuivre mais soyez assurés d'une
manière générale madame la sénatrice que
ce gouvernement met tout en oeuvre pour
que l'action des services régaliens
qu'il s'agisse bien évidemment de la
sécurité civile des sapeurs pompiers
mais aussi de nos policiers de jeunes
aux gendarmes pour que cette action elle
s'effectue dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et tout ça ce sont
les efforts que nous faisons en matière
de recrutement en matière d'équipement
en matière budgétaire en matière
indemnitaire puisque nous parlons des
policiers et des gendarmes également
mais soyez assurés que notre attention
est totalement porté vers eux pour
qu'ils puissent exercer leurs missions
dans des conditions de sécurité
optimales
on n'a vraiment pas verrou quelques
secondes dans votre réponse monsieur le
ministre mais il ya urgence urgence à
agir efficacement pour garantir l'unité
de la france
merci la parole est à notre collègue
nathalie gaulle et pour le groupe de
l'union centriste y avait la parole à
messieurs les ministres ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre
l'intérieur
elle est aux confins de deux sujets que
nous avons déjà évoqué le break sic et
terrorisme puisque le break site avec ou
sans accord se traduira par un recul
significatif de la coopération policière
et judiciaire entre les pays de l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne et une
fragilisation des acquis d'élever des
actions que nous avions mis en place au
cours de ces dernières années au service
de notre sécurité
une faille majeure dans la sécurité
européenne d'autant que le royaume uni
est l'un des pays le plus touché par le
terrorisme il est le deuxième pays
occidental après la france par le
phénomène des filières syrienne qui
revient évidemment au coeur de
l'actualité
le royaume uni ne pourra plus utiliser
le service d'information schengen qui
permet notamment d'alerter sur les
déplacements fini l'accès au pnr au
système européen d'information et
d'autorisation concernant les voyages
les bases de données qui répertorie
aussi les empreintes digitales de tous
les demandeurs d'asile et des émigrés
illégaux
de la même façon il n'y aura plus de
mandat européen pour le royaume uni
aussi ma question est simple quelles
dispositions avez vous prévu pour
endiguer les failles qui vont résulter
et manque ablement du bric site pour
vous répondre la parole et tous
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur monsieur
neige
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice nathalie goulet je vous sais
très haut vous ont fait de ces questions
permettez-moi d'abord de vous dire que
la coopération en matière de lutte
antiterroriste c'est aussi une
coopération des services de
renseignements intérieurs comme vous le
savez est que cette coopération qui a
été accentuée depuis les attentats qui
nous ont frappés en 2015 entre tous les
services de renseignements intérieurs au
sein de l'union européenne
mais en dehors du cadre de l'union
européenne cette coopération extrêmement
productive va bien évidemment se
poursuivre elle s'exerce dans un cadre
bilatéral directement entre les services
français et britanniques aient pu
également dans un cadre multilatéral
mais informel et j'insiste bien là
dessus
en dehors de quatre bien évidemment du
traité de l'union européenne donc il n'y
a pas de difficulté de ce point de vue
et cette coopération il a lieu tous les
jours il est tout à fait exact
et vous avez raison de le souligner que
pour partie cette coopération utilisent
des outils qui sont des outils prévus
dans le cadre européen et par un certain
nombre de textes européens
vous avez cité notamment le pnr vous
avez cité le système d'information
schengen sur lequel sont recensés un
certain nombre d'individus recherchés et
notamment notre fichier des personnes
recherchées et que ces dispositifs
obéissent effectivement à des
dispositions européennes et que le break
site aura nécessairement une conséquence
sur l'utilisation de ces outils
mais la sortie sans accord ou avec
hacker ne dépend pas que de nous bien
évidemment vous l'avez compris et il est
bien évident que dans le cadre de
l'accord si accord il doit y avoir il y
aura un volet pour poursuivre
l'utilisation de ces outils européens
dont je parle et que quand bien même il
n'y aurait pas d'accord nous ouvrirons
bien sûr des discussions mais il ne nous
appartient pas à ce stade de nous
prononcer sur des choses qui nous sont
imposées madame la sénatrice et choses
nous sont encore une fois imposé dans le
cas d'un accord oui il ya un volet de
sécurité intérieure mais voilà je ne
peux pas vous faire une autre réponse
que celle ci et de renvoyer aux
partenaires britanniques
madame boulet oui mais c'est le ministre
remercie de votre réponse mais quand
même la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement a rendu il ya quelques
semaines un rapport alarmiste sur la
situation notamment de la sécurité et
des conséquences du bric site je
voudrais aussi dire que nous sommes très
très souvent dans ces situations dans
l'ex post je crois qu'il faudrait pas
attendre le 31 octobre je sais très bien
que les services continuent à travailler
mais je pense que là il ya des mesures à
prendre de façon extrêmement urgente
il ya une évaluation des besoins le
problème des mandats européens est un
problème extrêmement sérieux parce qu'on
risque d'avoir des déconvenues
judiciaires importantes avec un certain
nombre de personnes indésirables sur
notre territoire et que nous ne pourrons
plus poursuivre faute d'outil donc je
vous demande monsieur le ministre de
prendre les dispositions avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
merci beaucoup la parole vers notre
collègue florence lassarade pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
commissaire mes chers collègues la
réforme des retraites telle que proposée
dans votre rapport je le vois inquiète
les femmes mères de famille actuellement
les mères de famille valide 8,8
trimestre dans le secteur privé par
enfant né ou adopté et quatre trimestres
dans le public
il s'agit de ce que l'on appelle la
majoration de durée d'assurance la
réforme envisagée supprime les
dispositifs actuels pour les remplacer
par une majoration retraite de 5% par
enfant dès le premier enfant
cette bonification pourra éventuellement
être transféré au père ou partager avec
lui la retraite des femmes est
actuellement inférieur de 38 % à celle
des hommes
cela est en grande partie due à la
maternité qui conduit un grand nombre de
femmes à prendre du temps pour leurs
enfants a renoncé à une promotion à
prendre un temps partiel ou un congé
parental pour beaucoup de maires n'ayant
pas de carrière
complète l'attribution d'une retraite
qui soit le strict reflet de leur
période d'activité sera défavorable par
rapport au système actuel
il est particulièrement injuste de
bonifier la retraite d'un par an en
pourcentage en lisant les maires dont
les carrières sont incomplètes mais
aussi celles ayant de petits salaires il
serait particulièrement inéquitable que
la réforme des retraites accroissent
l'écart de niveau des retraites au
détriment des mères monsieur le
commissaire est ce que cette majoration
de 5 % se substituera à la majoration de
durée d'assurance pénalisant ainsi les
femmes ayant élevé plusieurs enfants
d'autre part est ce que cette loi aura
un effet rétroactif
en supprimant les droits acquis par les
femmes ayant eu des enfants avant
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme en
2025 pour vous répondre la parole est à
jean paul delevoye haut-commissaire aux
retraites sur le ministre devait les
paroles chez le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs chère madame je
connais tout l'intérêt qu'il y a apporté
la situation des femmes dans le futur
système universel des retraites
notre cap est clair les mêmes règles
pour tous l'universalité et la recherche
de l'équité
vous avez vous même évoqué que quand
vous êtes maman dans le secteur public
est d'abord dans le secteur privé vous
n'avez pas la même majoration de durée
un juste vous êtes si vous avez évoqué
huit trimestres et catherine est la
seconde c'est que s'il ya une majoration
durée dans le système actuel il n'y a
aucune majoration de pension pour le
premier enfant pour le deuxième enfant
pour le quatrième et de cinquième
le dispositif a été créé pour compenser
les préjudices de carrière vous avez
raison de souligner que l'insee en 2019
indiqué qu'il y avait une perte de 20 5%
des revenus salariaux des femmes que
quand vous regardez le taux d'activité
des hommes et des femmes au troisième
enfant avant que celui-ci ait trois ans
il est de 70 % pour les hommes de 30 %
pour les femmes mais le résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce dispositif fait
qu'il bénéficie à deux tiers des hommes
deux tiers des hommes et donc nous avons
décidé de compenser cela par une
majoration proportionnelle dès le
premier enfant de façon à ce que l'écart
de 40 % des pensions entre les hommes et
les femmes qui tombe à 25% avec la
réversion puisant nos simulations sur
les générations 80 90
augmentez les pensions en moyenne des
femmes de 5 à 10% troisième dispositif
troisième normes hervouet non non mais
ce qui est intéressant monsieur
retailleau ce qui est intéressant c'est
que nous avons fait des simulations et
nous allons parler chiffres contre
chiffres simulation contre simulation et
pas sur des slogans
troisième élément nous augmentons le
minimum contributif habile euros ce qui
là aussi permet de pouvoir apporter une
amélioration pour les femmes notamment
de temps partiel le conseil
d'orientation des retraites a indiqué
que le dispositif que nous mettions en
place était favorable aux carrières
heurtées et courte est donc concerne
notamment les femmes
voyez vous nous avons la prétention de
faire en sorte d'apporter une
redistribution en faveur des femmes dans
le système universel merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à notre collègue dominique
théophile c'est une réplique non non non
non il n'y a pas de tva là dessus
monsieur dominique tian
théophile nom n'avait évidemment
meilleur pour le groupe la république en
marge de la parole monsieur le président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à la ministre d outre-mer
madame la ministre
en guadeloupe en martinique et en guyane
le journal france antilles ou
france-guyane appartient à un groupe de
presse en cessation de paiement l'unique
quotidien régional sera bientôt
peut-être dans un mois et demi en
liquidation ces territoires doivent
pouvoir conserver une presse vivante et
pluraliste une pièce qui a contribué au
développement de la citoyenneté de la
liberté d'opinion et de la démocratie
dans nos villes les mutations
technologiques des réseaux sociaux les
changements dans les habitudes de
consommation met cependant cause la
survie de ce journal sa disparition
signifierait la perte cumulée de 253
emplois à haut niveau de qualification
en guadeloupe en martinique et en guyane
ces emplois sont occupés en grande
partie par des originaires leur niveau
de spécialisation rendra à la leur
démarche difficile voire impossible en
cas de liquidation
ce quotidien est aujourd'hui
constitutifs du patrimoine de ces
territoires
depuis plus de cinquante trois ans il
rythme notre vie quotidienne
il doit être à ce titre préserver c'est
pourquoi il est nécessaire de mobiliser
l'ensemble des aides au pluralisme de la
presse périodique régionale le conseil
constitutionnel et le conseil d'état ont
consacré dans leur jurisprudence
la valeur constitutionnelle du
pluralisme de la presse écrite
ils ont également admis qu'au soutien
public a cru devraient être apportées à
la presse d'information politique et
générale
je vous prie madame la ministre de nous
faire connaître les mesures que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour
maintenir une presse quotidienne
régionale vivante ainsi que les nombreux
emplois si importants ou des territoires
touchés par un chômage de masse qui en
dépendent pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la ministre d outre-mer
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur théophile oui malheureusement
vous avez raison la presse écrite
quotidienne en outre mer connaît
malheureusement des difficultés aux
antilles bien sûr mais aussi en guyane
et à l'île de la réunion
et ça nous impose à tous de re penser
ensemble de choses d'abord le modèle
économique de ce secteur et ensuite de
renouveler l'offre l'offre aux lecteurs
dans les pratiques évoluent nous le
savons tous
et cette question d'adaptation est
nécessaire aussi dans les territoires
d'outre-mer le groupe france antilles
c'est l'éditeur du premier quotidien de
presse en guadeloupe en martinique et en
guyane
concrètement ce sens 285 salariés
répartis entre ces trois territoires et
pour la réunion c'est environ le même
nombre pour deux quotidiens le groupe
france antilles a été placé en
redressement judiciaire le 25 juin et le
tribunal de commerce de fort de france
se prononcera fin novembre des offres de
reprise sont d'ores et déjà déposé
le gouvernement est bien entendu
mobilisées depuis quelques mois sur ce
sujet a pris trois décisions
la première c'est une inspection iga
jack doit qui doit formuler des
propositions avant la fin de l'année sur
un soutien que nous devons apporter à
ces sectes à ce secteur
deuxièmement des outils pour faciliter
la trésorerie et là nous avons décidé de
pouvoir effectivement échelonnées dans
le temps les dettes sociales et fiscales
pour certains de ces organismes et puis
troisièmement je le dis je les demande
est défendue au siom au comité
interministériel à l'outre-mer
il faut que le comité interministériel
de restructuration industrielle ce qu'on
appelle le ciri qui a pour mission
d'aider les entreprises en difficulté
avec des solutions défini entre
actionnaires et créanciers puissent agir
sur ce sujet le premier ministre l'a
acté et validé c'est aujourd'hui chose
faite c'est trois engagements seront
tondues tête seront tenus et puis vous
dire effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
en conclusion le dynamisme
de presse régionale est fondamental dans
nos territoires d'outre-mer comme
partout c'est le droit à l'information
c'est bien sûr aussi la vie démocratique
qui nous faut défendre c'était au fil
vous avez on seconde dont la parole est
à notre collègue didier mandelli pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la fois au ministre
de l'économie et à la ministre du
travail
le 10 octobre dernier le groupe michelin
fleuron industriel français leader
mondial du pneumatique annonçait la
fermeture définitive du site de la roche
sur yon
après joué les tours en 2013 et 700
entre 730 emplois supprimés
cette décision met fin la production
destinés aux poids lourds en france
619 hommes et femmes qualifiées
hautement qualifiés sont concernés vont
perdre leur emploi
la moyenne d'âge des salariés de 39 ans
et beaucoup ont été recrutés ces cinq
dernières années dans le cadre du plan
skipper qui prévoyaient 100 millions
d'euros d'investissements et 200
recrutements 70 millions ont été
investis les femmes et les hommes ont
consenti beaucoup d'efforts pour
améliorer la productivité du site
cela n'a apparemment pas suffi et le
couperet est tombé brutalement
michelin propose 120 millions d'euros
pour accompagner la reconversion de
lusine suggère la mobilité interne pour
des personnes qui ont construit leur vie
familiale et professionnelle en vendée
pour certains depuis plus de trente ans
c'est une vue de l'esprit la présidente
de la région pays de la loire cristal
morancé notre éminent collègue bruno
retailleau ont obtenu le remboursement
des aides régionales accorda michelin
est ce que l'état fera la même démarche
pour une part du cice l'état sera-t-il
présent aux côtés des salariés et des
élus locaux dont le maire de la roche
sur yon du guaje le président du
département yves auvinet pour obtenir
toutes les garanties et amortir les
conséquences de ce drame économique et
humain à long terme
cette malheureuse actualité illustre les
travers de notre économie aussi plus
généralement comment l'été tente l'état
entente il oeuvrait pour préserver et
développer l'industrie dans notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état
lors du mérite au ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur mandelli je crois que votre
question jette une lumière assez
évidente et urgente sur l'autre question
qui était posée tout à l'heure par le
sénateur bargeton sur l'urgence d'un
pacte productif puisque ce qu'on voit
c'est que le problème de michelin et de
michelin à la roche sur yon
c'est l'émergence de concurrents chinois
et on le voit les concurrents chinois
immerge dans le numérique
il émerge dans l'industrie et il émerge
dans des secteurs comme les pneus où
nous avions pourtant des entreprises qui
étaient parmi les meilleurs du monde
donc il est nécessaire que nous ayons
des actions défensives mais également
des actions offensives et que nous
soyons capables de nous battre à la
hauteur de la compétition mondiale
s'agissant du site de la roche sur yon
j'ai entendu le président de michelin
dire qu'il accompagnerait l'ensemble des
salariés ce que ce dont je veux vous
assurer c'est qu'avec bruno le maire et
muriel pénicaud
nous ferons en sorte de veiller à ce que
chacun je dis bien chacun et chacune des
6 119 salariés d'ici du site michelin
soit accompagné soit accompagnée jusqu'à
ce qu'il ou elle trouve un emploi
le site de la roche sur yon est un
bassin d'emploi industriel dynamique
j'ai eu l'occasion quand j'étais dans
l'industrie de travailler sur le sujet
mais il faut bien que chacun et chacune
des salariés retrouvent un emploi dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent et
le gouvernement sera très attentif au
sujet un dernier sujet monsieur le
sénateur puisque il ya aussi une
certaine aberration avoir parfois des
pneus qui sont peut-être moins chères
mais moins durable se vendre mieux est
évincé des technologies françaises qui
sont plus durables et donc plus
écologique
c'est également un sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement compte se mobiliser bruno
le maire à une espagnole une hache et
ont demandé un contrôle express à la
dgccrf et c'est un sujet que nous
voulons porter au niveau européen pour
faire en sorte qu'on respecte à la fois
nos ambitions industrielles et nos
objectifs écologiques je vous remercie
simon déry simplement sur le sujet dans
le cadre de projets de l'économie
circulaire nous avons intégré
l'obligation dans la commande publique
d'intégrer des pneus issus de ces
filières qualitative française plus
généralement vous m'avez apporté une
réponse
je n'avais pas être convaincus ou pas il
s'agit simplement que les salariés eux
mêmes le soin donc nous leur poserons la
question après votre intervention
merci beaucoup maintenant on est à notre
collègue sylvie robert pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
par sa décision du 11 octobre dernier le
conseil constitutionnel a tiré du 13e
alinéa du préambule de la constitution
de 1948
l'exigence constitutionnelle selon
laquelle la gratuité s'applique à
l'enseignement supérieur public des
frais d'inscription modique peuvent être
néanmoins perçu en tenant compte des
capacités financières des étudiants à
travers cette décision qui fait suite à
la volonté du gouvernement d'augmenter
brutalement et de manière importante les
droits d'inscription pour les étudiants
extracommunautaires il est rappelé que
l'égal accès devant l'instruction aux
fondements du projet du projet
émancipateur de la république ne
s'arrête donc pas aux portes de
l'enseignement supérieur public et que
ce principe ne peut être entravé pour
des motifs pécuniaire alors dans la
tente de la décision du conseil d'état
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur a dit vouloir garder la
stabilité du système d'enseignement
supérieur public très bien mais comme
dit le poète être patient ce n'est pas
attendre c'est agir en attendant par
conséquent comment allez-vous anticipé
ces décisions 11 et envisagez-vous par
exemple de revenir sur l'arrêté
ministériel relatif aux frais
d'inscription différencier des étudiants
étrangers auront lieu
mais plus globalement comment
comptez-vous sécurisé et assurer la
pérennité du financement de
l'enseignement supérieur public qui
risque on le sait d'être profondément
bouleversé réponse de la jeunesse sur
l'antenne merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs m la
sénatrice sylvie robert je vais répondre
un nouveau évidemment en lieu et place
de
mamie de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal et jeffrey l'explication
de texte de ce que j'ai commencé à dire
tout à l'heure d'abord je vous répondrai
en n'oubliant pas que j'étais d'abord un
avant/après un professeur de droit
constitutionnel et donc je vois à peu
près là non contradiction qui existe
entre ce que le conseil constitutionnel
a dit est ce que le gouvernement a porté
avec évidemment l'approbation du
parlement
il n'y a pas de contradiction puisque
les deux principes que j'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure sont parfaitement respectées
par le dispositif actuel c'est à dire
d'une part le principe
d'individualisation c'est à dire on
tient compte de la situation sociale
chaque étudiant et puis d'autre part le
pince le principe de financement d'abord
et prioritairement par l'impôt de
l'enseignement supérieur donc nous ne
sommes pas dans une contradiction avec
le régime juridique que nous avons créée
par contre il ya désormais un besoin de
précisions c'est pour ça que nous avons
à attendre la future jurisprudence du
conseil d'état mais on peut être sereins
par rapport à cette jurisprudence
parce que le terme utilisé par le
conseil constitutionnel
c'est le terme de modiques et modique
nous le sommes dans les perspectives que
nous avons puisque nous avons limité à
un tiers la somme le plafond de ce qu'un
étudiant étranger pourrait payer et
n'oublions pas que lorsque ce n'est pas
cet étudiant qui paye c'est le
contribuable français il est normal que
nous ayons une attention à cela donc il
ya un respect du principe de gratuité
dès lors que l'on est dans le modique et
nous sommes dans le modique conseil
d'état évidemment appréciera de manière
précise et qui fera autorité mais nous
pouvons être serein par rapport à cela
d'autant plus sur le plan social et
c'est là que j'aurais peut-être une
différence avec vous que comme je le
rappelais tout à l'heure la ministre a
prévu avec le plan bienvenue en france
le fait que précisément cette manière de
gérer permet d'être plus accueillants
permet d'avoir plus d'étudiants ce qui
est un enjeu pour la france pour la
force et la puissance de la france et
que et de le faire dans des meilleures
conditions donc aussi bien
quantitativement que qualitativement
ceux ci mènent à des améliorations et en
plus à de la justice fiscale donc ça
s'accumule beaucoup davantage esquissé
ce qui nous rend serein par rapport à la
future jurisprudence
merci
merci monsieur mono on sent bien que le
débat même si les plus larges va porter
autour du terme modique vous le situer
au regard du coût de la formation
c'est votre prisme je pense qu'il doit
être maintenant mis en regard de
l'exigence de gratuité et d'égalité car
je ne suis pas certaine que paient plus
de 2000 euros de droit d'inscription
pour une formation soit considérée comme
modique
d'un point de vue d'un étudiant et de sa
famille en tout cas nous souhaitons un
vrai débat parlementaire car il s'agit
d'elle dans l'enjeu et du financement de
notre enseignement supérieur public
demain
[Applaudissements]
dernière question pour jean louis masson
pour laisser d'acteurs de figurant sur
la liste d'aucun groupe il a deux
minutes
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
par le passé les immigrés qui venait en
france voulait s'intégrer dans notre
société aujourd'hui les flux migratoires
sont différents ils conduisent à des
noyaux communautariste qui rejette notre
façon de vivre
or les terroristes musulmans trouvent
leur vivier de recrutement dans le
communautarisme radicaliser cette
radicalisation recrutent elles mêmes
dans le communautarisme ordinaire et il
est urgent de réagir
j'approuve la ministre des collectivités
territoriales qui suggère d'interdire le
port du voile islamique dans les
assemblées des collectivités
territoriales j'approuve aussi la
position du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui ne souhaitent pas que les
parents qui accompagnent les sorties
scolaires portent le voile islamique
cependant au gouvernement d'autres
ministres disent le contraire et
soutiennent le communautarisme islamique
au risque de favoriser le terrorisme
de son côté le président de la
république se complaît dans l'ambiguïté
monsieur le premier ministre
oui ou non êtes vous favorable au port
du voile islamique dans les assemblées
des collectivités territoriales oui ou
non et doux favorable au port du voile
islamique par les parents qui
accompagnent des enfants dans les écoles
pour répondre la parole et à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte parole du gouvernement
la milice levée la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vois que vous
êtes manifestement eu égard aux murmures
sur les bancs de cette assemblée
largement habitué à toutes les formes
d'outrance je crois qu'il est important
et le premier ministre a eu l'occasion
de le faire de rappeler au fond quels
sont les fondements de notre république
et la manière dont le fait religieux est
encadrée dans l'espace de la république
française la loi de 1905 le premier
ministre a eu l'occasion de le rappeler
fixe ce cadre et détermine le fait que
c'est en france l'état qui est laïque et
non pas la société cela signifie d'une
part que l'état laïc a un devoir de
neutralité devoir de neutralité qui
s'incarne dans les agents de la fonction
publique c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas avoir un professeur
à l'école qui porte la kippa ou qui
portent le voile ce cadre juridique a
été complétée il y a quelques années
c'était en 2004 pour faire en sorte que
l'école en particulier soit un espace si
j'ose dire ça crée un espace de
protection qui permet aux enfants d'être
éduqué dans les valeurs de notre pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle les signes
religieux ostentatoires sont interdits
pour les élèves mineurs à l'école nous
avons également fait le choix collectif
c'était celui du législateur en 2004 de
laisser le voile autorisé pour les
parents accompagnateurs de sorties
scolaires qui sont des adultes dans la
mesure où ils ne pratiquent pas de
prosélytisme
à l'attention des élèves nous avons je
crois et le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler
une attitude extrêmement résolue de
lutte contre toutes les formes de
communautarisme religieux et une
attitude extrêmement ferme de lutte
contre toutes les formes de
radicalisation religieuse nous sommes
monsieur le sénateur tout aussi fermes
pour dénoncer toutes les stigmatisations
à l'intention de nos compatriotes en
raison de leur appartenance à une
religion et en particulier à la religion
musulmane
je crois que nous sommes une nation
ouverte mais une nation ferme dans ses
principes qui luttent contre la
radicalité qui lutte contre le
communautarisme
et le fait toujours sans relâche je vous
remercie je me trompe je devrais je
devrai tout d'abord dire que les gens
qui viennent dans notre pays c'est à un
de ceux de s'adapter à nos règles de vie
et c'est pas à nous de subir les règles
de vie de ceux qui viennent chez nous et
alors qu'on leur a rien demandé
par ailleurs par ailleurs je voudrais
dire je voudrais dire que sur cette
affaire c'est scandaleux que par exemple
mes petits enfants vos petits enfants
arrivent puissent être amenés à les
faire des visites scolaires en étant
entouré par des femmes complètement
voilées mais où est-ce qu'on en est où
est ce qu'on en est c'est scandaleux
c'est la négation à ce niveau-là de la
delà de la laïcité et moi ce que je dis
aux conclusions
oui ce que je veux dire juste pour
conclure c'est qu'à mon avis le
conseiller régional du rassemblement
national qui a posé le problème mérite
cette décoration il a raison
nous avons terminé que les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
les prochaines auront lieu le 23 octobre
mes chers collègues je vais juste pour
la séance mais et sera reprise à 16h35
pour la désignation des membres de la
commission spéciale en charge d'examiner
le projet de loi sur la bioéthique
puis pour les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi relative à la
création du centre national de la
musique puis nous reprendrons ensuite
l'examen du projet de loi engagement et
proximité la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement qui se sont ouvertes par
une série de questions sur l'offensive à
turc en syrie mais comme vous avez pu
l'entendre cette séance a surtout été
marquée par de nombreuses
interpellations au sujet du port du
voile lors des sorties scolaires alors
un sujet polémique qui a opposé la
droite et la gauche
alors tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle la
sénatrice l heure jacqueline eustache
brinio a dénoncé une communautarisation
de la société française
quand le socialiste jérôme durain
parlez-lui d'atmosphère irrespirable et
même de racisme
alors écoutez à la réponse du premier
ministre edouard philippe
ma boussole à moi c'est le droit et mon
cap c'est la lutte contre le
communautarisme et la radicalisation
il me semble qu'en matière de lutte
contre la radicalisation et le
communautarisme il y a des choses
incroyablement plus efficace à faire
incroyablement plus productive à faire
que de légiférer sur les sorties
scolaires et l'interdiction du voile
dans les sorties scolaires faire en
sorte d'exercer un contrôle beaucoup
plus strictes sur les écoles hors
contrat au moment de leur création faire
en sorte de pouvoir avoir un contrôle
beaucoup plus strictes sur les enfants
déscolarisés sur les raisons de leur
déscolarisation et sur le compte
l'éducation qu'ils reçoivent à domicile
voilà à mon avis des sujets qu'ils sont
bien plus important c'est la position du
gouvernement
c'est la boussole que nous avons choisi
le cap que nous regardons donc ainsi
edouard philippe a répété son supplément
ce qu'il avait dit hier à l'assemblée à
savoir donc il ne voulait pas légiférer
à ce sujet préférant donc s'attaquer à
d'autres priorités
il s'est fait particulièrement applaudir
sur les bancs à gauche de l'hémicycle et
donc pas vraiment à droite puisque
rappelons le
la sénatrice a l'air jacqueline eustache
brinio à déposer donc une proposition de
loi sur l'interdiction des signes
religieux pour les sorties scolaires
donc notamment pour les accompagnons aux
sorties scolaires qui sera examinée donc
le 29 octobre prochain
alors jean michel blanquer lui a enfoncé
le clou on dit en rappelant donc son
attachement au principe de laïcité
ce trésor cet héritage précieux et cet
outil pour le 21e siècle at il dit et ce
qui nous distingue de des pays voisins
alors pour lui donc le port du voile
n'est pas souhaitable mais par contre
lui que tout comme l'a dit edouard
philippe ne souhaite pas de loi bien que
les sorties scolaires doivent sont soit
une question hybride donc compliqué à
traiter
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire donc
pour ces questions au gouvernement est
tout de suite donc la suite des débats
avec vous ta main merci beaucoup à l'iss
pour toutes ces explications autour
effectivement de ce temps fort de la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement nous avons débriefé tout
cela en plateau mais d'abord et bien on
va tout de suite prendre la direction de
la salle des conférences du sénat
car alexandre vous êtes avec le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer r bien sûr qu'il ya bien des
choses à dire sur cette polémique autour
et bien du port du voile pour les
accompagnants scolaires
oui jean michel branquart sur cette
polémique autour du port du voile dans
les sorties scolaires
ça y est votre position
éclair vous êtes opposé à une loi pour
l'interdire même position est toujours
la même
regardez les débats parlementaires d'il
ya plusieurs mois j'ai toujours dit
exactement la même chose et donc je
continue à dire exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire nous n'avons pas besoin
d'une loi sur le sujet pour autant nous
devons éviter toute pression sur nos
élèves la laïcité c'est la neutralité
politique et religieuse pour nos élèves
dans le contexte scolaire donc dans les
sorties scolaires on doit éviter cette
pression religieuse et donc c'est
pourquoi j'ai utilisé cette expression
que le voile n'était pas souhaitable ce
qui reste vrai et ce qui est d'ailleurs
les termes juridiques actuelles
rappelons que la vie que nous avons du
conseil d'état de 2013 non seulement dit
que la loi permet le port mais qu'en
même temps les responsables locaux les
directeurs d'écoles peuvent juger que
s'il ya une pression prosélyte et bien
cela doit être interdit par ailleurs
j'avais fait ajouter dans la loi pour
l'école de la confiance qui est l'actuel
article 10 l'interdiction de tout
prosélytisme aux abords des
établissements donc il n'ya pas de
variations dans la position ça reste
toujours la même au fil du temps c'est à
dire la laïcité la république et en même
temps bien sûr notre objectif c'est la
scolarisation de tous les enfants et la
respecte tous les principes mais le
risque de l'état dans cette affaire créé
de l'ambiguïté en étant opposé à cette
loi mais en disant que le voile en étant
souhaitable d position d'équilibré ont
parfois du mal à être comprises dans
notre débat public est souvent très
nerveux mais ma position depuis le début
et une position d'équilibré
qu'est ce que nous visons nous visons
d'abord à être une république la
république française en république
française ça veut dire l'égalité des
citoyens
ça veut dire que nous sommes tous égaux
ne sommes pas une société
communautariste la république française
ça signifie aussi l'égalité hommes
femmes
c'est tous ces sujets là sont
parfaitement claires et c'est évidemment
le projet de société que nous avons on
doit pas confondre tous les sujets nous
avons un sujet de lutte contre la
radicalisation d'une part aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet très important sur lequel
le président la république s'est
fortement exprimée dans son discours à
la préfecture de police de paris
c'est un point il ya un deuxième sujet
qui est la lutte contre le
communautarisme
autrement dit la promotion de notre
modèle de société français républicain
qui signifie que tous les citoyens sont
égaux
ce qui signifie évidemment que chacun
peut pratiquer sa foi ou sa non fois et
que c'est justement ça toute la force de
la laïcité que de nous permettre cela et
puis la laïcité en relation avec
sont des citoyens autrement dit le
principe de neutralité politique et
religieuse des services dernière
question la droite du sénat a tort de
proposer une loi pour interdire le voile
dans les sorties je pense que plusieurs
formes dans le pays cherche toujours à
mettre l'accent sur des points qui
divise alors que tout notre travail doit
être au contraire de réunir les français
et de le faire autour de notre socle
républicain liberté égalité fraternité
et laïcité
très bien merci beaucoup jean michel
blanquer merci beaucoup alexandre pour
cette interio va continuer à parler du
voile en plateau parce qu'effectivement
cette polémique était docker de la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec nos invités
hélène conway mouret bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste des français
établis hors de france membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat vice-présidente du sénat et ancien
ministre chargé des français de
l'étranger également sur ce plateau
cédric perrin bonjour sénateurs l ère du
territoire de belfort vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense
et je précise que vous venez d'être élu
rapporteur général de la paix autant on
va en parler puisqu'on va également près
de la turquie et de la syrie qui était
également au coeur de cette séance de
questions d'actu également sur ce
plateau jean philippe derosier bonjour
jour vous êtes resté avec nous
constitutionnaliste professeur agrégé de
droit public à l'université de lille et
enfin je le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau franck mais non vie lé sénateur
rds de la meuse membre de la commission
des affaires européennes vous avez des
indépendants il est indépendant pardon
et vous avez d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
interpellé le gouvernement autour de la
question du break site
il en sera également question tout
d'abord et bien est-ce que vous avez été
satisfait par la réponse à l'instant de
jean michel blanquer rate il lever
toutes les ambiguïtés
mais que pensez vous de sa position le
voile n'est pas souhaitable mais il ne
faut pas de l'oie hélène conway mouret
voici les positions me va très bien je
regrette cette polémique parce que je
pense que les sujets internationaux sont
beaucoup plus importants que cette
petite polémique que nous avons en
france mais qui al'avantage quand même
de nous rappeler des principes
fondamentaux et moi je suis très
heureuse que nous reparlions de laïcité
de ce que cela signifie dans notre
république
comment elle doit être comprise parce
que pendant très longtemps on l'a 1
peu mise à toutes les sauces et surtout
elle a été récupéré ou par l'extrême
droite en particulier et sincèrement la
laïcité c'est la sphère de toutes et de
tous notamment des femmes en particulier
donc voilà donc qui lie à un rappel et
je pense qu'il ne faut pas tout mélanger
donc moi je suis d'accord avec la
position du gouvernement et du ministre
telle qu'elle a été exprimée aujourd'hui
la loi aujourd'hui déjà pas on n'y
touche pas on n'est toujours pas là
dessus
voilà mais on n'a pas besoin d'en
rajouter voilà c'est vrai que opéra on
l'a vu à la réponse du premier ministre
finalement la réponse le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a satisfait dans
la partie gauche de l'hémicycle alors
que se prépare un du côté de votre
groupe
une proposition de loi justement pour
interdire le port du voile
enfin les signes distinctifs religieux
aux personnes accompagnant les sorties
scolaires pour la fin du mois mais qui
va être porté par la sénatrice
jacqueline eustache brinio absolument
alors moi je dois tout à fait d'accord
avec mon amie hélène pour une raison
simple c'est que je pense que justement
il ya ya ya un flou comme disait c'est
lillois martine aubry et contient
contient un flou c'est qu'il ya un loup
et moi je pense que c'est de ce point de
vue là le miz éducation nationale a été
très clair en disant qu'il fallait pas
que le voile deviennent rouges tous les
termes exacts qui l'employait de vienne
ne soit comment la règle c'est pourquoi
je pense qu'ils en prennent comme terre
mais d'un autre côté on a des décisions
qui étaient présents 2004 dans le cadre
législatif on a une circulaire chatel de
2012 qui a été invalidée par le conseil
d'état je crois et le conseil d'état qui
laisse la porte ouverte à des
possibilités d'interdiction en tout cas
des mises en garde contre l'usagé août
contre le port du voile par des
enseignants ou des directeurs d'école
est-ce que c'est aux enseignants aux
directeurs d'école de juges et de
comment dirais-je de la possible du
possible prosélytisme que ferai
certaines personnes je ne le pense pas
et donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
clarifie les choses
je vous donne la parole tout de suite
mais d'abord on va rejoindre alexandre
poussin vous êtes avec le président du
groupe l air au sénat vous êtes avec
bruno retailleau et on va lui poser
justement la question notamment la
question du voile mais oui bruno
retailleau qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette position du gouvernement et
notamment de jean michel blanquer a pas
de loi sur l'interdiction du voile dans
les sorties scolaires
mais en même temps le port du voile
n'est pas souhaitable et en même temps
le double langage on n'y comprend plus
rien du tout d'un côté monsieur blanc
caire dit que le voile n'est même pas
souhaitable pas seulement à l'école ou
dans les sorties scolaires c'est à dire
dans toute la société
mais en même temps il ne veut pas
légiférer s'il y avait monsieur blanc
caire où le premier ministre actuel
jamais la loi de 2004 qui interdit le
voile à l'école jamais elle n'aurait pu
être votée ils se seraient des fossés
notamment sur les enseignants et bien
nous nous voulons prendre notre
responsabilité on peut pas se défausser
ni sur les directeurs d'école ni sur les
enseignants ce cap a quand même un
risque de stigmatiser les français de
confession musulmane en interdisant le
voile dans les centres non non non moi
je pense qu'il faut protéger nos
compatriotes justement qui professent la
confession musulmane
il faut les protéger parce que il ya un
certain mouvement de radicalisation ce
que nous voulons faire c'est très très
simple c'est faire en sorte que l'école
soit un sanctuaire
nous considérons que les sorties
scolaires si la prolongation d'école
c'est l'école la classe hors les murs et
je pense que il ya une exigence de
neutralité et de laïcité renforcée à
l'école pourquoi parce qu'on à faire des
jeunes à des consciences en formation et
la querelle des hommes doit rester à la
porte de l'école à la porte des sorties
scolaires
mais les parents d'élèves qui font ces
sorties scolaires font un effort
d'intégration au sein de la république
donc ce n'est pas les rejeter en
interdisant le port de signes religieux
là
non666 demain on mettait des religieuses
avec leur corne est dans les sorties
scolaires qu'est-ce qu'il en aurait été
non il ya un objectif justement de
laïcité et il concerne l'école dans
toute sa périphérie dans la classe c'est
ce qu'a exprimé tout récemment la cour
administrative d'appel de lyon le 23
juillet dernier puisqu'il a donné
l'accord ni strativa donné raison un
directeur d'école qui vous l'a exigé la
neutralité de parents d'élèves qui
venait dans la classe bien nous nous
considérons que la sortie scolaire
c'est une classe en dehors de l'éclat de
l'école mais c'est toujours les colts
voilà autre sujet qui est bien distinct
je le précise la radicalisation le
terrorisme islamique vous allez avec le
groupe l'est républicain que vous
présidez demandé la création d'une
commission d' enquête contre la
radicalisation
qu'est ce que cette commission va
apporter de plus ce qui est beaucoup de
rapport sur ce sujet non il s'agit
aujourd'hui alors que le gouvernement
baissent les bras
il s'agit de comprendre un double
phénomène il ya d'un côté le terrorisme
islamiste
c'est un phénomène brutal violent
sanguinaire mais de l'autre côté il ya
une machine à fabriquer du reddick
alisme des jihadistes ce que nous
voulons voir parce qu'il ya eu tant de
livres y compris de vos confrères sur
trappe
il ya eu des études des sondages qui
montrent qu' il ya des territoires qui
désormais sont conquis par l'islamisme
nous voulons avoir justement le
diagnostic précis de ce phénomène et
nous voulons voir quelles sont les
meilleures formes les meilleurs remèdes
à y apporter
on ne peut pas se contenter là encore de
ne rien faire
est-ce que selon vous par exemple il ya
eu une explication économique social à
ce ce développement de la radicalisation
dans ce que l'on voit bien que notamment
un certain nombre de terroristes qui
sont passés à l'acte ne connaissait pas
des situations sociales désespérées
donc il faut dit joindre ses
explications qu'ils soient qui sont de
l'ordre de la psychiatrisation en disant
ce sont des dingues
voilà des loups solitaires et c'est là
où des explications qui consiste à dire
que il ya un problème social et qui
peuvent finalement être excusés non
c'est inexcusable très bien pas d'excusé
merci beaucoup
bruno retailleau pour les explications
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle intervention et je précise
avant que nous reprenions le cours de
débat que on ne mélange pas tout en la
lutte contre la radicale
a sion la lutte contre le
communautarisme et la question de la
laïcité en plateau pour l'instant nous
parlons bien de la question de la
laïcité jean philippe derosier bien
justement votre regard de
constitutionnalistes sur ce sujet et
puis aussi sur ce qu'a dit tout à
l'heure
bruno retailleau bruno retailleau qui
juge qu'une sortie scolaire ça reste
l'école est donc pour lui et bien il ne
faut pas avoir de signes distinctifs
religieux dans ce cadre là alors pour
essayer de dresser un petit peu le plan
du droit
ce qu'il y a le droit il ya la politique
les deux sont liés mais c'est d'abord le
droit qui est applicable et pour réagir
ce que 10e et disait monsieur sénateurs
sont alors c'est pas parce qu'on est
lillois qui ont souscrit toujours aux
thèses de martine aubry parce que je dis
et en l'espèce je crois pas qu'il y ait
de flou il n'y a pas de flou il y a un
droit dans ses détails
enfin après le premier de la
constitution qui dit que la république
est laïque qu'elle respecte toutes les
croyances
un article un nouvel article dans le
code de l'éducation qui a été inséré
dans l'or par la loi écoles de la
confiance pour ta part les ministres
blanc caire tout à l'heure qui est
l'article l 141 tirer 5-2 du code de
l'éducation qui interdit le prosélytisme
un pas exactement ces termes là mais
c'est très précisément ce que ça veut
dire y compris pendant les sorties
scolaires et donc une accompagnatrice
une sortie qui est un parent une mère ou
un père d'un des élèves qui accompagne
n'est pas un agent du service public
le principe de laïcité de la république
s'appliquent aux agents du service
public pas à ses usagers elle accompagne
la femme dont il est question
aujourd'hui qui a déclenché cette
polémique elle accompagne dans une
sortie tant qu'elle ne fait pas de
prosélytisme si elles faisaient du
prosélytisme et que par son voile elle
allait voir les enfants en leur disant
les petites filles en disant tu sais tu
devrais porter comme ça effectivement ce
serait parfaitement condamnables le
simple fait que elle porte ce vêtement
eh bien ça ne porte pas atteinte au
principe de laïcité et pour terminer sur
ce point là et pour revenir sur la
circonstance on ne veut pas faire de
communautarisme le ministre blanc caire
le dis je je veux je veux lutter contre
le communautarisme et en disant texto le
voile n'est pas souhaitable
c'est très exactement ce qu'il fait il
ne dit pas les signes religieux ne sont
pas souhaitables
il parle très précisément du voile il
stigmatise une communauté en particulier
et cela me semble problématique dans la
bouche d'un ministre qui effectivement
entretient le doute et je comprends ceux
qui le dénoncent entretient le doute
entre une position où le voile n'est pas
souhaitable mais non on ne légifère pas
franck mais non ville est-ce que je vous
jugez que le ministre est en train de
stigmatiser une communauté lorsqu'il dit
le voile n'est pas souhaitable
et quand dans le même temps il dit
qu'une loi n'est pas souhaitable non
plus parce qu'elle serait
contre-productive non je ne pense pas le
ministre a rappelé les grands principes
de la laïcité
néanmoins je crois que ces grands
principes et notamment la loi de 1905 a
évolué ces dernières années notamment
été complétée par la loi de 2004 et ça a
été dit par mon collègue en 2012 aussi
par le ministre chatel
moi je pense qu'il ne faut pas légiférer
dans l'urgence mais non moins il y a
aujourd'hui la nécessité sans doute de
clarifier les choses et notamment
l'école compte de la loi n'y de 2004
effectivement développe et permet de de
rappeler un certain nombre de principes
au niveau 2 de l'école quand vous dites
je tarifier vous seriez favorable à une
proposition de loi qui interdit le voile
à des accompagnants de sorties scolaires
ça que je veux dire c'est pas que je
suis favorable à une à légiférer dans
l'urgence mais en tout cas si je pense
qu'il faut se poser la question
et comme ça a été fait en 2004
effectivement pouvoir faire évoluer la
législation 2000 théâtre actuel si c'est
nécessaire parce que je crois que ce
qu'il veut on ne peut pas non plus
considérer que tout ce qui entoure
l'école ne fait pas partie de l'école et
du processus éducatif donc gérer que moi
je suis large en une
par contre absolument pas pour le voile
mais pour tout signe distinctif
religieux
d'ailleurs la proposition de la part de
là où là je dis qu'il ya un flou c'est
parce que la décision du conseil d'état
de 2013
effectivement remet en cause la
circulaire chatel qui prenez interdisait
le port du voile dans les sorties
scolaires pour les accompagnateurs qui
ne sont pas des agents du service public
mais elle dit aussi qu'en cas de
prosélytisme les directeurs d'école où
les organisateurs de la veuve prendre la
décision de demander à ce que le voit ne
savent pas ne soit pas portée mais est
ce qu il appartient aujourd'hui aux
directeurs d'école aux enseignants de
juger du fait qu'une attitude soit
jeudi liberté égalité fraternité mais
pas naïveté voilà il faut pas non plus
qu'on soit coupable d'une naïveté qui
d'un jour qu'un jour on regrette douleur
législatives introduites dans le code de
l'éducation a dit hélène conway
rapidement tu as en face à rennes dans
un moule amenant devant dire que si nous
commençons par appliquer ce qui existe
correctement nous n'avons pas besoin de
changer sans cesse et de légiférer sans
cesse d'autre part le prosélytisme n'est
pas simplement religieux il peut être
aussi politique
donc je veux dire je pense qu'il faut
faire non mais voilà il faut faire
confiance à la fois aux directeurs
d'école qui sont à même de juger parce
que ils sont au premier rang de ce qui
se passe du prosélytisme ou pas et
d'appliquer la loi telle qu'elle est
tout simplement qu'il faut pas légiférer
dans l'urgence
et vous croyez néanmoins évaluer le
dispositif actuel pour savoir s'il est
adapté à la situation où vivent 3 parce
que là on est on est dans la théorie est
ce que vous croyez que dans un certain
nombre d'établissements plutôt sensible
dans un certain nombre de secteurs
plutôt sensible que nous connaissons
nous qui sommes des élus locaux
un certain nombre d'études de
d'enseignants ou de directeurs d'école
prendront le risque d'aller
contraint certains de nos comportements
et je le promets je pense à la loi doit
peut-être le faire alors je ne dis pas
que c'est nécessaire il faudra peut-être
un débat en tout cas aura lieu le 29
octobre au sénat puisque c'est le jour
où cette proposition de loi sera discuté
en séance
on va passer un deuxième thème qui a été
très marquant lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ce thème est bien c'est l'offensive
turque en syrie il y avait bien une
question du président de la commission
de la défense et des affaires étrangères
christian cambon et la réponse des doors
philippe on écoute les cures de nos
alliés les kurdes nos amis qui se sont
battus avec temps d'héroïsme pour notre
propre sécurité
ce peuple sans patrie ce peuple trahi
une fois de plus ce qui contraint
d'appeler au secours ses ennemis d'hier
comment le temps peut-elle rester sans
réagir
cette absence de réponse me semble
traduire un très grand trouble
pour dire les choses de façon posée est
ce trouble
regardons le en face quiconque aurait
pour discours de dire que l'otan
fonctionne
comme elle a toujours fonctionné
circulez ya rien à voir pardon de le
dire trivialement à mon avis se
tromperait hélène conway bien votre
réaction tout de suite à ce moment fort
pour le coup consensuel qui montre aussi
peut-être et bien l'impuissance
européenne dans cette situation oui
absolument
je crois qu'il ya en effet consensus sur
tous les bancs aujourd'hui de de
l'hémicycle pour dire que nous sommes
devant un fait qui je crois qu'ils nous
désespère et 2 kg et l'incapacité
aujourd'hui à faire cesser cette
opération que nous savons merci aux
meurtrière pour nos amis kurdes mais
également très dangereuse pour nous et
ça pose tout un tas de questions sur
aujourd'hui le rôle de l'état ceux qui
en sont membres
pour quelle raison et de la place des
états unis qui de toute évidence montre
un nouveau signe de leur désengagement à
l'étranger et notamment dans cette
région du monde
je crois que les saoudiens elle avait
déjà notée avec l' attaque iranienne de
drones sur leur territoire alors que
leurs amis américains pour lesquels ils
ont acheté en tout cas de l'armement
très important et investit très très
largement n'ont pas levé le petit doigt
et là on voit à nouveau et bien que
l'ami américain finalement n'est pas aux
côtés de ses alliés traditionnels
cédric perrin les etats unis c'est le
problème et on le voit avec ce blocage
aussi de l'otan qu'amd membre de l'otan
la turquie et les états unis font
cavalier seul chacun de leur côté je
pense que nous sommes en train de vivre
des moments historiques d'un changement
profond en termes de géopolitique
vouziers sais pas si c'était dans votre
propos même aux états unis était la
solution aujourd'hui son problème
aujourd'hui on a une espèce de transfert
les états unis d intérêt en tout cas
vitaux des états unis vers l'asie et un
désengagement des états unis de 2,2 du
pays du moyen-orient et de l'afrique est
aujourd'hui la grande question c'est que
vaut la parole des alliés hélène le
disait fort bien tout à l'heure les a
faits les saoudiens viennent d'en faire
les frais les kurdes viennent d'en faire
les frais qui seront les prochains à en
faire les frais sont peut-être d'autres
pays que nous connaissons bien
donc aujourd'hui il est clair que
l'intervention turque en syrie mais fin
malheureusement à cinq ans d'efforts
importants de la coalition contre d'esch
et avec une possible pense même très
possible reconstitution de l'état
islamique et donc des conséquences que
cela pourrait engendrer pour la france
mais pour l'europe dans sa généralité
parce que on parle parfois de d'un
millier potentiellement des milliers de
djihadistes qui pourrait revenir en
france mais comme le disait fort bien le
ministre des affaires étrangères hier à
la commission c'est pas 2000 dont on
parle c'est de 10000 et qui ne sont pas
eux qui n'ont pas forcément revenir
qu'en france ils vont revenir un peu
partout et potentiellement ce sont des
problèmes qui vont nous tomber dessus
assez rapidement donc une situation très
inquiétante et une attitude américaine
qui je le rappelle quand même ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya deux
événements mon avis ces dix des dix
dernières années il y aura deux
événements qui auront marqué le
désengagement américain c'est 2013 le
refus des frappes et de 13,12 obama
voilà et très simplement pas k donald
ray 13 octobre 2019 trump qui décide
brutalement mais qui décide dans la
ligne politique de ce qu'avait lancé
obama de ne pas intervenir en turquie et
donc on est dans la continuité
malheureusement franck mais non ville
hier jean-yves le drian a dit les
européens doivent arrêter de subir sinon
ils vont sortir de l'histoire
est-ce que vous avez vous aussi mal à
votre union européenne en ce moment non
mais tout à fait je crois que ce qui se
passe actuellement est absolument
dramatique et là la manière de le
surmonter c'est plus d'europe plus
d'europe politique est aussi plus
d'europe de la défense on voit bien
qu'on a sans doute trop compter
sur l'otan sur l'alliance avec les
etats-unis aujourd'hui on voit bien
aussi que les états unis pensent avant
tout à leur stratégie propre et c'est
assez dramatique sûrement actuellement
ce qui se passe et les risques qui lui
désengagement des états unis sur sur
cette scène peut être sans doute assez
dramatique pour la sécurité du
moyen-orient et même et même du monde et
je crois que l'europe doit absolument se
renforcer et exister je pense que
l'europe doit exister l'europe doit
s'organiser le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que l'europe et inorganisé
aujourd'hui la moitié du pib de la
turquie est quasiment été réalisée avec
les pays européens
si les pays européens étaient en
capacité de s'organiser pour infliger
des sanctions sévères à la turquie peut
être qu'elle comprendrait parce que en
face des trois millions et demi de
migrants qu'on nous met dans la balance
il ya peut-être aussi une grosse partie
de l'économie turque qui pourrait être
mise dans la balance
or pourquoi y arriver il faut pouvoir
s'entendre c'est exactement la même
problématique que sur la libye il ya
quelques temps et voilà donc le jour où
on aura construit une europe où on
arrivera à construire une offre qui est
capable de s'entendre sur ces sujets
bien on pourra peser c'est pas le cas
pour le moment hélène conway une entente
qui apporterait aussi une protection
aérienne et qui protégerait aujourd'hui
les populations qui sont bombardés parce
qu'il faut savoir quand même réalisé que
la turquie n'a pas envahi comme nous
l'avons annoncé dans les médias français
la syrie il a quand même des frappes
aériennes qui pourraient peut-être ne
pas exister si nous étions capables de
résister protéger le le ciel et l'espace
moi je voulais simplement dire que la
défense européenne ce n'est pas gagné
pendant six mois avec un collègue nous
avons travaillé sur ce sujet nous ont
présenté un rapport la commission des
affaires étrangères qui a été adoptée en
juillet dernier et ce que nous avons pu
voir c'est que nous avons en fait un
bloc atlantiste qui craint de l'embêter
ou d'énerver les américains qui
risquerait de se désintéresser de nous
et puis un bloc un peu plus à l'ouest et
au sud de pays dont qui en aucune
analyse des menaces
un petit peu différente et qui est
beaucoup plus indépendants mais qui
n'arrive pas à entraîner les 28es en
tout cas les vingt-sept demain
dans une coalition européenne les gens
disent souvent des crânes vers l'est ce
qui est inquiétant c'est le signe astori
gens lisent les russes ce qui est
inquiétant c'est le cynisme dont font
preuve les organisations internationales
on était avec hélène conway mouret ce
week end à londres le cadre de la paix
autant on a entendu solberg alors qu'il
était interrogé à nouveau par le
président de la commission de la défense
nous redire qu'il fallait que la turquie
agissent avec retenue mais ça veut dire
quoi agir avec retenue ça veut dire en
gros au lieu d'envoyer dix bombes vous
leur envoyez que cinq quoi c'est
hallucinant on a des positions qui se
côtoient hallucinante hallucinante
quel cynisme de nos organisations
internationales jean philippe derosier
j'ai pas beaucoup de choses à ajouter
sur ce que vient de dire madame et
monsieur les sénateurs la situation est
effectivement dramatique est la cause de
ce problème là c'est qu'effectivement du
fait d'une dune tensions politiques
internes à l'europe parce que c'est la
tension politique interne à l'europe qui
fait qu'on a pas d'europe de la défense
si on était tous d'accord pour en faire
une y en a réuni depuis 50 ans il n'y a
de ce fait là il n'y a qu'un seul
gendarme et à partir du moment où il n'y
a qu'un seul gendarme pour quoi que ce
soit et bien dès qu'il est défaillant ou
que partial et bien il ya personne pour
prendre le relais c'est comme si sur un
terrain de foot il ya qu un seul arbitre
et ben il peut pas tout voir il peut pas
s'occuper de tout c'est pour ça que on
en met on en met plusieurs parce que il
se ils se complètent et et là il est
indispensable mais ça fait des années
qu'on le dit il est indispensable que
l'europe de la défense et que l'europe
existe au niveau sécurité et défense
international pas seulement de ces
territoires mais également à l'extérieur
pour pouvoir effectivement soit tordre
le bras soit pallier la carence des
états unis donc je pense un seul instant
en une europe de la défense
ce soit que les photos ce qu'il faut je
pense qu'il faut clarifier les choses je
pense qu'il est important de parler de
coopération européenne en matière de
défense c'est différent d'une europe de
la défense parce qu'on perd ce vous
croyez que la france toujours pas donné
la souveraineté de la bombe nucléaire à
l'allemagne la cantine non ça ne peut
pas exister et une armée dans laquelle
une armée avec des bérets
dans laquelle tout le monde s'engage à
je n'y crois pas en quoi c'est une
coopération en matière industrielle en
matière de politique de défense c'est ça
qui est important
mais par pitié arrêtons de faire croire
comme l'a fait croire le président de la
république à quelques temps qu'on allait
faire une armée européenne ça n'a pas de
sens et ça n'arrivera pas oui mais
problème c'est les montrent un sens vous
en avez parlé au début de cette
discussion sur et bien le risque de la
dispersion des djihadistes et de leurs
familles c'est clairement une grande
menace pour la france a dit frédéric
péchenard
tout à l'heure il a été question il
vient de la résurgence de dèche
c'est un certain danger aux portes de la
france et pour la france et pour
l'europe dans son ensemble important
hélène conway mais bien évidemment
d'autant que ces personnes reviendront
avec une certaine vengeance et certaines
d'entraînement qu'il n'avait pas
auparavant aux faits militaires et et
quelques exactions qu'il aurait pu
commettre et qui en font des personnes
incroyablement dangereuse avec aussi
quand on parle de radicalisation en
france je crois que la radicalité de ces
personnes là va bien au-delà de ce que
nous connaissons sur le territoire
aujourd'hui
et donc quand on voit le peu de succès
que nous avons à ramener ces personnes à
une sorte de normalité c'est pas le
terme à utiliser mais je pense que vous
comprendrez je crois que vraiment il y à
un grave danger de menaces terroristes
et d'attentats mais également de flux
migratoires importants qui ne sont pas
sans conséquence sur une déstabilisation
de nos démocraties avec la montée des
populismes et de l'extrême droite que
l'on connaît déjà
alors on a beaucoup parlé de fragilité
européenne à notre facteur de fragilité
pour l'europe et bien c'est le break
site
lebrac cite personne ne sait à peu près
où on en est tout le monde nage un peu
dans la purée de pois vous avez posé une
question à franck mais non viella ce
sujet déjà ce que vous êtes rassurés par
le fait que michel barnier le
négociateur du break site se veulent
rassurants il nous dit encore
aujourd'hui un accord est encore très
possible faut dire que l'on est acculé
vous
y croyez vous à rassurer sa fédé
plusieurs semaines et mois qu'on nous
annonce un accord possible donc je reste
prudent il c'est le sens de ma question
et on peut pas forcément dire d'ailleurs
que la réponse était étaient très
précises
en tout cas par contre
rassuré sur le fait que ce soit de
michel barnier entre autres qui qui est
un qui connaît parfaitement le dossier
qui mène les négociations qui est
extrêmement exigeant parce que je crois
que oui oui mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que face au brésil
il faut être absolument exigeants sur
les sur le contour de l'accord parce que
rien ne serait pire qu'un canaccord où
on concéderait trop de largesses au
royaume uni et quand on se lève content
c'est aussi les ce que j'ai évoquées
dans ma question les rapports et la
stratégie développée par les états unis
mme je crois que il en dira ça pourrait
fortement compromettre l'unité de
l'europe et même mêmes sans efficacité
donc il faut certes un accord met un bon
accord et je crois que si le temps que
tant qu effectivement l'accord n'est pas
satisfaisant et bien le voilà un accord
exigeant
jean philippe derosier finalement dans
cette situation n'est que dans des
premières qui s'enchaînent on ne sait
absolument pas ce qui va se passer
personne n'aurait prédit il ya trois ans
que l'on pourrait arriver vers un autre
dit il enfin bon tous et c'est un gros
miroir très opaque pour vous que ce
proxy bleus
le no deal sincèrement personnellement
je n'y crois pas il faut pas oublier que
celui celui qui est souverain au royaume
uni c'est le parlement et le parlement a
très clairement dit qu'il ne voulait pas
de nos deals d'ebay cet élément il à
votre accord on l'a voté une loi
contraignant boris johnson a cl aboutir
à un accord accord qui si jamais celui
qui est proposé par boris johnson le
premier ministre au conseil européen est
acceptée par les manettes doit encore
être soumis au parlement à westminster
donc à la chambre des communes et à la
chambre des lords et c'est pas dit que
la chambre des communes le valide donc
on est encore assez loin au moins dans
la procédure de la validation d'un break
sites au 31 octobre
c'est bien que la seule chose dont on
soit certain c'est qu'on ne sait rien un
petit peu à l'instar de socrate et que
effectivement ça fait trois ans que l'on
voit à quel point il est difficile de
sortir de l'union y compris lorsque l'on
est un pays puissant tel le royaume uni
et je crois que ça c'est déjà un premier
message et juridique et politique très
fort envoyé à l'union européenne
on peut sortir formellement c'est
possible mais pour la mise en oeuvre
c'est quand même extrêmement difficile
cédric perrin jean philippe desrosiers
ne crois pas au no deal en tout cas est
bien le parlement s'y est préparé parce
qu'il ya eu un rapport qui a été rendu
sur le désastre que serait le no deal
par par le sénat ce serait effectivement
une grande catastrophe ce serait une
catastrophe pour nous pour les
britanniques et je pense qu'ils feront
il faut tout faire pour l'éviter mais il
ya une jurisprudence assez constante ou
réguliers en tout cas du ou de
westminster sur des refus ces derniers
temps donc je crois que bruce johnson
avec toutes les bonnes intentions qui
c'est une blague l'animent aura tout
intérêt à y parvenir mais c'est vrai que
les conséquences sont assez assez
inquiétante moche quand on suit ces
sujets notamment en matière de défense
enfin de défense européen aujourd'hui
quand il faut quand même comprendre que
les nounous seuls nos principaux
partenaires sont aux opérations acteurs
sont britanniques qui sont pas d'autres
pays de l'union européenne donc on a
besoin de continuer à travailler avec
eux alors il ya des accords de lancaster
house évidemment mais il ya beaucoup de
choses qui font qu'aujourd'hui nos
partenaires importants essentielles sur
bien des sujets sont britanniques
on a besoin d'arriver à travailler avec
et on peut pas avoir en tout cas on peut
pas c'est compliqué de me dire oh
de se positionner en disant écoutez vous
pouvez avoir
vous pouvez refuser d'être en europe
mais vous continuerez à avoir les
avantages qui vont avec quoi c'est à
dire c'est vous refusez vous vous partez
mais vous pouvez pas avoir ce qui vous
arrange les refuser ce qui vous arrange
pas c'est quoi un peu compliqué une
autre britannique annonce stratégique
bon en même temps moi ce que j'ai noté à
londres c'est en discutant avec nos amis
anglais c'est qu'ils sont tous
aujourd'hui prêt à sortir avec accor ou
sans accord mais je crois que au bout de
trois ans il ya une énorme lassitude et
qu'ils veulent tous en finir même libre
e-mails ne nous dise ouvertement voilà
il faut que ça s'arrête même dominique
strauss-kahn a le droit de voter et donc
ils sont tous aujourd'hui dans cet état
d'esprit où il faut que ça s'arrête il
faut qu'ils passent à autre chose
donc c'est vrai que ça crée notamment
pour nos français que j'ai rencontré
donc le week-end dernier une grosse
inquiétude
pendant très longtemps ils sont restés
dans l'état d'esprit de dire de toute
façon on peut être que ça ne va pas se
passer avec cet espoir que le président
n'aura pas lieu si bien qu'aujourd'hui
alors que si le break site a lieu le 31
octobre
il faut que tous les ressortissants
étrangers sur le sol britannique est
rempli un formulaire qui s'appelle cette
attaque pour être en conformité ne pas
être illégalement sur le sol britannique
seule la moitié des français inscrits au
consulat l'ont fait parce qu'il était
dans ce déni de
une réalité qu'elle fait trois ans qu'on
a mais cela fait trois ans de déni mais
mais l'ambassadrice ou disait que en
trois semaines ils ont ils ont eu dix
mille inscrits supplémentaires mais
beaucoup ont pris la nationalité
britannique aussi donc on voit qu'il se
passe quelque chose qu'il va se passer
quelque chose enfin et je pense que nous
sommes tous heureux de pouvoir en sortir
parce que nous avons tous vécu le bric
sitcom c'est dallas chaque jour il avait
un épisode nouveau et on se dit bon il
faut qu'un jour l'épisode final est ce
qu'il y aura un meurtre qui disparaîtra
en tout cas ça sans être un bon franck
mais non vie de la fin de dallas c'est
peut-être le conseil européen
jeudi vendredi de farid un an et demi je
crois que le madame monsieur barnier
doit intervenir en cette fin d'après
midi on aura peut-être quelques
informations supplémentaires
jean philippe derosier bon voilà on
croise les doigts en attendant les
annonces de michel barnier il faut dire
que ça serait une situation terrible le
quart no deal on en parlait pourrait
bien tout c'est citoyens britanniques
qui vivent en europe et pour tous ses
citoyens européens qui vivent au royaume
uni notamment millions oui oui le no
deal serait là la pire des situations
il yal inverse du no deal qui est qu'il
reste on apprend que donald tusk dit que
les bases de l'accord sont prêtes donc
il ya encore une marche qui vient d'être
franchie quand il ya la cour chaque
seconde
voilà le décor mills effectivement mais
les bases de l'accord sont prêtes et il
faut que ce soit accepté par les 27
d'accord ça c'est sûr mais encore une
fois j'insiste il faut que l'accord soit
validée par le parlement est d'abord par
la chambre des communes et johnson le
contrôle ni la chambre des communes ni
même sa propre majorité
donc là haut niveau au niveau politique
la situation est extrêmement incertaines
extrêmement incertain vous dit la même
chose cédric perrin s'est endettée à
londres ce week-end j'ai vu ce qui s'y
passe et j'ai vu la quiétude des gens
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement de
rebondissements dans ses affaires que je
me garderai bien pour tous autour de la
reine qui est très important ça faisait
deux ans qu'elle ne s'était pas exprimé
publiquement et qui très clairement
donné la liste de tout ce qu'il est allé
être mises en place après le bric site
donc je pense que dans l'esprit des gens
le bric site va avoir lieu
d'une façon ou d'une autre après pour
nous tous
je crois que nous saurions soulager
qu'en effet il y à un accord parce que
nous savons ce qui a été négocié nous
savons notamment en matière de défense
et de sécurité
ce qu'il y a dans cet accord est la
possibilité de continuer à travailler
avec nos amis britanniques sans accord
c'est vrai que c'était le saut
dans l'inconnu et auquel était prêt
boris johnson pour faire monter les
enchères et parce que il est en campagne
il faut le savoir comme donald trump
l'est aussi avec les décisions qu'il
prend ils sont en campagne électorale
pour une une population qui les soutient
et des votes qui vont du faut quand même
signaler
pour compléter ce que dit hélène que la
reine a lu le discours de son premier
gorille johnson à la virgule près c'est
pas son texte à m
comme toujours importants comme qu'elle
donnait son étoile a été dit bon eh bien
merci à tous d'avoir participé en tout
cas ce débat qui est il faut le dire
toujours aussi nébuleux peut-être que la
clarté sera au bout du tunnel sur le
bret site
je parle pas du tunnel sous la manche
alors merci beaucoup cédric perrin merci
beaucoup hélène conway mouret merci
franck mais non ville merci beaucoup je
suis fier d'avoir participé à cette
discussion
merci à tous d'avoir débriefer tous
ensemble cette preuve que cette séance
de questions d'actualité dit mercredi au
sénat
l'actualité parlementaire justement elle
continue sur public sénat tout de suite
on vous a sélectionné les temps forts de
l'examen du projet de loi sur le statut
de l'élu
les sénateurs débattent de ce texte
depuis une grosse semaine et là il
arrive à l'un des points phares de ce
texte le renforcement des pouvoirs de
police du maire
quelques remarques puisque nous allons
effectivement avoir un certain nombre
d'articles qui concerne le renforcement
des pouvoirs de police du maire
peut-être monsieur le ministre en tout
cas vous interpeller sur ce que disent
les élus et vous réfère pelé d'abord
parce que je crois quand on parle de
renforcement du pouvoir du maire un
certain délit voudraient d'abord que le
pouvoir puis le poids existence soit
effectif et court pour mener à bien ce
pouvoir de police du maire déjà dans
celui qui existe il y a bien évidemment
besoin d'un véritable accompagnement sur
le terrain un accompagnement en amont
pour l'aide à la prise de décision bien
évidemment un accompagnement au moment
pour l'effectivité de ce pouvoir je le
disais et puis un accompagnement par la
suite pour prendre en compte les
difficultés auxquelles parfois peuvent
être confrontés un certain nombre d'élus
donc il ne donne
ne suffirait pas en tout cas de se
satisfaire par un certain nombre
d'articles tel que rédigé dans le projet
de loi initial ou même tel que rédigé ou
rajouter ici par le sénat pour se dire
qu' il n'y aurait plus besoin demain
d'une présence de l'état qui viennent en
soutien à la prise de décision des élus
loto du des élus locaux pardon qu'il n'y
aurait plus besoin en tout cas moins
besoin d'une présence de gendarmerie ou
de police parce que à un moment donné
l'effectivité de ce pouvoir de police
justement est parfois mis en opposition
en contradiction face à l'absence en
tout cas des personnels des forces de
gendarmerie et de police sur l'ensemble
de nos territoires je crois en tout cas
qu'ils ont été nombreux à l'exprimer
c'est derniers mois donc voilà d'une
façon générale j'ai envie de dire sur
cet article 10 12 pardon je voudrais
décidément l'article 12 et les suivants
ce qui évitera de se répéter dans les
articles qui vont suivre
désolé merci madame kuperman la parole
est à monsieur olivier jacque
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre va faire une communication un
peu particulière sur ce chapitre dont le
titre ii vise à renforcer les pouvoirs
de police et évoquer la problématique de
la responsabilité pénale des mères
lorsque officiers police judiciaire ils
exercent leur devoir il arrive qu en
l'exerçant et bien la justice puisse se
retourner contre eux je vous donnerai à
cet effet une correspondance précise
d'un maire de mon département qui
sollicitent président de la république
c'est un cas récent dans mon département
dans une petite commune le maire
appelons le jean-claude expérimenté très
humain vraiment très humain pas du tout
un shérif un gars violent bien un soir
de 14 juillet avant le lancement du feu
d'artifice il y avait des troubles dans
un groupe et donc pour l'apaiser il y va
seul et une altercation s'en suit il se
défend mais à 20 ans
contraint en termes de témoignages la
justice a tranché cet échange de coups
par un jugement de salomon 50 50 et le
condamnant à une somme substantielle de
1100 euros
le maire en train de faire appel j'en
donne pas de détails bien évidemment le
même soir les perturbateurs sont venus à
son domicile et ont ont saccagé des
biens
il a porté plainte mais là n'ayant
certainement pas à cette preuve la
sphère a été classée sans suite
alors imaginez la désespérance de ce
maire qui se retrouve dans une telle
situation
bien évidemment il n'y a pas de police
municipale bien évidemment il n'y a pas
de gendarmerie sur place et la situation
est pénible et monsieur le ministre je
ne vois pas dans ce texte de
dispositions qui vont permettre deux
premiers protéger les élus qui comme
jean claude prenne pleinement à coeur
leurs fonctions merci monsieur jacques
un la parole est à monsieur hervé maurey
merci à la présidente moi je voudrais
attirer l'attention du ministre sur un
sujet qu'elle jouait à connaître dans un
département qu'il connaît bien et qui
concerne le pouvoir de police du maire
en matière d'immeubles menaçant ruine
lorsqu il y a notamment un risque
d'insolvabilité du propriétaire
vous le savez tous lorsqu'il ya un
immeuble qui menace ruine
le maire est tenu de mettre en oeuvre la
procédure de péril qui prévoit une mise
en demeure du propriétaire pour qu'il
exécute les travaux
et s'il ne le fait pas le maire doit
exécuter deux fils ses travaux à charge
de se faire rembourser par le
propriétaire
le problème qui se pose c'est lorsqu'il
ya insolvabilité du propriétaire que
celle ci soit réel ou organisée
et donc là on se trouve devant une
situation difficile encore une fois
c'est un exemple qui vient du
département dont je suis élu ou un mère
n'ose pas enclencher la procédure et
n'osent pas surtout faire faire deux
fils des travaux sur un bâtiment une
maison sachant très bien qu'ils risquent
ensuite de ne pas pouvoir se faire
rembourser et donc on est dans cette
situation juridique compliqué notamment
et principalement pour le maire qui
quelque part engage sa responsabilité en
ne faisant pas preuve procéder à ces
travaux d'office mais qui ne veut pas le
faire parce qu'il sait très bien qu'il
ne sera pas remboursé et que la commune
n'a pas les moyens financiers de
supporter la remise en état de cette
maison alors j'ai pas déposer
d'amendement sur ce sujet mais
j'aimerais peut-être que comme ministre
puisse m'éclairer sur la situation
juridique et sur la et la manière dont
on pourrait envisager une évolution de
la législation sur ce point peut-être
dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire
merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il est minuit presque et je vous propose
de prolonger notre séance jusqu'à minuit
et demi afin de poursuivre l'examen de
ce texte s'il n'ya pas d'observation il
en est ainsi décidé voilà nous
poursuivons donc jusqu'à minuit et demi
alors nous passons maintenant l'examen
des amendements le 360 tombe puis ce qui
n'est pas défendu le 771 rectifier les
présentes aient peur madame grès home
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mais chaque collègue par cet
amendement de suppression partielle nous
refusons que ce projet de loi sur
l'engagement des élus soit vue comme une
opportunité pour augmenter d amende
ce qui autorise entrerait ce texte vers
une logique de répression qui n'est pas
son but
en effet la commission des lois a
profité de l'examen du texte pour
accroître le montant de l'amendé en cas
de manquement à un arrêté relatif à une
fermeture d'établissement
cette sanction parce passant de 3750
euros d'amendé à 10000 euros soit bien
plus du double si nous approuvons la
nécessité de tout
né sur certains sujets davantage de
pouvoir au maire pour faire respecter
ses décisions
nous refusons que ce dernier devienne un
gendarme distribuant des amendes
nous refusons qui porte sur ses épaules
ce poids qui pourra se retourner contre
lui
par ailleurs nous ne prenons pas côte
nous ne pensons pas que tout peut se
régler par des amendes ni que c'est à la
hauteur de son montant que la sanction
sera davantage respectée et que le
trouble originel cessera l'état doit
donner les moyens aux communes de faire
respecter la loi
non pas par des nombres que l'on change
sur le chéquier des citoyens mais sur
les effectifs et les moyens matériels
que l'état assure auprès des communes en
préservant développant des services
publics et sa présence où cela est
nécessaire
mieux accompagner les communes ce n'est
pas augmenter les possibilités de
répression si madame grès aux mains
monsieur le rapporteur pour la vie de la
commission oui mais la présidente il ne
s'agit ici en aucun cas de se borner à
la seule augmentation des des amendes
encore moins d'exposer le maire a des
responsabilités qu'il n'entendrait pas
lui-même en dos et pour autant je veux
insister sur le fait que la peine
d'amendé prévue n'a rien de
disproportionné quand on sait les
conséquences pour la sécurité des
personnes
que peut avoir un tel comportement ou
des comportements auxquels sont soumis
les maires donc bien sûr ce sera un avis
défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
oui avis défavorable avis défavorable
pas d'explications de vote
explications de votre main agréable on
parle qui a pas de répression mais
n'empêche on a quand même reçu des
maires qu'ils ont été molestés merci
chers collègues je mets aux voix
l'amendement 771 rectifier avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 963 et donc monsieur
d'arnaud va nous le présenter merci
mister monsieur le ministre si ces
matériels c'est favorable
alors avis favorable du gouvernement je
mets au voile amendement 963 qui et pour
qui comptent qui s'abstient il est
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 12 qui
est pour contre
attention il est adopté après l'article
12 un amendement 841 rectifier les
présentée par monsieur raison merci
madame la présidente madame et monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre la
france est un beau pays mais lorsque
vous la traversée au gré des villages ou
des hameaux on peut voir ça ou là des
dépôts sauvages ça peut être des frigos
des machines à laver des chauffe-eau des
voitures et le maire se trouve sans
pouvoir de police pour pallier à ce
problème est donc cet amendement vise à
permettre aux mères d'utiliser leurs
pouvoirs de police pour lutter contre
ces décharges privé au même titre qu'ils
peuvent le faire pour aujourd'hui
des publicités qui vous marquent une
pollution visuelle importante donc cet
amendement est en même temps très
important pour donner le pouvoir
nécessaire au maire mais pour que notre
france soit encore plus belle et
respecter encore plus l'environnement il
monsieur raison monsieur le rapporteur
avis de la commission
oui je comprends tout à fait les
motivations de notre collègue michel
raison pour autant il me semble que cet
amendement qui vise à renforcer les
pouvoirs de police du maire pour lutter
contre les décharges privé et dans
l'esprit satisfait et il ne nous semble
pas souhaitable d'introduire un
dispositif des initiatives spécifiques
qui serait source de complexité sera une
demande de retrait ou à défaut un avis
défavorable
oui ma présente merci monsieur c
une fois plus l'âge aussi jeu je vais
dans le sens de ce que vous souhaitez
faire
néanmoins on va vers une superposition
de procédure avec cet amendement donc en
fait il en partie déjà satisfait par non
seulement les dispositions telles
qu'elles sont présentées par le
gouvernement mais aussi par les travaux
de la commission
tel que le texte a été amendé donc
demande de retrait monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur le ministre je vois
monsieur raison vous retirer votre
amendement
je suis a pu perturber jeu je peux avoir
confiance envers autant le ministre que
le rapporteur mais si on est jamais trop
sûrs d'être satisfaits dans ses couteaux
là parce que j'ai l'habitude qu'on nous
explique lorsque l'amendement convient
pas parfaitement
ne vous inquiétez pas il est satisfait
moi je suis pas facilement satisfait
donc par principe mais j'ai confiance en
eux quand même mais je le maintiens
quand même
monsieur raison maintenant son
amendement je propose donc de vous le
soumettre aux voix
il a donc un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui contre s'abstient les alors on
recommence kippour
ce
qui est contre
tu s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée après
l'article 12 un amendement 886 rectifier
il est présenté par madame noisy merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à donner des outils
adaptés aux maires afin de mieux
répondre au risque croissant d'un sont
dit qu'ils sont liés on le sait on l'a
vu malheureusement ces derniers mois aux
sécheresses aux fortes chaleurs il
propose donc de donner la possibilité
aux maires qui le jugerait utile
d'instaurer des obligations légales de
débroussaillement sur les périmètres
jugés à risque de leur commune ça
concerne donc essentiellement des
taillis des forêts aux abords des
habitations des particuliers
sylvain a moisi monsieur le rapporteur
oui madame la présidente je ne voudrais
pas abusé de la confiance de nos
collègues
pas plus notre collègue loisier que
notre collègue raison mais je puis vous
assurer qu en l'état du droit
cet amendement est satisfait donc ce
sera une demande de retrait monsieur le
ministre avait gouvernement oui mais à
présent je fais
nous sommes en confiance et au droit et
aux rapporteurs donc même avis demande
de retrait madame waziers je
souhaiterais juste aucune précision ce
qui me semblait que actuellement le
dispositif était d'abord à la main des
préfets et que c'était des périmètres
qui est définie par le préfet que dans
ces périmètres effectivement les maires
pouvaient mettre en place des eaux elle
d mais s'il n'y a pas de périmètre et on
le voit aujourd'hui avec un danger de
risque d'un syndic qui remonte on a on
peut être on peut avoir des communes un
peu éparpillé qui ne justifient pas donc
une une décision du préfet donc pas de
décret à l'échelle départementale ou
régionale donc est ce que vous pouvez me
répondre sur ce point monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre
merci bien à présent il n'y a pas de
décret départementale se serait arrêté
le cas échéant pour le pour le préfet
qu'est ce qui est possible de faire
aujourd'hui bien souvent dans les faits
les maires saisissent le préfet le
préfet donne droit ce que demandent les
mères tout cacher des situations
contraire je suis prêt à y regarder de
près ça m'intéressera beaucoup
et préfet aussi seront contents je m'y
intéresse deuxième chose
enfin en principe deuxième chose il ya
déjà des obligations potentiel à la main
du titre de la police générale du maire
des obligations déjà de débroussaillage
sont possibles par décision du maire en
police administratifs dans les faits
donc tout ça déjà satisfait madame
choisi vous le retirer merci beaucoup
donc l'amendement 886 rectifier et
retiré après l'article 12 un amendement
887 rectifié madame brasier monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
l'avons beaucoup évoqué les maires des
petites communes rurales sont souvent
isolés lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à des
difficultés dans le cadre de l'exercice
de leur pouvoir de police la gendarmerie
a mis en place depuis quelques mois un
dispositif de référents sécurité sur un
certain nombre de territoires qui a
montré beaucoup de d'efficacité et donc
cet amendement propose de généraliser le
principe du référent sécurité qui
permettrait donc au maire de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur un personnel est un
professionnel qualifié qu'à même de le
second thé dans des tâches de police qui
on l'a vu sont souvent et de plus en
plus délicate
merci mesdames et monsieur le rapporteur
avis de la commission
mais maintenant la présidente cette idée
qui est une idée de bon sens d'autant
plus qu'elle fait partie des des
propositions qui ont été formulées à
maintes reprises
par les maires consultés lors de la
grande concertation et consultation du
sénat qui a donné lieu à des
propositions faites par le président de
la commission des lois il ya de cela
quinze jours et parmi ces propositions
bien sûr l'idée d'avoir un référent à
s'imposer de façon assez assez
généralisé pour autant si l'idée nous
paraît intéressante à creuser
elle nous paraît plus relever de bonnes
pratiques locales plutôt que de faire
l'objet d'une inscription dans la loi
donc si nous comprenons les motivations
si nous les partageons ce sera toutefois
une demande de retrait appelant plutôt
les maires et les autorités aux de
police ou de gendarmerie a engagé ces
dispositions sont donc ce sera à vis de
retrait demande de retrait pardon ou
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mais la
présence merci pour cet amendement
madame la sénatrice ce matin aux
invalides le général d'armée richard
lizurey fait ses adieux aux armes
après de longs mois et de longues années
au service notre république est
justement dans les grandes orientations
tels que la fameuse circulaire cent
mille et pris quelques orientations sur
la visibilité des gendarmes sur la
capacité à retisser dans le lien armée
nation un certain nombre de choses il y
avait justement cette pratique du
référent en clair une commune en face un
sous-officier gendarmerie référent pour
le maire en question est activable
autant que de besoin
dans les faits c'est déjà généralisé ce
n'est pas que en côte d'or que l'on
connaît bien cette cette pratique en
tout cas j'espère qu'en côte-d'or ça
fonctionne bien le cas échéant je me
permettrait de vérifier là aussi
le préfet de région sera ravie de puisse
vérifier sur toutes les questions de
dijonnaise nous occupe beaucoup par
ailleurs comme vous le savez donc là
dessus je crois qu'il est déjà satisfait
comme l'a dit le rapporteur
l'organisation des forces de sécurité
intérieure ne sont pas du niveau de la
loi mais bel et bien de l'organisation
des de ses forces
d'ailleurs votre amendement m'appelle
cette vérification qu'il nous faudra
faire autant que je crois pouvoir vous
dire que ces choses sont systématiques
pour les autres gendarmerie même s'il
peut y avoir toujours quelques loupés
quelqu'un on peut les on peut les
corriger
il faut veiller à ce que en zone police
nationale les choses soient aussi
systématique mais comme le disait le
sénateur roger tout à l'heure qui est
parti dans les zones policiers souvent
elles sont de celles spd qui fonctionne
parce que les zones police en général
beaucoup plus dense donc demande de
retrait en tout cas vous avez eu raison
de mettre un coup de projecteur sur sur
cette affaire qui est quelque chose
d'essentiel et qui globalement a changé
quand même pas mal là les choses ces
dernières années ou enfin l'argent parle
de manière en tant qu ancien réserviste
dans cette arme je peux en parler
longuement mais après de longues années
où les procédures étaient très complexes
relations entre les élus et la
gendarmerie parce que fallait
systématiquement passés par les
autorités hiérarchiques en clair comment
groupement commandant de compagnie là
les référents mais beaucoup de bon sens
entre un gendarme - chef ou un étudiant
on la juge en chef est directement le
maire de la commune concernée
et ça pour le coup c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt robuste et efficace donc merci en
tout cas d'avoir fait cet amendement
d'appel pour nous permettre de
généraliser cela même si c'est déjà le
cas de veiller à ce que ce soit bien
fait en zone police
madame loisirs mais merci c'était
effectivement plus un amendement d'appel
mais je confirme que même si le
dispositif a vocation à être généralisée
il n'est pas toujours pris au sérieux
par les uns comme par les autres donc je
pense qu'on a là un bel outil qui
pourrait répondre à beaucoup de
difficultés sur nos territoires merci
donc merci chers collègues la maman 887
rectifié est retiré et nous passons à
l'article 13 d'abord la maman 361 qui
n'est pas défendu
le 91 rectifier il est présenté par
nathalie delattre chers collègues merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en premier lieu vous dire qu'en gironde
cet art qui n'est pas vraiment voulu par
une majorité des maires qui pensent
qu'en la matière il était plutôt utile
d'avoir le préfet comme filtre a
cependant cet amendement exploite le
sujet en s'intéressant à un autre volet
qui est l'ouverture de ces
établissements de ces débits de boissons
sur lequel le maire n'a même pas le
droit aujourd'hui d'émettre un avis
consultatif
alors que lors de la déclaration le
maire est en charge de récolter les
différents justificatifs et de vérifier
que le dossier est complet une fois que
ce dossier complet le maire doit
délivrer le récépissé à la personne qui
souhaite rouvrir cet établissement dans
les trois jours
il doit transmettre procureur de la
république et au préfet du département
copie intégrale de la déclaration et
c'est tout pourtant lors de ce transfert
le maire pourrait avoir le droit de
formaliser un avis consultatif sur le
dossier et mettre ainsi en cohérence les
pouvoirs qui lui sont donnés dans cette
danse projet de loi concernant la
fermeture des établissements avec un
avis sur l'ouverture de préciser que
dans le cadre d'une demande de transfert
d'un débit de boisson d'une commune à
une autre
le préfet a d'ores et déjà l'obligation
de consulter le maire de la commune où
le débit de boisson va être installée
mais comme le propose aussi cet
amendement leur avis ne lie pas le
préfet il l'a vous l'aurez compris dans
un souci de cohérence
il est proposé que le maire puisse
donner un avis sur une implantation de
débits de boisson le troisième et de
quatrième catégorie et des
établissements pourvu de la petite
licence restaurant ou de la licence
restaurant décision qui impacte parfois
lourdement le territoire de sa commune
merci merci madame delattre monsieur le
rapporteur avis de la commission
la présidente je voudrais juste rappeler
à notre collègue nathalie delattre un
psy je comprends encore une fois les
raisons de cet amendement de l'ouverture
d'un débit de boisson est soumise à un
régime de déclaration
administrative et non d'autorisation
administrative en conséquence le refus
d'ouverture d'un débit de boisson ne
s'apprécient pas en opportunité le
préfet une compétence liée et se
contente de vérifier la régularité et la
situation du déclarant si que le respect
de la législation applicable aux débits
de boissons en particulier des quotas
d'installation sur le territoire de la
commune dans ce contexte la vie du maire
n'aurait aucune valeur ajoutée pardon
notons en outre qu'un avis simple qui ne
lirai pas le préfet ne serait pas de
nature à renforcer les pouvoirs de
police du maire ce sera donc un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
oui madame la présidente même avis que
le rapporteur je rajouterais quand même
peut-être pas même la sainterie that
quand parts il peut être satisfait si
l'on regarde que parfois ce lieu sera un
rpg établissements recevant du public
est là par ailleurs vous avez les
procédures que vous connaissez sur sur
les erp et donc demande de retrait ou
avis défavorable vous maintenez
l'amendement donc l'amendement étant
maintenue je le mets au voit donc il a
un avis défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui pour qui contre et
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
avons cinq amendement faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune
le premier le 489 rectifié lycée
présentée par monsieur canevet merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues avec plusieurs
collègues nous nous sommes interrogés
effectivement sur cette disposition qui
tendrait a confié au maire la police
spéciale des débits de boisson le maire
a déjà une compétence pour pouvoir
enregistrer les déclarations des
migrations et puis pour aussi pouvoir
octroyer des autorisations plus tardive
pour jusqu'à un certain horaire mais
quel est véritablement l'intérêt de le
doter d'une compétence supplémentaire en
la matière parce que les problèmes de
police sur les débits de boisson
requiert la présence des forces de
l'ordre que ce soit la gendarmerie en
zone rurale où la police s'en sont
urbaines et à qui ses organes vont en
référé bien entendu aux préfets
puisqu'ils sont sous l'autorité du
préfet sont pas sous l'autorité du maire
et donc il convient que ce soit le
préfet qui l'assurent d'autant plus qu'
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même dans
ses dispositions la nécessité d'une
approche qui soit global et cette
approche globale seul le préfet peut
l'exercice puisqu'il a une vue globale
sur l'ensemble du département et non pas
simplement une vue partielle au cas par
cas et si l'on veut véritablement qu'il
et d'équité dans le traitement sur un
même département vis-à-vis de situations
d'incivilité ou de difficultés et bien
c'est vraiment le préfet qui a la
possibilité de l'assumer donc c'est le
sens de cet amendement qui vise à
supprimer 11 alinéa de cet article pour
faire en sorte que et bien le dispositif
actuel puisse perdurer
merci monsieur canevet la parole est
maintenant à monsieur cabanel pour
défendre le 212 rectifier merci madame
la présidente je me serais cherche
collègues il est proposé par cet
amendement de remplacer le délai de
fermeture de deux mois maximum par un
délai de deux mois reconductible afin de
permettre au préfet ou maire de
reconduire le délai de fermeture si
aucune solution n'a été trouvée pour
mettre fin au trouble à l'ordre public
provoqué par le débit de boissons car il
arrive bien souvent que la fermeture de
deux mois ne suffisent pas à faire
rentrer dans l'ordre des comportements
illicites
si monsieur cabanel la dame laverhne va
défendre le 118 rectifié bis et le 119
en même temps puisque vers ces deux
amendements je suis le porte-parole de
notre collègue philippe dallier qui les
a déposés donc en l'état actuel du texte
l'article 13 du projet de loi vise à
transférer un des pouvoirs du préfet
visées à l'article l 33 32 15 du code de
la santé publique mais ils transfèrent
uniquement le petit 2 à savoir la
fermeture administrative pour touvre à
l'ordre public
la maman 118 lui vise aussi à transférer
au maire le pouvoir prévue au petit 1 du
même article du code de la santé
publique à savoir la fermeture
administrative en cas de non
p des lois et des règlements et
l'amendement 119 était en fait un
amendement de repli puisqu'il vise à
restreindre le champ d'application de ce
petit 1 uniquement aurait au non respect
des règlements municipaux
merci madame lagarde enfin le 772
rectifier il est présenté par monsieur
guay merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
bon on aura débat sur débits de boisson
donnera notre avis sur les quatre
amendements avant nous nous posons une
question c'est jusqu'où va s'arrêter la
liste à la prévert on pense qu'il faut
supprimer les aligner à sur la question
de la musique parce qu'on va avoir
il faut rentrer dans le dur c'est quels
moyens après on donne au maire pour
faire respecter tout ça c'est une
question parce que je partageais la
philosophie de notre collègue michel
canevet qui a défendu le premier
amendement sur le débit de boissons
comme on fait après pour faire respecter
ce nouveau pouvoir du maire si on n'y
met pas les moyens avec la présidente
assassines ou et notes nous sommes élus
en seine saint denis il ya des questions
autour des débits de boissons mais on
peut donner le pouvoir au maire ou et
les forces de l'ordre pour l'accompagner
pour faire respecter la loi
je vous pose la question monsieur le
ministre devait avoir la police de
sécurité du quotidien à part aux
informations à la télé on les a pas vus
nous sur le terrain et les élus
municipaux et locaux non plus non mais
je dis ça parce que quand on est
habitant par exemple en seine saint
denis on a moins d'officier de police
judiciaire qu'à paris - un policier tout
court qu'à paris et après si en plus
vous arrivez à aller jusqu'à la mort
après qu'il soit condamné il faut qu'il
passe au tribunal il ya moins de juges
que partout ailleurs
donc je dis ça parce que on il faut pas
qu'on ait un débat hors sol quoi alors
on peut en voir le débat sur débits de
boissons on peut la voir et on n'est pas
fermés sur cette question on va donner
notre avis après après évidemment
monsieur leur apportant à monsieur le
ministre mais franchement ajouté
la question de la musique là dessus ça
nous paraît inopportun
donc nous proposons vraiment de
supprimer ces deux alinéas
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
alors nous passons maintenant à l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
[Rires]
oui même la présidente
s'agissant de la maman présente et
défendu par notre collègue canevet je ne
vais pas revenir sur les arguments que
j'ai déjà évoqué lors du précédent
amendement donc ce sera un avis
défavorable
s'agissant de l'art de l'amendement par
dont 212 de notre collègue cabanel je
voudrais rappeler que la loi prévoit
trois motifs de fermeture de débits de
boisson il serait donc peu cohérent de
prévoir une possibilité de prorogation
que pour l'une d'entre deux s'agissant
des amendements 118 et 119 de notre
collègue philippe dallier l'amendement
118 qui vise à donner la possibilité aux
maires de fermer des débits de boissons
non seulement pour des motifs d'ordre
public mais également en cas de non
respect de la réglementation en vigueur
ce sera un avis favorable
en revanche un avis défavorable au 119
enfin sur l'article 772 j'entends
complètement les arguments avancés par
notre collègue fabien gay à ceci près
que c'est un débat qu'on va pouvoir
avoir tout au long de ces discussions
autour des amendements sur le pouvoir
police des mers puisque c'est une
faculté et malheureusement nous ne
trancherons pas nécessairement la
question des moyens de sécurité
donc il s'agit de mettre en cohérence
ce que nous avons appelée de nos voeux
sur les pouvoirs de police des mers et
ce sera donc un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement
oui même la présidence dont ils ont fait
l'objet d'une discussion commune m'enfin
mine de rien ils ne disent pas tout à
fait tout la même chose donc on va juste
prendre un court instant pour bien
s'assurer qu'on disent tous la même
chose 489 rectifier votre amendement
même la présidente défendu par par votre
collègue
je rappelle juste qu'au final il est
déjà satisfait dans la mesure où je vous
regarde en même temps dans la mesure où
cette faculté qui est ouverte au maire
n'est qu'une faculté
le maire demande aux préfets de se voir
attribuer ce pouvoir de police
administrative ou pas donc dès lors que
c'est une liberté
je pense que le maire qui a envie de le
faire le fait est le maire qui n'a pas
envie de le faire et bah le fais pas ça
me semble la meilleure des choses est la
meilleure des garanties que l'on puisse
faire
mais vous avez raison il faut le
rappeler parce que sinon ça mais le
maire potentiellement dans une seringue
et ça c'est pas une bonne chose donc là
on garde ce principe de liberté
et en plus comme vous le savez tout cela
est conditionné dans le temps parce que
là on est chef des choses on l'a
peut-être un peu 10 ans dg enfin avec la
commission des lois en commun avec le
gouvernement on assume aussi d'aller sur
le terrain d'une forme d'expérimentation
parce que souvent on a renversé le
pouvoir de police des mers on a rarement
fait descendre de la police
administrative du niveau du préfet au
maire et dans la pratique la proximité
engagement et proximité dans le mot
proximité c'est pas que de la
décentralisation la proximité c'est
aussi de la déconcentration de pouvoir
du corps préfectoral vers le maire en
tant qu'agent de l'état donc là on a à
mon avis quelque chose qui est déjà
satisfait mais c est utile à mon avis
que de rappeler sur le 212 rectifié de
monsieur cabanel ah oui alors si c'est
intéressant
il faut garder quand même la capacité de
rouvrir je m'explique vous prenez un
arrêté pour fermer pendant deux mois
siri enfin vous ne pouvez pas reprendre
un arrêté pour fait faire quatre mois en
revanche le lieu en question pourrait
ouvrir une journée et le maire peut
refermer pendant deux mois au terme de
cette journée
juste qu'on se veut même pas journal
officiel dutil notre échange que de le
dire donc voila mais en revanche il faut
garder ce délectable les deux mois
reconductible à souhait pour le coup là
on terme d'excès de pouvoir et de
fragilité de l'acte on serait évidemment
complètement dedans mais rassurez vous
ce n'est pas deux mois
et puis ensuite c'est fini ces deux mois
et puis si on constate encore mais fort
faire le constat et c'est ce qui protège
aussi la la démarche du maire donc là
comme l'amendement précédent madame la
présidente demande de retrait si vous
même d'accord mais la précision était à
mon avis là aussi importante sur le 118
rectifié bis monsieur rapportant vous
avez émis un avis favorable ou danser
sur deux suivants 68 jeudi un avis
favorable
je n'ai malheureusement je vais mettre
un avis défavorable parce que l'enfer
est pavé de bonnes intentions
typiquement sur cet amendement je ne
fais pas un quart mais je pense qu'il
faut quand même qu'on fasse attention à
protéger nos nos collègues élus la
frontière entre polices administratives
et police judiciaire est une frontière
ténue jeu
le premier aux sénateurs d'alliés au
président allié de regarder de près son
amendement est en déplacement c'est pour
ça qu'ils ne peut pas de présenter ce
soir et assurent excusé je vous en ferai
un retour c'est compliqué de demander à
un maire de commencer à contrôler
d'autres critères que l'ordre public
droit du travail l'hygiène la
consommation de stupéfiants dans un
débit de boisson un lieu de restauration
voyez là on passe d'un schéma de police
administrative on regarde la question de
l'ordre public et uniquement de l'ordre
public comme un membre du corps
préfectoral le ferai et donc le juge
administratif bien sûr référé-liberté
référé pourquoi que c'est de pouvoir
enfin tout ce que vous connaissez et
efficient mais si vous commencez à les
chercher d'autres bases légales pour
justifier une fermeture c'est plus la
ministre hâtif c'est un début de constat
c'est un début de constats jeu
10 hier bon et là pour le coup on
revient avec le maire entend que pj mais
comme vous le savez le pgi ne peut pas
et constater et en même temps condamné
sauf pour les contraventions au code de
la route et c'est donc là je pense que
on s'achemine dans quelque chose que je
vois bien pour les raisons éminemment
locales pour lequel ont pu être
proposées mais demande de retrait parce
que je pense que là on fait pas que des
choses utiles et facile pour les élus et
avec une fragilité mon avis qui sera
vite qui sera vite démontré à la
première premier contentieux venu une
fois plus mélanger police administrative
et police judiciaire law dans nos débats
et dans nos amendements et dans nos
votes dans vos votes et moi dans mes
avis à mon avis n'est pas n'est pas une
bonne chose donc demande de retrait sur
le 119 rectifier pour le coup là
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez émis un
avis également favorable si j'ai bien
tout noté favorable défavorable
alors là je suis honnête avec vous je ne
comprends pas on rajoute la la l'aspect
visuel sur l'arrêté municipal pour le à
le restreindre mais je vois pas
l'intérêt de le restreindre pour être
avec vous puisque soit ya un trouble à
l'ordre public dans les cas concernés
par l'article
mais après je bon je dois plutôt avis
défavorable pardonnez moi mais je ne
comprends pas complètement l'opportunité
mais c'est certainement la fatigue avec
cette heure avancée
monsieur le sénateur sur vos deux
remarques
bon sur la musique ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui l'a introduit c'est la
commission on y reviendra dans les
débats là-dessus sagesse je vois bien
les conditions et les ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui introduit
mais j'ai pas dis ça je dis juste que je
j'ai ma paternité et président bah la
sienne et donc la commission répondra et
réexpliquera j'imagine ce pourquoi la
question de la musique est intervenu
dans les débats
moi je le sais mais c'est pas moi de
rapporter les travaux de la commission
par définition sur les moyens pour
appliquer votre interpellation
si j'en reste à l'amendement enfin
surtout à l'article 13
l'intérêt de la police administrative
c'est qu'elle est souple pour le maire
et que c'est une décision et qu'une
décision c'est un arrêté non mais
attendez
j'étais maire je vois bien comment ça
fonctionne donc la réalité c'est que ce
sont des décisions qui sont d'une
décision de très grande souplesse et si
vous avez un débit qui débute bresson
par exemple qui décide de rester ouverts
malgré l'arrêté
là c'est pas le maire qui engage
l'action publique
c'est le parquet lorsque vous avez un
arrêté de police administrative qui soit
préfectoral ou qu'ils soient municipales
s'il n'est pas appliquée on retombe dans
ce que vous connaissez par ailleurs en
tant que législateur sur l'application
du droit et donc par définition c'est
l'action publique qui se déclenchent
c'est le recours à la force publique le
cas échéant c'est éventuellement des
articles 40 qui peuvent être déclenchées
jeudi à ça j'ai tenu à cette ligne là
est d'ailleurs la présidente à ça si le
nom je n'ai comme partout les effectifs
sont en tension parce que vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs que les
policiers et gendarmes accompli soucier
des missions nouvelles sur le terrorisme
sur l'ordre public on l'a bien vu
donc non mais faut plus j'ai porté
l'uniforme je ne méconnais pas la
difficulté dans ces unités
non j'ai pas tout fait mais je témoigne
parce que je pense que c'est bien aussi
de le faire je dis juste seneweb votre
débat sur les moyens
ce que je dis c'est que ça ce sont des
moyens concrets juridique qui permette
d'avancer
merci monsieur le ministre je vous
propose maintenant de procéder au vote
sur ces amendements
alors avant il
toute une série d'explications de vote
nous allons commencer par monsieur du
rhin merci madame la présidente écoutez
je profiterai de ce premier amendement
mais ça aurait pu intervenir sur
d'autres pour un propos un peu général
sur sur les pointes police pour avoir
rencontré les élus et leur avoir soumis
le texte ses articles et ses intentions
ce que demandent les élus locaux
s'agissant des pouvoirs de police c'est
moins d'en avoir plus que de pouvoir
déjà correctement faire ce qu'ils ont à
faire et la question de l'effectivité de
leur pouvoir de police et centrale c'est
derrière la question du lien avec la
gendarmerie avec la police avec le
procureur la capacité à articuler
intelligemment toute cette chaîne
derrière la décision prise par les
locales et donc ce que nous disons
à l'étude de ces de ses amendements et
de cet article et de ses articles ses
faut-il vraiment donner de nouveaux
pouvoirs s'il n'y a pas de nouveaux
moyens et est faut-il vraiment généré
des espoirs en matière de pouvoirs de
police si on n'est pas en capacité de
sécuriser la capacité pour les mères
d'aller au bout des intentions qu'ils
manifestent en matière pouvoir de police
faute de quoi c'est un peu le miroir aux
alouettes
faute de quoi on peut un peu trompé son
monde faute de quoi on peut même mettre
une pression inutile sur des maires sur
lesquelles on va faire peser de
nouvelles responsabilités alors qu'ils
peinent déjà à assumer celle qui leur
incombe aujourd'hui
merci monsieur du rhin dans la série de
demandes d'explications de vote chez
monsieur guay merci madame la présidente
je partage en l'intervention de notre
collègue du rein je le dis à monsieur le
rapporteur et monsieur le ministre on a
sincèrement cette réponse vous avez
raison mais c'est pas le moment de
parler des moyens
oui mais je reprends prenons un des 4 è
pratique
demain si vous offrez cette possibilité
aux maires la population va se tourner
vers le maire et donc qu'il va prendre
un arrêté mais n'aura aucun moyen de
l'appliquer et on va créer des
disparités parce que rat des villes qui
auront les moyens parce qu'ils auront
par exemple une police municipale
importante
et puis à côté une ville qu'il n'aura
pas les moyens mais qui pas de police
municipale mais qui y compris cherche
les effectifs et je redis bon désolé en
as tropisme mais dans le 93
on a déjà pas assez de moyens dans la
police pour assurer les missions
régaliennes
alors quand c'est sur la fermeture des
débits de boisson et qui est une réalité
par exemple qui peuvent être déduits
sens très forte pour les populations
plusieurs jours par semaine donc on va
créer de l'espoir et en fit au final on
ne réglera rien et ce sont les élus
locaux qui vont se retrouver face à
cette situation
donc franchement on votera donc
l'amendement présenté par madame l'état
ses collègues puis évidemment le note
sur la suppression de ces alinéas qui
n'apportent en vérité qu'une vraie
fausse enfin une fausse une fausse
solution
merci monsieur gay la parole et à
monsieur cabanel madame la présidence
par rapport aux explications que dit le
ministre donc je retire mon amendement
de 5 212
merci monsieur cabanel monsieur cannes v
nous passons maintenant aux 489 rectifié
bis vous le retirer je vous remercie le
212 donc ce monsieur kavanagh les
retirer le 118 rectifié bis madame
lagarde
alors je vais maintenir le 118 rectifié
bis et je vais retirer du coup s'il est
voté je retirerais le 119 notamment
parce qu'en fait le 119 visé à dire que
si jamais on considérait que le maire
n'était pas en capacité de pouvoir juger
de l'ensemble des lois et règlements
donc ce que j'ai bien compris dans votre
exposé monsieur le ministre on lui
autoriser quand même enfin lui donner la
capacité de pouvoir gérer les arrêtés
municipaux ce qui est son pouvoir
puisqu'il les a écrits et entre
guillemets fait voter par son conseil
municipal dont c'était l'objet de la 219
arriver peut-être mal écrit donc on peut
peut-être laissé le 118 dans la navette
est comme ça vous pourrez reprendre
l'idée du 119 c'est ça qui posait
problème ou voilà donc je laisse le 118
qu'il a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission
alors merci madame l'avare donc jeu
mais oh vous à l'amendement 118 rectifié
bis qui a donc un avis favorable de la
commission et une demande de retrait du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement est adopté
donc le suivant est retiré et le 772
rectifier donc je procède au vote sur
cet amendement qui a un avis défavorable
de la commission mais une sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
il reste deux amendements avant de
conclure peut-être on termine cette
partie vous êtes d'accord
allez on continue on va vite monsieur
leroy pour le 576 rectifié bis je vais
aller très vite madame la présidente
monsieur mini spicher collègue ben
écoutez ça rentre dans le même état
d'esprit l'objet de mon abonnement et
autorisé le maire à réglementer les
ouvertures de commerces de nuit lorsque
le fonctionnement
ces établissements qu'on promet le
bonheur de latran qui la tranquillité et
la quiétude publique
merci chers collègues avis de la
commission
oui il nous paraît totalement satisfait
et je rappelle même par ailleurs que
depuis 2009 le maire peut également
interdire la vente d'alcool à emporter
sur certaines zones entre 22h et 8h du
matin ceux qui visent entre autres les
épiceries de nuit
donc c'est une demande de retrait tim
smith fait ma vie mais ma vie ma
présidente monsieur le sénateur vous le
retirer il est retiré le 880 94
rectifier il est présenté par monsieur
chaize
enfin la présidente ministre
d'amendements que je vous présente vise
à permettre à la police municipale
d'intervenir sur demande des
propriétaires ou des exploitants de
terrains dès lors que ces derniers
seront occupés par des personnes qui ne
respectent pas les principes d'accès de
libre circulation des personnes
autorisées de sécurité de sûreté et de
tranquillité des lieux
actuellement le code de la sécurité
intérieure permet de faire appel à la
police municipale pour les squats dans
des immeubles d'habitation l'objet de
l'amendement et de l'étendre aux
terrains donc d'exploitation merci
monsieur chaize monsieur le rapporteur
avis de la commission
oui cet amendement dont quittant
autoriser les agents de police
municipale a procédé à l'évacuation
d'office d'un terrain privé sur simple
demande du
propriétaire si on peut comprendre
l'objet il est évident que cette
disposition aurait principalement
vocation à être appliquées dans la
pratique à la rencontre des occupations
illicites des gens du voyage
on peut comprendre encore une fois la la
portée toutefois à moins qu'elle n'ait
été autorisée par un juge l'évacuation
d'une occupation illicite d'un terrain
public comme privé constitue une mesure
de police administrative et doit à ce
titre être entouré d'un certain nombre
de garanties destinées en assurer la
proportionnalité c'est ainsi que
l'évacuation d'office des campements
illicites ne peut être mises en oeuvre
qu'à l'issue d'une procédure encadrée
par le législateur après mise en demeure
par le préfet et garantissant le droit
au recours effectif enfin au delà de ces
difficultés juridiques que nous n'avons
pas jugé souhaitable de confier aux
seuls agents de police municipale sans
appui de la police ou de la gendarmerie
le soin de procéder à des évacuations
d'office il ne serait pas à notre sens
opportun de permettre à ses agents que
ce soit qui ne sont pas dans ni formés
ni équipés à cet effet de procéder seul
à ce type de mesures coercitives ce sera
donc un avis défavorable
merci monsieur leur apportant même avis
même avis mais le président alors le
monsieur ben asher demande la parole
[Musique]
là là dessus la présidente monsieur le
ministre c'est quand même un vrai sujet
moi j'entends bien la police municipale
pour déloger les gens du voyage c'est
sans doute pas la bonne solution
on va encore venir pour la sécurité de
tous simplement il ya un vrai sujet et
vous pouvez pas l'ignorer
donc moi je ce que j'aimerais monsieur
le ministre c'est vous preniez
l'engagement à défaut que ce soit
traitée ici dans cet hémicycle que vous
preniez le temps de gérer le sujet à
l'assemblée nationale merci monsieur ma
chère madame chilin j'ai demandé la
parole ministre j'aimerais bien aussi
qu'on se penche sur ce sujet parce que
on était aussi sur le fait accompli
il ya quelques week-ends une rave party
200 jeunes sur un terrain privé ou la
police n'a pas pu évacuer et jusqu'il ya
vingt communes impactées la musique
était tellement forte
il se mettait même eux-mêmes en danger
donc un moment donné il faudra trouver
des solutions pour aussi sécuriser les
jeunes qui vont sur des terrains privés
mais voilà c'est parmi d'autres sujets
merci chers collègues je vais maintenant
mettre aux voix cet amendement s'il n'y
a plus de demandes d'explications de
vote avec un avis défavorable de la
commission monsieur chaize je vais me
retirer ma présente mais en insistant
sur le fait qu' effectivement je pense
qu'il faudra qu'on revient sur ce point
notamment qu'entre les terrains sont
deux multipropriétaires et on à la
difficulté de trouver le propriétaire
lui-même le propriétaire ne peut pas
faire la démarche et il faut que le
maire puisse se substituer à l'ensemble
des propriétaires pour maintenir l'ordre
bon je retire mais avec une demande
romande express de revenir sur ce sujet
très rapidement merci monsieur chaize
cet amendement est donc retiré
je mets aux voix l'article 13 qui pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
voilà pour ce temps fort de l'examen du
projet de loi engagement et proximité ce
texte sur le statut de l'élu que les
sénateurs débattent encore toute cette
semaine il fera l'objet la semaine
prochaine d'un vote solennel mardi
prochain
exactement c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite c'est allons plus loin
avec rebecca fitoussi qui revient sur
cette polémique qui déchire la classe
politique
cette polémique sur le port du voile
très bonne soirée à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]